Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie fühlst du dich heute?
Ich würde mich besser fühlen, wenn ich das Buch nicht gelesen hätte.
Oh wei, das klingt düster. Ja, also du findest, das Buch war nicht zuträglich, sondern abträglich. Es hat dir was weggenommen.
Ja.
Mehr als nur die Zeit fürs Lesen oder?
Es hat mich Nerven gekostet. Ah ja. Ich hab auch nicht den Eindruck, dass ich jetzt mehr weiß. Ich hab ein paar Literaturanregungen bekommen, den ich nachgehen will, denn wir sagen das gleich, Eva Illus bezieht sich sehr stark auf Literatur aus den vergangenen Jahrhunderten, aus dem westlichen Literaturkanon. Und da sind natürlich immer ein paar Werke, die man nicht kennt, noch nie von gehört hat. Und da dachte ich dann bei manchem, ah ja, das müsste man eigentlich mal lesen.
Ja, hat so ein bisschen ein Lesezeichen-Vibes von Sloterdijk.
Ja, aber Sloterdijk ist ein großer Erzähler, sie ist es nicht. Sie versucht ja Folgendes, also versuchen wir erstmal, ich will jetzt ja nicht gleich in die Folgen gehen, sondern werde das nach und nach hier entfalten. Versuchen wir erstmal zu sagen, worum es ihr geht. Das Buch heißt Explosive Moderne, das heißt also wir leben in der Moderne, aber da explodierte etwas und das hat zu tun mit unseren Emotionen. Eva Illus ist Soziologin, die sich mit Gefühlswelten schon immer auseinandersetzte, mit den Immodities, also wie Gefühle zu wahren werden im Kapitalismus zum Beispiel, wie wir unsere Liebe, unseren Sex organisieren, das waren die großen Themen, wie wir Romantik konsumieren. All das ist in vielen Büchern von Eva Illus anzutreffen. Sie sagt sich jetzt, irgendetwas hat sich verändert, die Intensität der Gefühle ist stärker geworden. Eine Gefühlswelt zeigt sie, die dazu führen kann, dass eigentlich die Versprechen, die die Moderne hat, explodieren bzw. dass sie enttäuscht werden, dass ein zu großer Stolz entsteht, dass Eifersucht und Neid die Menschen umtreibt. Sie verbindet das immer stark auch mit modernem Konsum, mit Kapitalismus, aber in Abstrichen, also da müssen wir auch noch drüber reden. Jedenfalls will sie uns jetzt anhand von verschiedenen Gefühlen zeigen, wo wir in der Moderne standen und stehen gerade. Ich glaube allerdings, dass sie hier ein Sammelsurium präsentiert zu dem jeweiligen Gefühl. Also es ist, ich will es mal so sagen, wir haben ja über Verlust geredet, oder sind ja viele im Bilde, wie wir über Verlust von Andreas Reckwitz geredet haben. Ich habe hier den Eindruck, es ist ganz ähnlich wie bei Reckwitz, nur hat sie nicht einen einzigen Begriff nur, den sie dann durchdekliniert, sondern sie hat etwa zehn Begriffe, Scham, Stolz, Neid und so weiter. Und zeigt dann anhand von literarischen Beispielen, was Neid zum Beispiel bedeutet, wie er dann zu schlimmen Taten führen kann, wie Neid in der Literatur geschildert ist, welche Rolle Neid heute spielt. Sie verweist sehr häufig dann auf ein paar Studien, die zum Beispiel über Chancenungleichheit berichten. Sie verweist natürlich auf eine Trump-Präsidentschaft, auf gewisse Fake-News-Produktionen und so etwas. Sie verknüpft also dann manchmal munter Othello mit Elon Musk und weiß ich nicht wem. Aber es bleibt dann doch so, dass sie eigentlich sehr assoziativ da durchgeht. Es ist ein bisschen so, wie wenn Professoren, die nicht mehr so gerne selbst schreiben, den studentischen Mitarbeitern sagen, such mir mal was raus zum Thema Neid, Eifersucht in der Literatur und dann stellt man das so ja etwas salopp und nett geschrieben zusammen. Ich fand das schon an sich eine ja nicht der Soziologie würdige Vorgehensweise, sondern hatte hier eher den Eindruck, dass ich so ein bisschen mal eingeführt werde in abendländisches Denken zu ein paar Sünden und Lastern.
Ja, ich verstehe was du meinst und habe ja auch im Vorspann eben schon angedeutet, ja es gibt größeres, gerade im politischen Denken. Irgendwer kommt mit so einer Idee des Leviathan, irgendwer kommt mit der Idee des Gesellschaftsvertrags, irgendwer bezieht sich immer auf das Grundgesetz, wie auch immer, und daraus abgeleidet und ich würde jetzt eben sagen zunehmend aus so einer Verlegenheit daraus, wird da so ein deklarativer Charakter und irgendwie stellt man doch fest, nee so richtig hat das mit mir jetzt nichts zu tun, was ich da gerade in der Weihnachtsansprache gehört hab. Oder achja die Koalition hat jetzt heute sich auf das und das verständigt. Okay, also wenn dann noch mal irgendeiner dieser neuen Podcaster, Gordon Rypinski oder Robin Alexander, mir die interaktive Geschichte dieser Aushandlung erzählt, es ist noch so ein bisschen interessant, aber eigentlich hab ich jetzt nicht, ich fühl mich nicht befangen von diesem Thema, dass mir da als das Entscheidende und dann weichen die Journalisten irgendwie aus und sagen, ach es ist ja auch nicht so wichtig, worauf man sich geeinigt hat, sondern dass man sich geeinigt hat, die Demokratie funktioniert noch und so weiter. Also alles, was wir bisher so kritisieren und daraus erwächst ja bei mir zumindest der Wunsch, dass der ein oder andere mal einen mutigen Schritt wagt und sagt, ich kenne die Grundbegriffe und ich weiß, worauf sich alle beziehen, aber das ist mir jetzt eigentlich auch egal. Ich will es mal wieder ein bisschen interessant gestalten. Wir haben ja eh nur so eine Approximationshoffnung an so eine Wirklichkeit. Also wir können uns ja immer nur annähern. Am Ende ist immer alles abhängig von wer spricht, wer beobachtet, wer leidet hier, wer erklärt sich irgendwie zum Opfer oder ich habe Angst, ich habe Recht und lauter so Zeug. Und auf der einen Seite haben wir ja so ein Gefühl dafür, dass Trump alleine dadurch, dass dieses Präsidentenamt so mega begehrt ist, einen großen Erfolg eingefahren hat. Also er hat etwas geschafft, was sich sehr viele in Amerika wünschen, Präsident zu werden, aber es haben eben die anderen alle nicht geschafft und er hat es geschafft. Und wir wundern uns zum wiederholten Male über die Methode. Und wir wollen auch nicht so richtig wahrhaben, dass wenn Mark Zuckerberg jetzt einfach sagt, ah, Scheiß auf die Realität und Scheiß auf das Gerede, ich kapituliere, ich unterwerfe mich, der Hauptsache mein Business floriert. Und wenn die Leute nur noch AI-generierten Scheiß haben wollen, dann kriegen sie den halt. Wenn dann jemand eine Community-Note drunter schreiben will, okay. Also sozusagen die totale Abwendung von allem, was uns bisher nicht nur wichtig, sondern eben auch so ein bisschen heilig war. So und Eva Iluz hat sich für mich auch ein bisschen unverständlich. Ich denke mir, sie ist auch über den 7. Oktober so ein bisschen politisiert worden, also mehr als vorher, dass sie da so ein Schwenk zu, ach jetzt haben die mich eh schon immer angefragt, ob ich das mal kommentieren kann, weil ich bin ja eine Israelin und eine Soziologin und wir haben ein mehr als politisches Problem. So, könnt ihr auch mal darüber schreiben. Also legt sie uns sozusagen einen Versuch vor. Anders als Reckwitz, der uns einfach erklärt hat, was Verlust bedeutet. Blinde Flecken waren ihm egal, Ansprüche des Publikums auch. Also wir hatten ja Fragen zum Grundbegriff, die hat uns nicht beantwortet. Stattdessen so eine Kartografie nach Max Weber Manier, so Paragraph 3578 und jetzt kommen noch ihr drei Zeilen zu, Verlust in Familie bei Tod, Tochter oder sowas.
Sie neigt mitunter auch dazu, dass sie sagt, es gibt vier Kategorien von, und dann denke ich mir, naja, vielleicht gibt es aber auch fünf Kategorien von Neid.
Also sie hat ein Gerüst, dass sie einfach, sagen wir mal eine neuen Felder-Tafel, die sie einfach durchgeht. Aber für mich steht doch jeder Text so ein bisschen für sich und vor allem vor diesen neuen Emotionen Hoffnung, Enttäuschung, Neid, Zorn, Furcht, Nostalgie, Scham und Stolz, Eifersucht und Liebe. Steht eben ein Textteil, auf den ungefähr fast so die Hälfte meiner Notizen druht, weil ich das spektakulär finde.
Interessanterweise, und dann liefert sie noch das, damit das Buch voll wird.
Ja, ich muss jetzt auch nicht.
Ich will aber vielleicht, weil jetzt nicht tatsächlich zwischen uns Unheiligkeit in gewissen Diagnosen herrscht, sondern in der Art, wie das Buch dann verfasst ist. Zunächst mal wollen wir ja beide wohl glaube ich darauf hinaus, dass man nicht mehr mit alten Grundbegriffen weiterkommt, beziehungsweise, dass man vielleicht überlegen muss, dass ein Sieg von Trump vor allem damit zu tun haben, dass Leute eifersüchtig sind. Würde man zum Beispiel damit weiterkommen. Und das ist gar nicht schlecht, so zu denken. Kommt man immer mit dem rein ökonomischen Argument weiter. Wir können uns Reallohnentwicklung und sowas ansehen und die erklären auch Dinge. Wir haben ja Isabella Weber hier schon mehrmals thematisiert. Aber wir würden auch sagen, es gibt so ein Gefühl oder mehrere Gefühle, die da sind, dass zum Beispiel Leute gerne rumhassen wollen, wenn sie die Grünen sehen. Und das hat dann nicht mehr mit einer realen Kritik zu tun, die ich jetzt äußere, zum Beispiel an Rüstungsvorhaben von Habeck oder die man äußern kann an Chipfabriken, die vielleicht ein bisschen unnötig sind, die zu subventionieren. Sondern es ist einfach so, ja die Grünen, das machen die jetzt wieder und das ist typisch und da kommen wir wieder in die Diktatur. Und diese Art ist ja zu sprechen losgelöst von Fakten, aber aufgeladen mit Emotionen. Und zu sagen, ich schaue mir diese politischen Emotionen an, weil die es eigentlich sind, die so vieles bewegen, ist sehr klug. Ich meine, es gab auch schon, das bei Mattes & Sals erschien vor ein paar Jahren eine Analyse, wie eigentlich bei der französischen Revolution die Politisierung der Gefühle stattfand. Wie auch dann als die Neuen an der Macht waren, sie versuchten, die Gefühle in eine Richtung zu kanalisieren. Das heißt also, eine Gefühlspolitik scheint mir sehr wichtig zu sein. Wir haben ja auch mehrmals darüber geredet, dass es eben nicht deliberative Demokratie sein kann, in dem Sinne, dass jetzt alle einfach mal so Argumente austauschen, dann wird man sich schon im Kompromiss einig werden, sondern es sind ganz starke Gefühle da, von denen wir ja auch immer wieder selbst berichtet haben. Ich hab ja schon mal gesagt, wenn eine gewisse Ansprache stattfindet und die kommt manchmal von den Grünen oder jetzt wenn zum Beispiel Maity mir sagt, warum ich eine Maske tragen soll, dann ist das eine Art der Ansprache, die sie wählt, bei der ich inhaltlich absolut wahrscheinlich d'accord bin, aber die Ansprache lässt mich die Maske runterreißen, sagen ne, ich bin kein Kind, ich will nicht so, dass mit mir geredet wird, ich laufe jetzt lieber ohne Maske, hol mir eine Krippe, bevor ich mich so ansprechen lasse. Und da wird also sehr viele Emotionen freigesetzt. Und das erleben wir natürlich überall. Deswegen glaube ich, ist der Fokus auf Gefühle wichtig, ich glaube nur, dass sie nicht die geeignete Autorin dafür ist.
Also will es nicht zu albern klingen, aber bei Gesprächen über die Gefühle, insbesondere in so Männer Podcasts wie unseren, muss man grundsätzlich erstmal so angehen mit, Hauptsache es wird über Gefühle gesprochen, egal wer. Und Eva Iluis ist nicht die Schlechteste.
Aber sie ist nicht, das ist kein gutes Buch.
Wir können ja mal einsteigen, wir gehen mal rein, denn ich finde auch das Problem, um das sich dieses Buch zum Beispiel dreht, ist, um, kann man jetzt in unendlichen Beispielen das verplausibilisieren, ich will es an einem machen, wenn Dunja Hayali in den öffentlich-rechtlichen Abendnachrichten über die AfD spricht, treibt sie der AfD die Zuschauer in die Arme. Obwohl sie doch inhaltlich ganz anderes sagt und das aus dem Transkript auch nicht ihr vorzuwerfen ist. Aber es passiert trotzdem, weil Gefühle eine Rolle spielen. Und mit Gefühle sind jetzt nicht, ach Gefühle gemeint, sondern das, was je nach Bandbreite des Mediums zu Hause ankommt. So und das Fernsehen hat eine gewisse Bandbreite für Inhalte und Fakten und das ist die manifeste Seite und dann gibt es halt diese latente Seite. Menschen sitzen auch davor und fühlen einfach etwas und ich hab ja schon häufiger, vielleicht erwähne ich es jetzt nochmal für einen, die sich darüber langweilen, aber ich halte das für relativ wichtig gerade jetzt. Wenn Leute den Staat scheiße finden, weil er ihnen irgendeine Einkommenssteuer nicht zurückerstattet hat oder was auch immer und die stellen dann fest, dass dieser Staat von Frank-Walter Steinmeier repräsentiert wird, deren Kampf gegen Antisemitismus führt, dann wählen sie die Einflugschneiße Antisemitismus, um den Staat eins auszuwischen. Wenn der Staat mit anderen Themen kommt wie Impfpflicht, dann sagen sie, der Staat hat noch nie was für mich gemacht, wieso soll ich jetzt was für den Staat tun? Ich bin entschieden gegen die Impfpflicht. Also diese Kontra-Intuitive auf innertlicher und populistisch so leicht ausbeutbare Situation ist einfach unbeschrieben. Da haben wir keine Reflektion, darüber redet kein Journalist, weder in irgendwelchen Gesprächen intern noch in irgendwelchen Supervisions-Kolokvien mit irgendwelchen akademischen Zusammenhängen, wie auch immer. Also das ist einfach unbestelltes Feld. So und dieses Buch steigt aber da ein, in diese Wirkungsmechanismen. Und gleich zu Beginn sagt sie, also wenn sie so die Themesetzung dann erklärt, Gefühle sind sehr viel wirksamer und bedeutsamer und vor allem sehr viel früher und schneller als das, über das wir sonst zu reden. Also eine Argumentation, ja das kann schon mal eine dreiviertel Stunde dauern, bis der Groschen fällt. Bei einem Gefühl nicht. So und die Wahlentscheidung wird nochmal von Leuten getroffen, die alle fühlen. Die sind zwar auch empfänglich für innerliche Argumentation, aber irgendwann ist mal Feierabend. So und typischerweise sind die politischen Nachrichten, 20 Uhr, Tagesschau, das ist zum Feierabendzeit. Und dann erwartet man immer, dass alle irgendwie so stramm wie im Klassenraum vorm Fernseher sitzen und sozusagen empfangen, was der Lehrer sagt. Nein, sie sind eigentlich im 2015-Modus. So und dann schiebt man da die Tagesschau rein und wundert sich jetzt, ach die Leute fühlen da viel mehr als und so weiter. Also allein diese kleinen Verweise, jeder hat schon mal die Erfahrung gemacht, dass Gefühle überwältigen. Ja, das tun sie halt. Man ist eine schlechte Nachricht davon entfernt, dass die ganze Welt zusammenbrechen kann. So und man kriegt dann einen kleinen inhaltlichen Fakt mitgeteilt. Irgendwer ist verunglückt, irgendwas hat nicht geklappt, wie auch immer, zack, greifen da Gefühle und haben dich vielleicht über Jahre im Griff und so nach Jahrzehnten stellt dann irgendwer fest, sollte man mal aufarbeiten. So und dann ist aber schon das halbe Leben vergangen. Ja, bevor man wieder mal, ach ja Inhalte gibt es ja auch noch, wir könnten ja auch mal und so. Nein, nein, da ist man dann einfach...
Diese Unmittelbarkeit, die ja auch das Fernsehen einem gibt, es ist ja eben nicht der Text, den ich lese. Ja, da wird schon mal mehr Abstraktion eingefordert. Aber ich erinnere mich an Abende bei meiner Großmutter, Gott hab sie selig. Es lief die Tagesschau und meine Großmutter, die nicht besonders politisch war, kommentierte das aber eigentlich immer nur mit Worten wie diese alte Esel oder diese dumme Kuh. Genau. Damit war das für die gegessen. Das war natürlich auch schön, wenn man sich danach freute, dass Hansi Hinterseher kommt, eigentlich beneidenswert. Aber für sie war das natürlich gefühlsfern.
Also Gefühle sind wirksamer, bedeutsamer, sie sind früher und schneller. Sie haben sozusagen Vorteile gegenüber anderen Inhalten, medialer oder zwischenmenschlicher Kommunikation. Sie haben oder sie bedeuten eine tiefe Verstrickung in die Gegenwart. Also sie fesseln dich geradezu an die Gegenwart. Geschichte wird nur noch durch diesen Gefühlsfokus vergegenwärtigt. Es wird einfach aussortiert, verdrängt, wie auch immer. Also diese Vergegenwärtigung, dieses Ausblenden von Geschichte und Zukunft und dieses rasante Wirken, also dieses frühzeitige, bevor überhaupt irgendjemand den Mund aufmacht, nur eine Argumentation. Kann man schon angepisst sein von irgendwas und dann hilft es auch nicht mehr, eine Argumentation zu folgen.
Und Gefühle sind liminal. Sie schreibt, der Neid auf meine Nachbarin, die Furcht vor dem Fremden oder der Nationalstolz sind Weisen, die Schwelle zwischen meinem Selbst und der Welt zu errichten, auszuhandeln und aufrechtzuhalten. Durch Gefühle internalisieren wir die äußere Welt und externalisieren wir unsere innere Welt, und zwar fortwährend und nahtlos.
Genau. Und da sind wir natürlich ganz nah an so sozio-logischen Argumentationen. Da muss man jetzt nicht nur die Systemtheorie nennen, sondern sobald jemand sagt, Organisation hat man so innen und außen. Und in dem Falle ist es eben für eine Soziologin recht ungewöhnlich, aber der Mensch und sein Äußeres, die psychische und die kommunikative Ebene, die sind in so einer zirkulären Verschränkung. Dieses Liminal, finde ich schon mal, hat einen Grundbegriff Charakter sozusagen.
Ja, das ist diese Schwelle, von der wir sofort auch wissen, was gemeint ist.
Also da finden einfach Irritationen statt. Was in der Welt passiert, hat Einfluss auf mich. Was in mir passiert, hat Einfluss auf die Welt. Aber so richtig kann man die Verbindung da nicht benennen, weshalb sie auch in so einen Begriff wie Liminal oder wie sie es gerade gesagt hat ausweicht. Sie nennt ja da schon Literatur. Also der Blade Runner wird genannt von Philip Dix. Philip Roth wird genannt, der im Roman Indignation befehlt, sei du größer als deine Gefühle. Du wirst von deinen Gefühlen hinweggeschwemmt, also ins Meer gespült. Gefühle können das größte Problem des Lebens sein. Schrecklichste Streiche werden da gespielt. Also so in diesem Tenor das aufzuhängen, finde ich nicht verkehrt. Denn ja, wir können immer über Habecks Heizung und so weiter, aber das Habeck geht so sehr auf Mensch bleiben, sich zeigen, sein Antlitz in schönster Manier und so.
Macht mich auch wahnsinnig wütend.
Ja, genau, das macht uns wahnsinnig wütend, was ja bedeutet, es führt zu Gefühlsregeln. Wir sind vielleicht nicht das Publikum, so vielleicht sind es andere, auf die das abzielt. Also je nachdem, es ist eine Strategie, die auf jeden Fall zu Emotionalisierung führt. In einer rein politischen Sphäre, da geht es darum, wer wird nächster Kanzler, wer stellt eine Regierung?
Wie gesagt, ich will gar nicht diese Grunddiagnose in Frage stellen und auch die Grundthese nicht. Gefühle scheinen sehr wichtig zu sein, um die heutige Welt zu verstehen. Nur frage ich mich, ob dann, und das frage ich als jemand, der Germanistik studiert hat, die Literatur die beste Quelle ist, um Gefühle, die heute vorherrschend sind, zu beschreiben. Kann ich einen Rückgriff nehmen auf die Literatur? Kann sagen, Othello war eifersüchtig und Eifersucht gestaltet sich folgendermaßen aus. Ja, aber hilft mir das wirklich weiter, wenn ich die Literatur als meine hauptsächliche Quelle ansehe, wenn ich die explosive Moderne beschreiben will. Und dann würde ich sagen nein und ich wundere mich, dass du da nicht völlig empört bist darüber. Denn für mich ist das ja dann immer noch so im Vertrauten jetzt hier mich mit diesen ganz literarischen Gebühren nochmal beschäftigen. Aber du bist ja jemand, der immer wieder sagt, na jetzt bitte lasst auch mal im Buch das 200 Jahre altes manchmal zugeklappt, um mal zu gucken, was ist gerade in den Nachrichten los. Und sie verweigert sich dem ja bis auf dann so ein paar Aspekte, wo sie das so durchgeht und sagt ja das hat in der Obama-Rede dann so und so geklungen. Sie verweigert sich ja eigentlich dem, was heute passiert völlig und geht immer wieder auf diese alte Literatur zurück, die natürlich einen zeitlosen Charakter hat. Und da ist aber das Ding, sie beschreibt hier in der Literatur sehr viele zeitlose Phänomene und erarbeitet die heraus, will aber zugleich etwas sagen zu unserer modernen, die sich jetzt anders gestaltet. Sie schreibt ja auf Seite 24. Selbst wenn keine der hier behandelten Emotionen an und für sich modern ist, wurden sie noch nie zuvor in so starkem Maße von Institutionen wie dem Konsumentenmarkt, der demokratischen Staatsbürgerschaft, dem Privatleben, der ökonomischen Ungleichheit und der wirtschaftlichen Dominanz getriggert. Noch nie in der Geschichte haben ökonomische, kulturelle und politische Institutionen so systematisch Gefühle hervorgerufen. Weiß ja auch nicht, ob das stimmt, ob das noch nie so war. Wo steht das? Wie kann ich das messen? Wie alt zum Beispiel das Gefühl des Neids auch sein mag, nie war es derart strukturell in die Konsumgesellschaft eingebettet wie heute. Dasselbe gilt für den Zorn, der durch eine hochentwickelte Parteipolitik, parteischen Nachrichten immer reichweichend stärkere ideologische Plattformen und die Sozialmedien mit ihren Blasen zirkuliert. Okay, das sagt mir aber dann doch, wenn dem so ist, dass ich mir die Plattformen ansehen muss, die parteischen Nachrichten mir die strukturelle Ungleichheit ansehen muss und dann kann ich nur inspirativ nochmal bei Shakespeare nachlesen oder bei Hofmannsthal oder wem sie da hatte. Joseph Roth hat sie ja viel, ja. Dann kann ich das da nochmal nachlesen, inspirativ, mir vielleicht damit nochmal Begriffe klar machen. Aber dann müsste ich doch mein Ziel und jetzt, da möchte ich schon sagen, dann muss man so vorgehen, wie Steffen Mauer und Co. bei den Triggerpunkten mit den Leuten reden, diese Gefühle abfragen, was jetzt bei Triggerpunkte zum Teil ja auch gemacht wurde. Da ging es ja auch schon stark um Gefühle. Und dann schauen, was mache ich da als Soziologin mit. Wenn ich aber jetzt sage, ich gehe in die alte Literatur und zeige daran auf, wie viele Facetten der Zorn haben kann, dann würde ich sagen, dann ist das möglicherweise noch eine gute Shakespeare-Exegese, es ist aber keine wirkliche Beobachtung der Gegenwart.
Also ich glaube, Ihr Wunsch ist so ein bisschen anders gelagert. Allerdings bin ich da auch selber befangen durch mein eigenes Buch. Das heißt, ich mache jetzt gleich mal einen kleinen Argumentationsbogen, der darauf hinausläuft, dass ich aus meinem eigenen Buch kurz vorlesen werde.
Ach so, jetzt heißt das da Exklusiv-Lesung.
Sozusagen, genau. Also Philip Roth, Philip Dix, Thomas Mann werden ja gleich am Anfang genannt. Alle haben natürlich über Gefühle gesprochen. Also bei Blade Runner ist Fühlen das Merkmal der Menschlichkeit, weshalb man allen, denen man begegnet, ein Empathietest unterzieht, um Mensch und Maschine wieder zu unterscheiden. Thomas Mann treibt das dann, wie sie schreibt, auf die Spitze. Mensch ist göttlich, sofern er fühlt. Denn, also damit werden wir erst mal alle zu göttlichen Wesen erklärt, ist ja auch ganz schön, aber Gefühle irren sich nie. Sei dir deiner Gefühle bewusst. Also wir haben so ein Authentizitäts-Ding heute irgendwie drin, das wir immer wieder betonen, denn das wahrhaft sinnerfüllte Leben wird nur erreicht, indem wir emotionale Authentizität zum Echtheitssiegel für unsere geistige Gesundheit und unser Glücksempfinden machen. Also werde glücklich, damit auch andere glücklich werden können. Das Glück der Welt hängt davon an, dass du reflektiert bist, dir bewusst bist über, ja was eigentlich, ist dann so die Frage. Dein Gefühlszustand, dein Gemütszustand, wie auch immer. Wir haben heute eine Mammutindustrie der psychologischen Beratung, die sich genau um dieses Problem dreht. So und jetzt schreibt sie, weshalb sie das als politischen Fokus oder warum sie da so einen politischen Fokus jetzt auf Gefühle legen will. Diese beiden gängigen Auffassungen von Gefühlen, nämlich dass sie entweder ein Irrtum sind, an den man so therapeutisch rumdoktern muss oder dass sie uns zur Wahrheit führen. Das möchte sie ausblenden. Stattdessen setze ich an der Prämisse an, dass unsere Emotionen stilisierte Momente des Seins sind. Momente, in denen wir uns in einer bestimmten Art und Weise auf eine Situation einlassen. Und das ist ja eigentlich, ich finde es so schon super naheliegend, aber ich finde es gut, dass sie es auch nochmal so sagt. Diese Verweise auf Literatur. Diese Literatur ist eben nicht einfach nur ausgedachte Wirklichkeit, sondern sie ist verdichtete Wirklichkeit. Genau. Sie manifestiert mit diesem Wahrhaftigkeitsanspruch von Ulrich Mattes, den wir da im Podcast gehört haben. Da sagt, ne ne, das Schauspiel ist nicht die Lüge oder das Vorspielen oder wie auch immer, also das zu tun als ob, sondern das zu tun als ob mit dem Anspruch, noch näher an die Wahrheit, Wahrhaftigkeit heranzukommen, als wenn man einfach nur so beiläufig Realität erlebt. Also man geht gezielt hin, guckt sich eine stilistisch kondensierte Situation an, die dann möglichst wahrhaftig, und deswegen ist mir auch wichtig, dass in Europa echte Menschen sind und ich nicht nur im Kino bin und so, dass das halt dort gerade so durchgespielt wird. Also eine Gegenwärtigung einer Erinnerung durch ein lebendiges Schauspiel.
Das Kino kann ja auch wahrhaftig sein und wir haben ja jetzt hier nur Text und das kann auch wahrhaftig sein. Also es geht hier darum zwischen Wahrheit und Wahrhaftigkeit zu unterscheiden. Also Wahrheit ist natürlich die, dass es den Othello von Shakespeare nicht gab, aber trotzdem kann die Geschichte wahrhaftig sein. Sie hat auch eine innere Lausibilität und all das.
Und damit ist sie ein Artefakt unserer, ich sag jetzt mal Menschlichkeit, wo wir ansonsten als Sachbuchleser, der ich ja nun bin, ich hab ja gesagt ich lese keinen Roman und so, ich will dann immer wissen, was geschah, in welchem Ablauf, wie auch immer. Ich will sozusagen nicht diesen Wahrhaftigkeitsanspruch, sondern ich will diesen Wahrheitsanspruch. Also die Fakten müssen stimmen, die Grammatik muss bitte der Sehgewohnheit entsprechen.
Und jetzt kommt sie mit der Literatur und macht aber doch einfach nur eine Rundreise durch wahllos zusammengewürfelte Literatur. Also ich finde zum Beispiel, dass sie in ihrer Auswahl völlig beliebig ist. Also das könnten auch 15 andere Autoren sein, auf die sie stützt. Die kennt sie halt jetzt gerade, die nimmt sie aus irgendeinem Grunde, den sie nicht klarmacht. Sie sagt auch, dass sie da jetzt nicht einen Überblick geben will, aber sie sucht halt sporadisch das Haus, was sie gerne liest und hat da ihre Überlegungen zu. Und was ich einfach so unlauter an diesem Anliegen finde, ist, dass die Literaturwissenschaft sich und gerade im englischsprachigen Bereich sich seit bestimmt 15, wenn nicht 20 Jahren mit Affekten und Literatur auseinandersetzt, mit Emotionen und Literatur auseinandersetzt. Man hat dort in der Literaturwissenschaft schon lange einen emotional turn. Und sie, die sich kaum hier auf Literaturwissenschaften bezieht, sondern nur auf diese Primärtexte, kommt jetzt mit einigen originellen, manchen banalen Erläuterungen zu diesen literarischen Texten und glaubt dadurch jetzt etwas Größeres zu unserer Moderne zu sagen. Ich würde mal die Behauptung aufstellen, dass wenn dieses Buch abgeliefert worden wäre von einer unbekannten Person, wäre es nicht gedruckt worden. Dann hätte man nämlich genau darauf verwiesen, Entschuldigen Sie, wir machen seit 20 Jahren der Literaturwissenschaften, warum kommen Sie jetzt damit an und schreiben uns noch mal auf 15 Seiten zusammen, was Othello meinte oder was bei Wagner's Tristan steht. Das sind ja eigentlich so Sachen, dass sie einzelne Passagen sich rausnimmt und dann versucht sie so ein bisschen assoziativ daran zu gehen. Zum Teil sind es auch nur einzelne Zitate, dass sie so ein bisschen nach, ich google mal was zurecht, was mir zu Verlust noch einfällt. Und ich muss sagen, dass sie da noch ein Gedicht von Emily Dickinson, da könnte ich auch mal was zusagen. Und man geht doch da so durch und hat doch am Ende 100 Namen, 15 Zusammenfassungen, 15, 150 Zusammenfassungen von irgendwelchen Romanen und Theaterstücken gehört, hat dann so ein paar eigene Überlegungen von Eva Illouz und weiß am Ende, naja, Gefühle scheinen wichtig zu sein, haben aber auch verschiedene Seiten solche und solche gibt. Und dann versucht sie gleichzeitig noch damit, eine Geschichte der bürgerlichen Demokratie und des Kapitalismus bzw. des Konsums zu erzählen. Und dann würde ich sagen, ja dann stützt dich auf genau eines, ein Werk und geht von dort aus. Aber es sind ja zum Teil springt sie. Also ich hab's mir rausgeschrieben, Stefan. Sie springt hier zum Teil von Michael Kohl haskleis. Dann kommt ein Zitat von Pankaj Misha. Dann kommt Francis Fukuyama. Dann geht sie wieder zu Guy de Montpassant. Dann was von René Girard. Dann Kafka. Dann Joseph Roth. Dann wieder Kafka. Dann Joseph Roth. Was ist das?
Ich verstehe das. Also ich verstehe, was du sagst. Auf der thematischen Ebene ist es beliebig. Also man hätte nicht Othello nehmen müssen. Man kann auch andere Shakespeare Sachen nehmen. Man hätte nicht die Literatur des 17. Jahrhunderts. Man hätte auch das 19. Jahrhundert nehmen können. Man hätte sich von Proust, den sie ja sehr lobt, nur das eine Buch, nur die Suche nach der verlorenen Zeit, und nichts anderes nehmen können. Also thematisch, ja, hohes Maß an Beliebigkeit. Und damit auch hohes Maß an Kritikanfälligkeit, weil wir alle wissen, und das ist auch ein Thema, das hier ja über Bande sozusagen ein bisschen humorisch genannt werden kann. Jeder hat halt seine Vorlieben. Sie hat ihre, du hast deine, ich habe meine. Nur, neben oder unter diesem thematischen Zugriff liegt ja ein problematischer, ein problematisierender. Und jetzt können wir natürlich sagen, na ja, Eva Eluse hat ein Buch über Gefühle geschrieben, hat nicht die Literaturwissenschaft schon ewig einen Turn zur Gefühlichkeit? Hat man nicht schon relativ früh festgestellt?
Nee, sie beschäftigt sich damit, wie Gefühle ausgedrückt werden in der Literatur, wie eine Gefühlslenkung des Lesers stattfindet. Also da gibt es ja ganz viele Analysen zu, wer sich dafür interessiert.
Genau. Aber das ist ja genau der Kram, weshalb ich keine Romane lese, weil ich das nicht brauche, weil es mich nicht interessiert. Und wie jemand seine Gefühlswelt in einem Roman zum Ausdruck bringt und das vielleicht nochmal vergleichend beobachtend, finde ich alles, also ich verstehe das als Hobby, aber es ist ja nicht mein Fall. Und jetzt ja die Frage, warum sag ich aber zu diesem Buch, das ist irgendwie gelungen?
Das interessiert mich.
Genau. Und die Einflugsschneise ist nicht Gefühle, weil 2025 ist irgendwie das Jahr, in dem, wie ich eben sagte, Trump gewählt wird, Trump die Leute so gefühlsmäßig überzeugt hat, das verstehen wir nicht, Politik ist doch ein Sachgeschäft und so, da würden doch Themen verhandelt, liest dann keiner mehr Programme, Wahlprogramme und so. Das ist ja nicht das Thema. Also Gefühle sind ja hier nur Vehikel, um etwas zu verstehen, das bisher unverstanden blieb. So, und diese Einflugsschneise macht sie aber ganz explizit. Und dann, also ich kontrastriere jetzt ihren Text und meinen Text, und dann wirst du glaube ich auch verstehen, warum jetzt ich da so eine hohe Sympathie für diese Art von soziologischen Einflugsschneisen habe. Also sie schreibt, Ohne dass uns dies bewusst wäre, umfassen und verkörpern Gefühle die zentralen Bestandteile der Gesellschaft. Normen, Regeln, soziale Strukturen, kulturelle Leitlinien bilden das unsichtbare, aber brennende Magma der Gefühle, den Glutkern ihrer Energie. Das sind die Annahmen, die den gedanklichen Hintergrund dieses Buches bilden. Es geht also bei Gefühlen nicht darum, dass wir alle mitgerissen sind von Gefühlen und Thomas Mann schon sagte, das Gefühl macht uns zu Mensch und der Dick sagte, das Gefühl unterscheidet uns von der Maschine oder wie auch immer. Also darum geht es nicht, sondern es geht darum, dass wir unsichtbare, latente Sinnstrukturen haben, von denen sie sagt, die brennen wie Magma. Also wenn wir die sehen würden, würden wir sofort ausweichen und sagen, holt ihr denn keine Feuerwehr? Wie kann denn das sein? Stattdessen, nee, wir wählen mal Trump. So. Also wir haben einfach die Lava übersehen. So in meinem Buch heißt es und ich interessiere mich gar nicht für Literatur. Also ich mache gar keine.
Ich dachte, du machst jetzt.
Ich habe so einen ganz kleinen Abschnitt über was in der Literatur und wann schon mal über Liebe gesprochen wurde und so. Also wir sind jetzt thematisch ganz weit weg, aber problematisch sind wir eins zu eins bei dem Interesse, das auch Eva Illouz treibt. Bei mir im Text heißt es, die materielle Politik, die Fakten schafft, wird flankiert von einem Human Interest, einer ideellen Politik, die auf Gefühlshaushalte und Gemütszustände zielt, über deren latente Sinnstrukturen, über immanente implizite indirekte Zusammenhänge wird, das sagen schon diese Worte, nicht geredet, wir wollen sie trotzdem ansprechen. So und ich wähle keinen Weg über die Literatur, sondern ich bin sehr dafür und freu mich auf dein Buch.
Ich finde das wichtig, das zu tun und ich glaube, dass es auch ganz schwer ist, darüber zu sprechen, weil es so wenig greifbar ist und sie macht es sich aber zu einfach, indem sie sagt, ne ne ist ja alles da, ich brauch nur mal die Literatur herzuholen. Und dann kommt sie aber mit halb garen literaturwissenschaftlichen Analysen, gemischt wird das mit ein bisschen Soziologie, dann auch wieder die entsprechend großen Namen, Weber, Simmel etc. Noch ein paar empirische Studien, aber auch gerade so was zur Hand war, auch da nicht systematisch sich zum Beispiel die Situation junger Menschen in den USA einmal angeguckt und durchgearbeitet, sondern nur so punktuell und da ist auch Enttäuschung und da ist auch Nostalgie und da ist auch Hass und das wird dann zusammen gebunden zu einem Strauß, der so aussieht, als hätte man hier so eine größere Abhandlung, aber tatsächlich haben wir hier Einzelüberlegungen. Also ich würde sagen als Materialsammlung, wenn man jetzt darauf Vorträge oder so aufbauen möchte, ist das ganz hilfreich, denke ich. Aber es ergibt nicht im Ganzen eine Monographie und das soll es ja wohl sein. Und dass sie auch diese doch sehr interessante Einleitung schreibt, also da bin ich ja ganz auf deiner Seite, sie aber dann diesen Begriff der explosiven Moderne so gut wie nicht mehr verwendet in den folgenden 300 Seiten, finde ich, ist ja schon ein Eingeständnis, das offenbar entweder die These nicht trägt oder sie gar keine Lust hat, da eine Kohärenz aufzubauen, die man ja aufbauen könnte. Also zu sagen, es gibt einen extremen Medienwandel, du sagst das ja auch wieder kürzlich im Podcast, naja, das ist so eine Verschiebung, das wird nicht wahrgenommen, die sind alle noch in ihrem alten Modus, die machen immer noch alle Dienst nach Vorschrift. Und diese Radikalität wird nicht nachgenommen, aber jetzt mit der Trump-Ära wird es zerfallen, es ist nicht mehr aufrechtzuhalten. Das jetzt als Paradigmenwechsel zu erkennen und dann zu sagen, ich bleibe jetzt bei dieser Explosivität der Gefühle und lasse mich hin und wieder von Literatur inspirieren, das kann ich ja nachvollziehen, um das zu beschreiben. Aber wenn man alles nacheinander einfach so aufzählt, dann ist man irgendwann bei so einer endlosen Liste angekommen, bei der man sich fragt, ja warum nicht noch ein paar weitere Gefühle. Also ich habe hier immer wieder den Eindruck, dass wir hier auch Binsenweisheiten relativ elaboriert präsentiert bekommen. Sie sagt zum Beispiel, es geht dann um amerikanischen Traum und so weiter, ein solcher Appell liegt nicht nur der amerikanischen Kultur, sondern der westlichen Moderne insgesamt zugrunde, in der sich die Individuen durch eine Reihe von Zukunftsprojektionen definieren. Das heißt durch die zukünftigen Chancen, die sie sich für sich selbst ausmalen und die Erwartungen, deren Erfüllung sie entgegensehen. Man denke an die bloße Natur der kapitalistischen Tätigkeit. Investitionen ergeben keinen Sinn ohne die Hoffnung auf Gewinn. Sich um einen Studienabschluss zu bemühen, ergäbe genauso wenig Sinn, wenn man nicht die Hoffnung hätte, auf dem Weg später eine gute Stelle zu finden. Die Karriereleiter in größeren Unternehmen weckt beim Großteil der Belegschaft, die Hoffnung aufzusteigen und die eigene Position zu verbessern. Ach ja, was denn sonst? Also das sind solche Sätze, bei denen ich sage, ja genau, Menschen werden einen Studienabschluss haben wollen, weil sie die Hoffnung haben, damit mal was zu werden. Ich kenne auch tatsächlich aus meinem Umfeld niemanden, der sagt, ich mache einen Studienabschluss, weil ich später nichts werden will. Was ist das? Warum wird das aufgeschrieben?
Ja. Also dieses Buch ist für mich, ich bleibe dabei, es zu verteidigen bis zuletzt und ich habe noch sehr viele Anmerkungen, die ich machen möchte. Ich habe ja nun auch, also ich gehe mit der Behauptung rein, Familie ist das allerwichtigste politische Thema, das wir haben und auch das ausgeblendete. Also nur mit Superlativen. So und jetzt interessiere ich mich über mein eigenes Buch hinaus für dieses Thema. Und Familie ist ja auch deswegen interessant, weil das eben so ein hartnäckiger interaktiver Zusammenhang ist. Sobald die Schwester in Amerika lebt, ist sie nur noch eine unter vielen. Ich weiß, man fühlt es noch ein bisschen anders, aber im Alltag spielt es keine Rolle. So, da wird dann doch irgendwann die Nachbarin wichtiger, von der man sich das einleihen kann, wie auch immer. So, wir brauchen also oder ich brauche für das große Interesse, das ich jetzt aufgebaut habe, Zulieferbetriebe. Die müssen nicht ganz genau auf mich passen. Also ich kann ja sehr gut inspirativ lesen, mache ich gerne, wenn das Angebot gut ist. Bei Verlust war es nicht gut, weil der Begriff hat sich relativ schnell erschöpft oder wurde umgedeutet. Hier einfach zu sagen, wir bleiben jetzt mal bei Emotionen. Nicht, weil wir immer über Emotionen reden wollen, sondern weil wir die brennende Lava sichtbar machen wollen. Und alles, was folgt, sind sozusagen Vorschläge. Und da positioniert sie sich als Soziologin, die also sagt, ja es gibt so die einzigartige Geschichte der seelischen Grundverfassung auf der einen Seite, psychologisches Interesse. Auf der anderen Seite sind Angehörige von Gruppen und Kulturen. Spätestens wenn wir dann mal als Tourist irgendwo auftauchen oder Flüchtlinge herkommen, merken wir, Kulturschock ist ein echtes Problem. Du kennst ja auch diese Rassismusdefinition, die darauf aussetzt, dass es ein Ekelgefühl ist, das zugrunde liegt und lott auf solche Sachen. Also wir haben es immer irgendwie mit Gefühlen zu tun, den wir nicht ganz entrinnen können und die man hier einfach mal sprechfähig macht. Und da sagt sie als Soziologin ganz klar, also da ist ja jetzt so ein Stück vorgelesen zur Biografiegestaltung, sie sagt aber ganz deutlich, als Soziologin bin ich weniger an der Heilung seelischer Wunden, als an der Frage interessiert, wie die Gesellschaft zu diesen Wunden beiträgt. Das wäre mir aus meiner soziologischen Richtung auch schon zu normativ. Also ich hätte es lieber so reindeskriptiv, was passiert, weil ihre Frage, wie die Gesellschaft zu diesen Wunden beiträgt, da steckt ja schon wieder so ein, wenn wir dieses Buch lesen und das Buch wäre gut, ja dann könnten wir sozusagen Abhilfe schaffen, voraus ein, vorbeugen, dass diese Wunden nicht gerissen werden oder wie auch immer. Selbst das wäre mir schon zu viel, muss gar nicht sein.
In dem gesamten Werk von Eva Illos geht es ja immer darum, dass die Moderne für eine Pluralisierung und Liberalisierung und Emanzipation sorgt. Zum einen, zum anderen aber, dass dies Nöte mit sich bringt wie die Qual der Wahl, dass sich Ewige nicht entscheiden können, dass Ewige enttäuscht seien, warum habe ich jetzt hier weitergeswipe, wäre nicht noch jemand anders besser gewesen, wenn ich noch länger gedatet hätte und und und. Das sind ja so ihre Themen und zugleich sagt sie, ist darin aber auch eine Modernität und eine Freiheit, die es zu beschützen gilt. Ja, sie ist jetzt ja niemand, die sagt, wir müssen zurück in feudale Zeiten, als die Ehen noch fest verabredet wurden durch die Eltern, weil die Höfe beieinander lagen und da war dann auch mit Konsum der Romantik nichts mehr. Sie sagt also, ich finde die Moderne gut, aber sie ist natürlich sehr dialektisch zu verstehen. Das ist jetzt etwas, was sie überträgt, zum Beispiel darauf, dass sie sagt, Enttäuschungen sind in der Welt, damit beginnt das ja, also der amerikanische Traum und die damit einhergehenden Enttäuschungen. Wenn ich natürlich in einer mittelalterlichen Gesellschaft lebe, bin einem Stand zugeordnet, bin Mitglied einer ZUNF, dann ist der Hoffnungshorizont ein sehr kleiner. Deshalb, weil ich ja gar nicht hoffen kann, auch noch dies und das zu machen, das ist gar nicht mehr vorgesehen. Wie wir das auch in Kastensystemen oder so kennen. Sobald ich aber potentiell zumindest die Möglichkeit habe oder auch juridisch gesehen die Möglichkeit habe, alles zu tun, alles zu machen, alles zu werden, sind natürlich die Enttäuschungen, auch wenn man etwas erreicht hat, relativ groß bzw. können groß sein. Zugleich sind ganz viele Projekte, die wir in der Politik haben, darauf ausgerichtet, dass sie Hoffnung versprechen, auf Verbesserungen hinauslaufen. Ich glaube allerdings, dass wenn man das alles so allgemein hält, man jetzt nicht wahnsinnig neu zutage führt. Denn was ich jetzt gerade hier ausgeführt habe, ist ja nichts, was nicht jedem intuitiv einleuchtet. Sie führt das aber dann immer länger auf. Sie sagt, das Projekt EU war auf Hoffnung gegründet. Martin Luther King hat seine Politik auf Hoffnung. Lass uns mal noch in dem Vorspann fangen. Und da ist die Enttäuschung mit drin. Dann gibt es das Lied We Shall Overcome. Auch da drin steckt Hoffnung. Dann geht sie zur Solidarnosc-Bewegung. Auch die wurde von Hoffnung und dann aber auch von Enttäuschung getragen. Und dann, yes we can, Obama, Hoffnung und Enttäuschung liegen da wieder nah beieinander. Ja, das ist eine schöne Aufzählung und wir stellen fest, Hoffnung und Enttäuschung sind Momente, die zu unserer Gesellschaft und zu unserem Leben dazugehören. Mag sein, dass sie durch diese Modernisierungsschübe noch einmal zugenommen haben. Aber auch hier frage ich wieder, bekommen wir nicht Binsen präsentiert in einem soziologischen Gewand?
Ja, erstmal klären wir noch die Grundbegriffe.
Ah, okay.
Die explosive Moderne muss ja noch erklärt werden. Was heißt hier Moderne und warum ist sie explosiv? Dass sie gefühlig hier als Vehikel benutzt werden, um das Latente, also ihre brennende Lava sichtbar zu machen. Ja, dein Vorwurf, sie als Soziologin, ja also die Emotionen verkoppeln eben biologische, psychologische und soziologische Sachen miteinander. Also da lohnt es jetzt nicht. Also das kann man sozusagen nur interdisziplinär machen. Da steht einfach jede Disziplin für sich. Das haben wir ja bei Thomas Fuchs auch schon. Und der sagt, die Psychiatrie und Psychologie muss jetzt immer Bezug auf den Körper nehmen. So und der Körper ist einfach eine Domäne der, sag ich jetzt mal, biologischen Medizin. Und diese somatischen Wissenschaften sind da eben nicht auszublenden. Wir haben es also, sagen wir mal so, hier mit einem Gegenstand zu tun, der uns vor die Herausforderungen stellt, unsere schöne Kartografie der Disziplin zu hinterfragen und zu sagen, das geht gar nicht. Also wenn du das jetzt verstehen willst, warum Trump gewonnen hat, frag keinen Politikwissenschaftler, frag aber auch keinen Psychologen, frag keinen Arzt, sondern bring sie in ein Gespräch und lass sie, sei es erst mal über Literatur oder wie auch immer, also so einen inspirativen Zusammenhang bauen. Wir haben es bei Emotionen mit einem, also nicht nur biologischen, psychologischen, sondern auch einem sozialen Charakter zu tun, die zu einer kulturellen und sozialen Grammatik führen, die sich in Sprache niederschlägt. Also der Zugang über die Literatur, so beliebig er ist, das kann man eher der Literatur vorwerfen. Sie hat halt ein zu großes Angebot. Und sie hat halt den Fokus gewählt, wie sie ihn gewählt hat. Noch sind wir ja nicht alle, Claude mit einem Token Fenster von eine Million und so weiter, wo dann 70 Bücher auf einmal verarbeitet werden können. Wir haben halt Lieblingsbücher.
Aber erinnert dich das nicht ein bisschen an Claude, was hier passiert? Also ich finde, das ist immer so ein bisschen einfach gemacht. Wenn ich jetzt sage, ja, das ist ja wie bei Chöchee-PT. Aber ich musste mitunter daran denken, wenn man solche Systeme danach fragt, wo kommt das Thema Eifersucht in der Literatur vor? Dann würde natürlich als erstes das Verhältnis von Othello, Iago und Desdemona vorkommen. Das würde genannt werden. Und weiteres folgt dann. Bis hin zu, dachte ich, eigentlich auch noch Die Schöne des Herrn wäre doch noch was. Und tatsächlich kommt dann auch dieser Roman noch gegen einen vor. Ist das nicht etwas, was wir hier so finden mit, naja, ich muss mal so ein Korpus suchen.
Das finde ich jetzt interessant, dass du das sagst, weil typischerweise wird mir vorgeworfen, dass ich im Podcast zu sehr die KI in der Hinsicht verherrliche. Aber das ist genau die Herausforderung. Wozu brauchen wir überhaupt noch von Menschen geschriebene Bücher, wenn wir Clot haben? Oder auch wozu brauchen wir Podcasts? Denn ich bin ja jetzt Kunde des 200 Euro im Monat GPT Pro Modus. Wenn ich mit dem in einem mündlichen Gespräch zusammen haben bin, kann ich dieses ganze Buch, die ganzen Themen einfach durchgehen. Und zwar nach meinem Interesse geleitet. Was jetzt nicht bedeutet, dass sozusagen das Angebot, das Clot mir macht aus dem Fundus, alles ist reintrainiert. Also die Literaturgeschichte liegt da einfach vollständig vor. Wenn ich einen Zitat haben will, trägt er es mir vor.
Aber das führt uns doch eher, dass wir solche Bücher nicht benötigen. Das heißt ja nicht, dass wir nicht Bücher bauen. Ich werde gleich zum Beispiel ein literarisches Werk kurz vorstellen, ein Buch, das von einer Autorin ist, die ich vorher gar nicht kannte. Und dann wird man sagen, naja, aber genau das kann ja eben eine KI nicht. Aber hier, wenn ich jetzt einfach natürlich ein Programm sage, such für mich Enttäuschung zusammen in der Literatur, dann kommt da etwa sowas natürlich bei raus. Und ich muss auch sagen und das liegt auch daran, also ich hab jetzt nicht diese Pro-Programme, aber ich merke natürlich, dass Originalität bei Perplexity oder Chachipiti nicht zu haben ist. Und das ist aber auch das, woran es hier in diesem Buch mangelt. Also die literarischen, wir werden ja das gleich, ich will es mal in zwei Beispiel nachher machen, diese literarischen Exegesen, die sie hier betreibt, sind einfach sehr schlicht. Das ist nicht besonders klug.
Hier müssen wir jetzt die Zäsur erkennen. Dieses Buch klärt uns darüber auf, wie ich finde, das ist mein Themeneinschlag, warum Trump gewonnen hat. Also es geht einfach diesen Gefühlshaushalten nach, die dazu führen, dass diese Wähleransprache erfolgreich ist. Was bedeutet? Wir in Europa haben vom Bundeskanzler eine öffentliche, ich habe gerade alle Staatschefs von Europa angerufen und meine Tagesordnung unterbrochen, um ihnen folgende Mitteilung zu machen. Wir sind dagegen, dass Trump mit Gewalt sich Grönland nimmt, also in Europa Einfeld und Krieg anzettelt. Diese Situation wurde hergestellt, weil 49,3 Prozent der Amerikaner von sich sagten, das Angebot, was mir Trump macht, reicht. Was bedeutet, 150 Millionen Amerikaner können einfach sagen mit voller Inbrunst, Kloot reicht mir nicht, ich brauch das höherwertige, ich will Hochkultur, ich will, dass auf der Bühne gesungen wird und so weiter. Das können 150 Millionen Amerikaner zurecht sagen. Sie können das zynisch, überheblich, wie auch immer darstellen. Sie können darüber lachen, dass Leute darauf hineinfallen, das war doch nur eine Fake-Werbung und so weiter, wieso hast du jetzt den Kandidaten gewählt? Die Ausländer sind doch gar nicht so drauf, wie in diesem Mid-Journey-Bild suggeriert wird. Das ist ja der Punkt. Das ist jetzt alles egal. 150 Millionen Amerikaner, wir wissen, es sind längst nicht so viele, die unbedingt gerne in die Oper wollen, die eine öffentliche Bibliothek brauchen, die zwei literarische Werke in ihrer Qualität voneinander unterscheiden können. Also dieser Zug ist längst abgefahren. Wir müssen uns jetzt, und das ist ja Anlass dieses Buches, mit der brennenden Lava befassen, dass diese Lava mal nicht brannte, sondern ein ganz festes Fundament war, auf dem ein Opernhaus stand, wo jeden Abend die romantische Hochkultur noch mal, alles schön und gut, aber jetzt brennt die Lava.
Also Stefan Faß, möchte ich sagen, ich hätte mir das Buch gewünscht, nur von dir geschrieben, nicht von Eva Illouz.
Ich bin einfach froh, dass wenigstens Eva Illouz sich hier mal in die...
Denn du hättest dir die Lava angesehen, du hättest den TikTok-Trend ausgemacht und hättest mir den beschrieben und hättest mir gesagt, was das für eine Emotionpolitik ist.
Genau, das wäre zum Beispiel meine Einflussschneise gewesen.
Und das halte ich für, also ich will ja nicht die Dittatur abwerden, vielleicht werden manche jetzt denken, was ist denn da los mit Wolfgang, sag doch sonst, die Dittatur hat eine zeitlose Qualität. Ja, ja, hat sie ja auch. Nur ich glaube, wenn man einfach dazu übergeht, etwas heutiges zu beschreiben und dann sich inspirativ ein paar alte Texte dazu nimmt und mit denen dann ein bisschen was macht, dann kommt man nicht wirklich ihm heute an. Wir werden jetzt nachher ja noch Adam Two's hören und der sagt, man muss in medias res.
Ja.
Und genau das tut sie nicht. Sie geht nicht in medias res, sie geht am Anfang in diese Einleitung, die tatsächlich interessant ist, da rein. Und vielleicht wäre das ein hundertseitiger, guter Essay geworden, wenn sie das noch ein bisschen weiter ausgeführt hätte.
Also es ist ein guter, hundertseitiger Essay. Nur weil danach noch in deinem Metier mit dem Spaten linksrum umgegraben wird, heißt das noch nicht, dass die ersten hundertseiten...
Ich will das jetzt hier nicht so, dass ich jetzt hier als enttäuschter Germanist davor sitze oder so. Ich halte diesen Ansatz für nicht weitführend, sondern wir haben jetzt hier einfach so ein, ich hab so ein bisschen Eindruck, es ist so ein Buch für Leute, die keine Literatur mehr lesen wollen. Aber man kriegt es noch mal so ein bisschen durchgeklappert. Eigentlich das, was Blinkist doch macht, oder? Sie brauchen das Buch nicht ganz lesen. Wir fassen es für Sie thesenartig zusammen. Das ist doch was sie da macht. Brauchen jetzt nicht mehr nachgucken bei Kleist. Wir machen das hier bei Eva Illus mal auf zehn Seiten.
Blinkist versucht ja den roten Faden, was wollte der Autor mir sagen, nachzuvollziehen. Hier haben wir es ja mit Stückwerk zu tun, das versucht, sich einer selbstgestellten Aufgabe unterzuordnen. Also wir haben ja ein Sammelsorium, das plausibilisieren soll. Wie das gelingt, also lass uns gleich, wir sagen dann ganz deutlich, jetzt sind wir im Kapitel Hoffnung und das ist dann das erste der Emotionen. Aber auch vorher, diese Einführung, die du ja auch wertgeschätzt hast gerade, die ist auch nochmal wichtig. Lass uns die nochmal so ein bisschen punktuell, denn sie erklärt ja ihren Buchtitel, der sich mir jetzt auch nicht erschließt. Ich hätte jetzt auch gedacht, ja, das kann man doch irgendwie Kartografie der Gefühle, Bedeutung von Gefühlen heute, also hätte man nicht mehr so einen Dienstleister-Ratgeber-Titel wählen sollen, statt jetzt Explosivo Moderne, was jetzt ein sehr verspielter Titel ist. Aber gut, vielleicht ist das auch so der Vulkan, ja, die Moderne, der Vulkan ist explodierter, die Lava kommt jetzt für alle sichtbar raus, wie auch immer. So, also wir haben es mit der Moderne, mit einem, wie sie selber sagt, mit Wagen und Komplexen Begriff zu tun. Komplex heißt hier, es ist alles möglich. Also es ist vieldeutig, sagen wir mal so. Kontingenz ist hoch. Ähm, der Gefühlsleben entfaltet. Die übergreifende Frage Ihres Buches ist also, dieses spezifische, die spezifische Malaise des frühen 21. Jahrhunderts, also jetzt unserer Zeit, durch die Brille einer Reihe von Gefühlen zu verstehen. Sie macht also ein alternatives Sehangebot, eine Reflexion für eine Sache, die wir uns eh nicht entziehen können, weil wir haben schon festgestellt, wir sind alle gottausgewählte Menschen, wir können fühlen, wir sind noch nicht von der KI da eingeholt. Nun gut, und jetzt haben wir das große Dilemma unserer Tage, dass wir gleichermaßen verkörpern und veranschaulichen wollen, womit wir es hier zu tun haben. Also wir fühlen die ganze Zeit und wollen über Gefühle reden. Aber das Reden über Gefühle führt selber wieder zur Gefühlsregung. Also wir sind in so einem zirkulären Reflexionen-Metier einfach drin, das hier jetzt aufzudröseln ist, so schwer es auch ist. Wie gesagt, es über die Geschichte der Literatur als Kondensat und Artefakte von Gemütszuständen und Gefühlszuständen zu machen, ist halt ein Weg. Also wie gesagt, ich hab's halt anders gemacht, aber der Weg sozusagen, das Ziel, die Richtung, in die man da geht, ist mal richtig. Diese explosive Moderne beschreibt sie ja, also sie sagt nochmal ganz konkret, ihr geht so um seit den 80er Jahren, also Menschen wie wir, die jetzt in der Mitte des Lebens sind oder so ungefähr, also um unseren Bewusstseinszeitraum geht's, sag mal mal. Seit die erste Hochzeit einer Besinnung, Zweiter Weltkrieg, sowas können wir echt nicht nochmal machen. Und dann in den 80ern bricht es aber auf und man denkt sich, nee ich hätte jetzt doch lieber mehr Profit als Menschenrechte oder wie auch immer. Also da gab es einen Bruch, der sie jetzt hier besonders interessiert. So und jetzt sagt sie, wir haben es mit zwei krassen Phänomenen zu tun. Das eine ist, unsere Demokratie geht irgendwie vor die Hunde. Wir stellen fest, überall ist nur noch Gespräch darüber, was ist mit unserer Demokratie. Wir kriegen sie irgendwann nicht gerettet und geschützt. So, da glaube ich kann jeder sagen, ja das stimmt, das ist so ein gängiger Tenor. Gleichzeitig Selbstmordraten in Amerika auf absoluten Spitzenwert, so hoch wie noch nie und ganz viel emotionale, gefühlsmäßige, individuelle Brachlande. Also wirklich Zerstörungen. Das ist auf politischer Ebene sehen wir diese Waldbrände in Los Angeles und wir wissen, die finden auch so in den Köpfen statt. Also diese Corona-Nachwehen und so weiter. Also dieses Bild der brennenden Lava, die wir aber nicht sehen, finde ich schon ganz gut. So, wir haben also hier zwei parallele Entwicklungen, die nicht unbedingt miteinander zusammenhängen, sondern wie sie sagt, die Spuren derselben Misere sind. Also wir haben nicht unglaublich viele enttäuschte und verzweifelte Bürger, die dann sagen, ja und deswegen werf ich jetzt ein Molotow-Cocktail in die Demokratie, weil die hat ja nichts für mich getan. Sondern diesen Schluss lässt sie so nicht zu, sondern sie sagt, nee das sind so getrennte Entwicklungen, aber es hat denselben Ursprung. Also Spuren einer Misere. Spuren heißt das Objekt, das wir eigentlich sehen wollen. Das liegt irgendwo vorne. Wir haben es noch nicht, wir sehen nur die Spur. Wir sind noch auf dieser forensischen Safari. So und dann sagt sie einfach Misere. Und Misere ist so, was ist eine Misere? So ich würde jetzt sagen, also diese Misere ist unser Grundbegriff. Und er beinhaltet den Umstand, dass wir nicht genau sagen, worüber wir hier reden.
Eine Misere ist ja eine verfahrenen Situation.
Genau. Irgendso was. Also irgendwas hier liegt im Argen. Es ist ein bisschen wie bei Tenet. Die Zeit läuft so rückwärts für manche Sachen. Und wir sehen alle Sachen, die aus der Zukunft sozusagen zu uns kommen, sind zerstört. Also irgendwas passiert in der Zukunft, aber wir wissen nicht was. Gab es jetzt einen großen Atomangriff, kamen die Aliens, wie auch immer. Alles, was in der Zeit rückwärts reißt, ist irgendwie komisch, weil es heißt in der Zeit rückwärts. Also es ist ja nicht mal rückwärts, sondern es ist ja sozusagen ein Vorwärts- und ein rückwärts, wie auch immer. Ganz kompliziert, aber man weiß nur, irgendwas krasses ist, aber wir wissen nicht was. Wir sehen nur die Artefakte. Wir können nur Ahnungen, Plausibilisierung und so weiter. Und genau das macht sie auch. Sie sagt halt nicht, Thomas Mann hat ja schon gesagt, und das ist jetzt so wie im Verlustbuch, und das ist die absolute Behauptung. Sondern nein, das bleibt halt alles ein bisschen unscharf. Wir sehen allenfalls Spuren einer Misere. So und näher geht sie dann eben auch nicht ran. Also alles, was an Literatur vorgestellt wird, sind Vorschläge, wie man etwas deuten könnte, wie etwas ja damals schon gedeutet wurde. Also schließen wir mal die Sehgewohnheit an. Vielleicht passts hier.
Aber vielleicht passts auch nicht.
Vielleicht passts auch nicht.
Aber das ist doch zu wenig für ein Buch.
Aber wenn es nicht passt, kann man eben inspirativ damit umgehen und sagen, ne, also diese Liebe wie Shakespeare sich das vorgestellt hat, das ist jetzt nicht das Problem auf dem Datingmarkt. Ja, und dann muss man jetzt irgendwie anders weiter denken. Aber unter dem Diktum des Zulieferbetriebs, des inspirativen Zusammenhangs, des Vorschlags, finde ich das einfach gut.
Ja, was sie ja machen will, ist ja die Moderne zu zeigen. Und deswegen sagt sie, ich suche mir moderne Literatur aus. Zum Beispiel Gustave Flaubert, Madame Bovary. Madame Bovary ist mit einem Arzt verheiratet, hat aber früh schon in Jugendtagen Literatur gelesen, weiß also von der romantischen Liebe, weiß von dem Meer, das eigentlich in der Liebe, in der sexuellen Erfüllung auch liegen kann und sehnt sich folglich nach Meer und zwar außerhalb der Ehe. Versucht also dort ihr Glück zu finden, aber natürlich lauert dort draußen nicht die romantische Erfüllung, wie sie einst die Literatur versprach, sondern vor allem die Enttäuschung. Ein großartiger Roman sag ich an dieser Stelle. Ich kann jedem empfehlen Mandambouvarie zu lesen. Sie nimmt das jetzt als Anlass zu sagen, damit beschreibt Flo Behr ein Gefühl der Moderne, das nämlich der Enttäuschung. Warum ist das ein Gefühl der Moderne noch mal im Speziellen? Denn früher waren ja auch schon Leute enttäuscht. Nun weil der Konsum, Kapitalismus, weil die Liberalisierung, die damit einhergeht, natürlich sehr viele Versprechungen macht, die größtenteils so überbordend sind, dass wenn man dann versucht sie zu realisieren, natürlich doch eher nur ein Abklatsch sein können. Man wird also eher enttäuscht sein. Es gibt da ein unendliches Begehren, sagt sie, und der Kapitalismus mit all den Waren, die er produziert, versucht einem nahezu legen, dass er dieses Begehren befriedigen kann. Aber wir wissen es, wir kaufen etwas Neues und sind dann doch wieder enttäuscht davon. Auch wenn es nicht schlecht ist als Produkt, wenn es genau so ist, wie es beschrieben wurde, sind wir etwas enttäuscht. Sie beschreibt, dass man sich ein Hotel aussucht, man kommt dort an und tatsächlich sind die Zimmer so wie auf dem Foto, aber irgendwas ist doch nicht so ganz. Man ist also in einem Gefühl der Enttäuschung. Das sagt sie, sei ein sehr modernes Gefühl. Ich glaube, ja, das stimmt, weil das sehr viel mit der Repräsentation von etwas zu tun haben und dem Erreichen davon. Und dann ist das natürlich die Frage, wie wird es sein? Also wir haben ja jetzt bei den Golden Globes auch allwieder diese Traumpaare auf dem roten Teppich gesehen, Tom Holland und Zendaya. Und dann denken sich die Leute, wie glücklich müsste wohl ein Leben sein, wenn die zusammen sind? Nun, die Antwort geben ja quasi Jennifer Lopez und Ben Affleck. Ziemlich unglücklich vielleicht oder auch nicht. Vielleicht aber auch irgendwie sehr gewöhnlich, weil sie sich natürlich nicht als Zendaya und Tom Holland als Repräsentation begegnen, sondern als Menschen begegnen sich. Und dann ist das natürlich so, dass man in gewisser Weise eine Enttäuschung erfährt. Was sie jetzt aber doch sagt über dieses unendliche Begehren, dass der Kapitalismus einem da bietet, sie sagt es ist ein Unvermögen, dass der Kapitalismus eine unendlich erneuerbare Suche in Gang setzt nach einer Befriedigung, die aber grundsätzlich nicht erreichbar ist, weil sie im Subjekt liegt dieses Unbefriedigtsein. Das ist ja etwas, was wir natürlich alle auch kennen. Wir kaufen etwas als Ersatzbefriedigung. Aber generell sind wir natürlich nie ganz befriedigt. Man spricht ja zum Beispiel auch für das Gefühl nach dem Sex von einer postkuitalen Traurigkeit. Also eigentlich ist es doch nicht das gewesen, weil was ist es denn? Also warum ist man danach eigentlich traurig? So das schildert sie jetzt hier, verknüpft das mit Madame Bovary und dann würde ich sagen, ja stimmt. Das ist so, das ist aber auch wirklich nicht neu, was sie hier beschreibt. Und dann kommt sie aber von dort ausgehend von dieser Enttäuschung, die jetzt bei Flaubert beschrieben wird und die auch so generell in der Struktur der menschlichen Psyche liegt, zur Meritokratie und sagt dann, die Chancengleichheit ist geringer geworden. Es ist nicht mehr wie früher, wo man durchaus vielleicht auch mit einem nicht so tollen Schulabschluss Karriere machen konnte. Wir wissen aber, die wir Michael Sandel gelesen haben, und sie zitiert ihn nur an einer Stelle, erwähnt sie ihn so halb, aber sie geht dann nicht auf sein Argument ein. Wir wissen ja, dass gerade die Meritokratie nicht daran krank, dass zu wenig Chancengleichheit gibt. Das ist natürlich auch ein Problem. Aber die Sache ist ja generell bei Sandel, sobald ich Leuten sage, du wirst erst Respekt verdienen, wenn du aufgestiegen bist, sind also alle, die nicht aufsteigen, jene, die sich als schlecht fühlen. Michael Sandel beschreibt ja, dass gerade da, wo die Ungleichheit sehr manifest war, durch zum Beispiel Segregation oder so etwas, die Leute diese Art der modernen Enttäuschung nicht empfunden haben, weil sie einfach sagten, naja für einen Jungen, eines Arbeitersohns ist das so, dass man auch Arbeiter wird. Punkt. Da ist nicht eine Enttäuschung da, sondern das ist ein Abfinden mit der Situation. Sobald aber in der Meritokratie gesagt wird, egal wer du bist, woher du kommst, du kannst es schaffen, sind natürlich alle, die es nicht geschafft haben, enttäuscht. Und das muss in einem Pyramidial aufgebauten System, wo eben nur manche an der Spitze stehen können, ist also diese Enttäuschung im System programmiert. Und das erkennt sie aber gar nicht als solches, sondern thematisiert dann, dass es mehr Chancengleichheit geben müsste. Wo ich denke, ja, das ist an sich ein Anliegen, da kann man nicht dagegen sein, aber das ist nicht das Grundproblem, das löst nicht das Problem der Enttäuschung.
Ja, Enttäuschung ist allerdings schon die zweite Emotion, die sie nennt. Vorher kommt ja noch die Hoffnung.
Ja, du gehst ja ganz strukturell da durch.
Ja, vor allem, weil du bringst ja mehr Struktur in das Buch, als da ist. Naja, also bevor es in die Emotion geht, in die Kartografie der neuen Emotionen, macht sie ja noch mal einen Vorschlag, der für dich vielleicht auch erklärt und mehr erklärt, warum sie jetzt so sehr auf die Literatur da abstellt. Also der erste Grund, es explosivo moderne zu nennen, habe ich gerade genannt, in ihrem Wortlaut, die Krise der Demokratie und die Vermehrung der psychischen Störungen machen uns darauf aufmerksam, dass etwas im Gefühls- und Sozialleben der spätmoderne angegangen und verstanden werden muss. Okay, soweit. Jetzt die Frage, warum verstehen wir es nicht? Also warum ist hier ein Missverstehen aufgelaufen? Warum fehlen hier Erklärungen? Und dafür führt sie den zweiten Grund an, warum dieses Buch explosiv geworden ist. Unter dem enormen Einfluss der kommerzialisierten Erzählliteratur und der psychologischen Kultur spielt die bewusste Erforschung und Überwachung der eigenen Gefühle inzwischen eine entscheidende Rolle in den Selbstbeschreibungen der Menschen sowie darin, wie sie soziale Beziehungen zu anderen knüpfen und pflegen. Was bedeutet, die emotionale Selbsterkenntnis, nach welchen moralischen Werten, Tugenden, was ist gut, was ist schlecht und so weiter, führt dazu, dass ich mich von der Erzählliteratur verabschiede und mich mehr auf dieses Social Media, wo es hier ein Shitstorm wäre, beschwert sich über wen und so weiter, also wo sozusagen nicht mehr durchgeschrieben wird, roter Faden und jetzt wird erzählt, sondern es ist dieses punktuelle, ich sehe ein Verhalten auf dem roten Teppich und meine besten Freunde sind davon angewidert, also ich auch. Da wird aber nichts mehr erzählt oder so. Also wir haben es auch mit einem gewissen Abschied von der Wirkmächtigkeit, zumindest der Literatur, zu tun, schon allein weil auch weniger gelesen wird, trotz Booktalk und so weiter. Die Literatur hat ihren, in der Medienkonkurrenz, ihren Platz einfach verloren, was für mich wieder bedeutet, okay, ja, dieses Gesamtgefüge aus, wir haben eine geschriebene Geschichte und dann haben wir die Erlebnis-Artefakte in der Literatur manifestiert daneben, dass dieses Gefüge nicht mehr aufgeht. Also entstehen gerade keine großen Höhle wegschreibt über wie der Islam in Frankreich einfällt oder sowas. Also wir haben keine begleitende Literatur zu Trump's Sieg, obwohl sie so dringend nötig wäre. Wo ich auch wieder denke, ja das stimmt, also in der Hinsicht fehlt vielleicht ein Nachwort. Nicht zur Frage, welche Gefühle bestimmen uns, sondern wenn du doch, bevor du die neun großen Katalogtexte zum Thema diese und jene Emotionen schreibst, dann sag uns doch, wie werden sie denn jetzt reguliert nach dem Ausfall der Erzählliteratur? Denn das scheint ja auch, also nicht nur, dass es diese Gefühle gibt, sondern auch, wie werden sie reguliert? Denn dass sie einfach diesen Hinweis macht, ja, das unterliegt jetzt jedem selbst. Man kommt halt in so eine pseudo parasoziale Beratungssituation hinein, weil einfach im Internet viel los ist auf diesem Gebiet. Ja, genau. Und das finde ich ist ein großes Forschungsdesiderat. Ja, also da müssten ja eigentlich jetzt alle reingehen und sagen, scheiß drauf, dass ich Soziologe bin. Ich muss mich hier mit den Biologen, also mit den Medizinern und den Psychologen zusammensetzen. Wir brauchen jetzt eine große interdisziplinäre, gratuierten Schule, die das einfach mal, die dem Ganzen auf den Zahn fühlt. Nur da ist für mich das halt wieder ein Zulieferbetrieb, ist eine Aufgabe und kann man auch vorwerfen, nur weil ich diese Aufgabe gerade formuliere, weil ich Eva-Eluis Buch in der Hand hat, heißt noch lange nicht, dass sie die Schuldige ist, dass wir jetzt diese Aufklärung darüber nicht haben.
Ja, das nicht. Aber du erinnerst dich zum Beispiel an diesen Abschnitt, in dem Peter Sloterdijk in seinem Buch über Europa beschreibt, dass irgendwann nicht mehr der Adel zählt, sondern ein Schriftsteller bekommt einen Adelstitel. Das heißt also seine Leistung ist plötzlich etwas, was ihnen einen aristokratischen Stand erhebt. Und damit war die Berühmtheit geboren. Er geht dann über bis hin zu Greta Gabo, die dann auch noch die Göttliche genannt wird. Sie bringt ja in ihrem Kapitel zur Enttäuschung auch wieder das Thema Berühmtheit. Sie sagt, junge Menschen, wenn man den Umfragen Glauben schenken kann, wollen gern berühmt werden. Natürlich werden nur wenige berühmt. Also birgt dieser Wunsch, danach berühmt zu werden, also dieses Versprechen der Moderne oder zumindest das, was die Moderne als Sehnsucht wecken kann, immer die Gefahr, dass man wahnsinnig enttäuscht sein wird. Das ist ja auch alles richtig. Die Frage ist also hier, haben wir es mit einem Buch zu tun, das zwar erst einmal vorgibt im Vorwort, das Gegenwärtige zu verhandeln, aber lesen wir das nicht dann doch eher als ein Buch, das uns noch mal erklärt, was in den letzten zwei bis dreihundert Jahren vorgefallen ist, welche interessante menschheitsgeschichtliche Entwicklung es genommen hat, dass wir heute zum Beispiel Berühmtheit als etwas Wichtigeres ansehen als die Abstammung von irgendeiner Familie und welche Dialektiken sind das, die wir da beobachten, wenn man tatsächlich diese Liberalisierung erfährt und zugleich aber auch dieses extrem lähmende Gefühl der Enttäuschung dann sehr bald hat.
Genau. Bevor wir auf die kommen, lass mich noch einen Gedanken, den sie hat und den sie uns präsentiert, bevor es dann in die Kartografie geht. Diese Individualisierung führt dazu, dass wir in sehr vielen Bereichen, in denen Gefühle wichtig sind und eben nicht nur Ehe und Intimität, sondern grundsätzlich eine Folge von Entscheidungskünsten sehen. Also wir selbst sind die Künstler unserer Entscheidungskaskaden, an dessen Ende Gefühlshaushalte stehen.
Ja.
Was eben bedeutet, es gibt viele Möglichkeiten und ich hab eben schon gesagt, das große durcherzählte literarische Werk mit roten Faden, wie kann Trump passieren und so, fehlt. Was wir stattdessen haben ist eben Hoss und Hopf. Dieses Buch, das einfach sagt, roter Faden in der Weltgeschichte, wieso, wieso Geschichte? Es geht auch um deine Zukunft. Und jetzt liest dieses Buch, das dir jeden Tag sagt, wie du dich ein bisschen besser machen kannst. Also diese totale Verdrehung aus große Vergegenwärtigung, roter Faden, alle lesen dasselbe Buch und reden darüber und werden sich klar, okay, ja, in den Abendnachrichten hab ich das gesehen, aber ich verstehe es jetzt, weil ich keine Ahnung was gelesen habe. Das fällt aus. Stattdessen kommen Autoren, die sagen, wir schreiben hier gar nichts durch, wir lesen uns nicht mal gegenseitig die Texte durch, sondern jeder macht einfach und wirft dir so einen Brocken hin. Inklusive des, und das muss man echt, das ist einfach so witzig. Also dieses Buch hat tatsächlich auch weiße Seiten, damit der Leser Platz hat zur Reflexion. Also die werden weiße Seiten verkauft, damit du dich in das Buch reinreflektierst, statt dass dir ein großer erklärerischer Ansatz geboten wird. Das ist so irre, wenn man sich das vorstellt.
Das ist eine tolle Idee, so könnte man natürlich viele Bücher im Jahr verkaufen.
200.000 mal weiße Seiten verkauft, damit der Leser jetzt auch eine Chance hat zu reflektieren. Also wirklich irre, irre, irre, irre.
Ich glaube, ich schreib mal einen Roman, einfach nur weiße Seiten sagen, da müssen sie sich selbst reinprojizieren, ich nehm aber 20 Euro dafür.
Lieber Leser, ich möchte Sie ernst nehmen, soll der jetzt sterben oder nicht? Am Ende ja, schreiben Sie es einfach hier rein. Und am Ende war er tot.
Ja.
Oder glücklich. Wenn Sie wollen, schreiben Sie am Ende glücklich rein. Irgendwie so, also es ist völlig irre.
Aber du beschreibst das jetzt gerade so, diese Individualisierung, das ist ja auch immer Thema bei Eva Idus, hier weniger als in anderen Sachen, dass das etwas ist, was wir in der modernen erleben. Und wir haben jetzt diesen Rechtsruck. Mir schrieb ein Bekannter aus Österreich, dass die Leute wählen Kickel und dann ziehen sie sich zurück und machen Handarbeiten. Das ist der große Trend. Oder dann eben Haus und Hopf so, das was man so täglich im Griff hat, steh früh auf, mach dein Sport und so was. Aber das ist ja etwas, was wir ja selbst auch gut kennen, dass das auch funktioniert. Also wir haben ja tatsächlich jetzt auf die Geopolitik nicht allzu viel Einfluss. Ja, also ich kann jetzt eine Partei wählen, bei der ich denke, die werden jetzt nicht mit Trump Hand und Hand in Grönland einmarschieren. Aber ich sag mal, das ist sehr limitiert. Ich habe aber jetzt schon, ich habe jetzt aber ja schon in der Hand, wie ich mich ernähre, wie ich Sport mache. Und das ist ja etwas sehr Verlockendes. Du hast ja auch schon hier quasi das Jahr des Sports ausgerufen. Du willst doch auch jetzt 2025 das große Sport machen.
Seit vier Tagen schon dabei, ja.
Ach ja. Und da ist dein Ziel mal gerade was Wichtiges hier. Ist dein Ziel jetzt so ein Deadboard zu bekommen oder geht es um noch mehr?
An dieser Stelle würde ich gerne einen Einwurf machen, unabhängig des Buches. Denn diese Idee von wir haben ja nur Einfluss auf unser eigenes Leben, also unser eigenes Leben, also nicht nur. Häkl und so. Das Ding ist, es gibt Leute in dieser Welt, die sagen von sich, ich will aber Einfluss auf 300 Millionen Leben haben und dann kaufen sie Twitter.
Ja.
Dann wundern wir uns 40 Millionen. Was ist denn das für ein komisches Geschäft? Ja, also hat ihm quasi 100 Milliarden eingebracht. Er hat sich sozusagen doppelt refinanziert von alleine. Plus er hat jetzt noch diesen Einfluss auf diese Free Speech Arena, denn die Leute verlassen ja Twitter dann doch nicht, sondern wir beide auch. Wir machen da unsere Ankündigungen, wie auch immer, was aber bedeutet, irgendwann haben wir es kurz offen und sehen wieder die Top Ten, der blablabla und hier wieder und da und so. Und man hat nicht nur Einfluss auf sein eigenes kleines Leben. Also die Handlungsmöglichkeiten erschöpfen sich nicht im, habe ich jetzt mein Bett gemacht oder nicht, sondern alleine in meiner Nachbarschaft hunderte Menschen, die ich einfach beeinflussen kann. Nur wenn ich es nicht mache und wenn ich mir von Horst und Hopf einreden lasse, und das ist ja auch die Marketing Strategie, die wissen ja genau, 300.000 Hörer des Podcasts, das sind 300.000 einzelne Hörer.
Oder man muss wirklich sagen vereinzelte Hörer. Genau.
U30, männlich, keine Freunde, kein Einkommen, ein Streben mit Bitcoin, hol ich mir noch mal ein bisschen was raus und so weiter. Ja, es mag die Einzelfälle geben, die dann auch sichtbar sind. Also die coole Seite des Publikums. Aber die Masse ist einfach der vereinzelte, ich kann ja gar nichts machen und jetzt noch irgendwie eine Investition. Also ein Roman lesen ist ja dann schon eine Investition. Wo ist denn da der Return an Investment und so? Nee, da mach ich lieber mein Bett. Lese ich lieber eine Seite morgens, mehr schaffe ich nicht und dann mach ich mein Bett. Und das ist schon ein Gedanke, den ich nicht gut finde und den wir auch nicht fördern sollten.
Nein, ich will den Gedanken nicht fördern, weil wir merken da natürlich eine unmittelbare Wirksamkeit. Das andere bedeutet ja wieder Interaktion mit Menschen. Und dann bleibt das natürlich auch da auf einer gewissen Ebene. Aber du hast jetzt nicht die Weltpolitik in der Hand. Also du kannst jetzt nicht...
Niemand hat die Weltpolitik in der Hand.
Ja, außer die, die die Weltpolitik machen.
Ja, die auch nicht so richtig.
Also es gibt schon auch Leute, die entscheiden können.
Ja, aber...
Also die sind Dingen ausgeliefert, das ist schon klar. Der Kontrast ist ja deutlich, dass wir uns zum Beispiel formen können ziemlich gut, dass wir aber relativ geringen Einfluss darauf haben, ob jetzt eine Partei sagt, die Einkommensteuer steigt oder fällt. Wenn die das jetzt entscheiden bei der nächsten Koalition und da steht nirgends im, also nehmen wir mal an, die nächste Koalition will, sagen wir, Vermieter noch mal 10 Prozent Erleichterung geben bei der Kapitalentragssteuer. Da steht kein Parteiprogramm, aber ich halte das für nicht unmöglich, dass in irgendeiner Konstellation so etwas passiert. Dann kann ich da nichts machen, da kann ich sagen, wir müssen mal gucken, ob man vier Jahren nochmal wählen dürfen. Dann können wir was anderes machen. Da ist keine Wirksamkeit. Eine Wirksamkeit ist aber da, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich geh morgen wieder ins Fitnessstudio. Diese Differenz gibt es ja einfach. Die ist ja da und die kosten die natürlich aus und skalieren das und maximalisieren auch diese Idee, dass man nur sich selbst in der Hand hat. Das ist natürlich falsch.
Ja, also du hast recht, aber um uns aus dieser Enge, dieser bedrückenden Enge dieser Argumentation, die ja richtig ist, zu befreien, nutze ich jetzt kurz die Schwungmasse. Ja, es gibt wichtige Leute, mächtige Leute und es sind nicht wir, das sind andere. Wir haben auf die jetzt nicht unbedingt Einfluss. Wir kennen die nicht, wir können die nicht anrufen, wie auch immer. Aber wir können ja mit einem Gefühl jetzt ins Jahr 2025 gehen, zu sagen, okay, wenn innerhalb der nächsten vier Jahre Donald Trump regiert, Le Pen die Präsidentschaft übernimmt, in Österreich Kickl Kanzler wird und Friedrich Merz Kanzler ist, dann besteht ja die Möglichkeit, dass die Welt das Publikum, also nicht die anderen Mächtigen, sondern die anderen, die so sind wie wir, erkennen, ne, das ist gar nicht die Lösung.
Ja.
Vielleicht sollten wir doch mal mit dem Geld anders umgehen. Was bedeutet das, was wir jetzt so befürchten, negativ beobachten, wovor wir Angst haben? Furcht könnte genauso gut schon mal Schwungmasse sein für die Argumentation, die dann folgt.
Denn Enttäuschung wird kommen.
Natürlich.
Vor allem bei denen, die sich jetzt für diese, also für die Wahl dieser Leute entschieden haben. Wir allerdings und das ist jetzt und jetzt also jetzt werden wir getestet. Sind wir bereit, den Zynismus abzulegen, die falschen Coolness Versprechungen hinter uns zu lassen und zu sagen, wir probieren es mit dem ganz kitschigen Prinzip der Hoffnung und zwar nicht als Prognose, sondern als grundsätzliches Angebot einen Möglichkeitssinn, wie sie sagt, zu entwickeln. Also aus einem Gefühl der Selbstermächtigung, es könnte ja auch anders sein, den Weg kenne ich aber noch nicht so richtig. Naja, das ist ja der Grund, weshalb wir hoffen, also das wäre dann Zuversicht da. Also wenn ich da langgehe, wenn ich jetzt jeden Tag ins Fitnessstudio gehe, sehe ich in einem Jahr aus wie...
Ja, da bist du meine Frage ausgewichen. Was ist denn nun jetzt? Willst du ein Deadbot oder soll es noch weitergehen? Weißt du, was ein Deadbot ist? Also der Deadbot ist, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden hab, also Daddy und Body natürlich. Und der Deadbot meint, dass man etwas trainiert ist, auch ein bisschen Muskel hat, aber vielleicht doch einen leichten Bauchansatz, das man quasi signalisiert. Ich genieße auch so das Leben. Ich bin so ein bisschen locker auch drauf. Ich bin jetzt nicht jemand, der nur, wenn ich essen gehe zum Date Putenstreifen mit Felsalat bestelle, sondern ich kann auch danach einen Nachtisch essen. Oder sagst du, ich will den Körper haben, der ja hin zum Sixpack geht?
Ja, genau. Ah, okay.
Das ist ja sehr ambitioniert. Spannend.
Ja, den Deadbot, also so wie du das beschreibst, bin ich ja da schon in dieser Konstitution, oder?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich wüsste nicht, wie ein Deadbot sich da versteht. Aber naja, jedenfalls Hoffnung, ja?
Ja.
Also das, wo man so leicht, wach, bist denn du für ein Träumer? Ja, also man kann ja mal mit Hoffnung rangehen und dann geht sie das eben so ein bisschen durch. Über die grundsätzlich offene, unabgeschlossene Vorstellung von einem selbst. Und das selbst kann ja dann noch ein bisschen größer die vernünftige Welt umfassen. Ihr kann also eine Anpassungsleistung hin zur Glückseligkeit vollzogen werden. Wenn man denn doch nur erstmal anfängt, also nicht von hinten raus denken, sondern von vorne das Ende noch nicht sehen, einfach schon mal hoffend sich an einer lebendigen Zivilgesellschaft beteiligen, statt nur daneben zu stehen und sagen, ne, also der Versuch ist viel zu klein. Das ist ja völlig aussichtslos und so weiter. Sondern einfach so ein bisschen naiv halt an die Sache rangehen und hoffen. Kant nennt sie da, denn der hat ja das Prinzip umgedreht. Wir sind nicht mehr was wir waren und so weiter, sondern wir sind was wir hoffen dürfen. Was darf ich hoffen? Damit hat sich die moralische Perspektive von der Vergangenheit in die Zukunft verschoben und wir sind ja seitdem da geblieben. Sie kommt ja auch über die, ich weiß gar nicht in welcher Emotion sie es unterbringt, aber die Karrierevorstellung von etwas wohlhabenderen Familien, dass dann die Kinder im Kindergarten schon auf die Grundschule vorbereitet werden und in der Grundschule schon auf die weiterführende Schule. Und in der weiterführenden Schule leben sie eigentlich schon wie Studenten und als Studenten schon wie Unternehmer und dann werden sie auch Unternehmer. Also man muss halt immer so einen Schritt zu weit gehen und schon mal so tun als ob. Aber eben hoffend und dann Schritt für Schritt es einfach mit Taten untermauern. Und so wie das, das ist ja auch eine kollektive Leistung, Familien schaffen, kann man das auch politisch schaffen. Also man kann jetzt einfach schon mal die kleinen Organisationen, ist ein bisschen wie Arne Semsrott schrieb in seinem Buch, einfach schon mal im kleinen Leben, wie man sich die Gesellschaft im Großen vorstellt. Das gewinnt dann Attraktivität wie auch immer und dann sammeln sich halt und dann passieren halt Sachen, ja, also so kann man es ungefähr sagen. Und so ein bisschen kitschig an Hoffnung ranzugehen finde ich gut, denn Hoffnung stiftet Sinn, ein sehr wichtiges Prinzip, der es eben Orientierung schafft.
Brauche ich dafür eine Soziologin, die mir nochmal erzählt, dass Hoffnung Sinn stiftet. Also jeder macht irgendwas aus einer Hoffnung heraus, wenn man keine Hoffnung hat, bleibt man im Bett liegen.
Das was du vorhin bemängelt hast, das ist zu wenig Widerstand, Erregungen, was auch immer gibt, zu dem Rechtsruck, der gerade da ist, ist allein eine Hoffnungslosigkeit geschuldet. Keiner kann sich gerade vorstellen, wie es besser gehen kann. Jeder wartet jetzt ab und hofft so ein bisschen, dass sich irgendwer entzaubert oder irgendwer und so weiter und so fort. Und ich finde, nee, hier kann man auch mit Programmen rangehen. Und das wär Hoffnung.
Und sie erinnert eben, es ist eben nicht nur Literatur, meine These ist ja auch, dass eine gewisse Normalisierung einfach da ist, dass gar nicht so viele Leute, die die vielleicht noch nicht wählen, aber grundsätzlich sagen, naja, dann soll die mal machen.
Ja klar.
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass da eine Hoffnung auf Umkehr oder was ist oder gerade eine Lethargie, sondern ich denke, dass viele auch eigentlich ganz gut finden, sich vielleicht selbst noch nicht so trauen zu sagen. So muss man noch Elon Musk bitten, dass er es aufschreibt, aber weil man sich selbst noch nicht so ganz traut, das zu machen. Nun haben wir die Hoffnung, dann kommt die Enttäuschung. Über die Enttäuschung haben wir jetzt schon anhand von Madame Bovary gesprochen. Da finde ich, kommt nichts interessantes von ihr zum Thema Meritokratie. Das ist wirklich nicht, das ist einfach banal.
Auf die Enttäuschung kommt sie ja zu sprechen, nachdem sie das Hoffnungskapitel abschließt mit dem Gegenteil der Hoffnung, nämlich Verzweiflung.
Tod aus Verzweiflung zentiert sie auch.
Der Tod aus Verzweiflung, dieses Buch, wir haben es ja auch mal auf unserer Shortlist gehabt und dann wieder auszuntiert. Ja, weil ich wollte es dann, also es ist mir einfach zu düster. Ich hätte lieber Hoffnungsschriftende Literatur als eine diskriptive Tod aus Verzweiflung, der vor allem die Männer betrifft, die eben hoffnungslos keine Möglichkeit einer positiven Veränderung ihrer Situation mehr gesehen haben und sich deswegen einfach verabschieden. Wir haben ja diesen Film in Düsseldorf gesehen über die japanischen sozialen Suizide, wo die Männer erst mal nur flüchten. Die verschwinden. Sich einer Verantwortung entziehen, da gibt es diese Nachtumzüge, da bucht man einfach so einen Dienst, der beginnt 22 Uhr mit dem Umzug und morgens, wenn alle aufwachen, ist die Wohnung leer, der Typ ist weg und hat eine neue Identität und nach 20 Jahren ruft er beschämt die eigene Familie an und entschuldigt sich dafür, das Kind nicht mit aufwachsen hat sehen, aber er musste gesichtswahrend leider verschwinden. So das sind natürlich krasse, krasse, krasse. Wie soll man sagen, in Amerika bringt man sich gleich um, in Japan hat man das schon so ein gewiss kultiviert. Also da hat man sich noch mal eine Revisionschance in dieses Phänomen mit eingebaut. Das ist natürlich super düster, weshalb wir dann bei der Enttäuschung sind und die Enttäuschung, findest du es nicht gut, wie sie den Tagtraum da eingebaut hat? Die Institution des Tagtraums.
Naja, aber das ist auch wieder so allgemein.
Naja, wenn du es einfach bloß findest, kannst du das ganze Buch blöd finden. Da hielt ich nichts daran.
Ich finde nicht das ganze, ich finde nicht alles blöd, aber ich verstehe die Konzeption nicht. Oder was heißt, ich finde diese Konzeption führt zu nichts. Man erzählt unendlich lange den Inhalt von Madame Bovary, um dann zu sagen, Tagträumen, fantasieren, ästhetisieren, genau hieraus erwächst die Enttäuschung. Inwiefern dieses Gefühl, der Fähigkeit der Konsumkultur eindringliche, ästhetische Erfahrungen zu vermitteln, inhärent ist, lässt sich anhand von Arbeiten der Ökonomen Gietowski und Hirschmann verstehen. So behauptet ersteren seine Analyse der Unzufriedenheit von Verbrauchern, dass Konsumentscheidungen durch zwei separate seelische Triebe ausgelöst werden, nämlich durch Lust und durch Behagen, neue Gegenstände und soetwas.
Weil hier steckt ja die Unentrinnbarkeit der Enttäuschung.
Ja, aber das wissen wir doch schon längst. Also der Hirschmann, das ist ja ewig alt. Also ich weiß nicht, warum sie gesagt hat, ich schreib das noch mal auf. Also das wäre ja, wenn ich jetzt ein Buch aufschreibe, in dem ich sage, übrigens CO2-Emissionen, die verursachen Klimawandel.
Okay, dann versuche ich das mal, was ich interessant finde, dir und den Hörern zu plausibilisieren. Also dieses Enttäuschungskapitel beginnt ja mit bittere Lippen der Enttäuschung. Und es geht um Institution. Es geht also nicht um individuelle Enttäuschung, sondern es geht um eine, und dann ist die Frage, wo kommt's her? Ja, Tagträumen, Fantasien, Ästhetisieren, also eine Vorstellungskraft, die wir bei der Hoffnung gerade noch bejubelt haben, im Sinne von, das ist ein Ansatz, den kann man erst mal fahren. Und zwar ausdrücklich, wenn man das Ziel noch nicht formuliert hat, also nicht wie Lenin sagt, die Revolution machen wir erst, wenn sozusagen in Aussicht steht und so, sondern nein, man kann einfach schon mal hoffnungsvoll rangehen, es sozusagen als Prepping, Anne Semsrott, Prepping for Future. Wir bereiten uns mal vor, was genau, wissen wir nicht, wir kennen ja nicht so genau die Ziele von Trump, wir rätseln, will er jetzt wirklich kriegen mit Europa, oder was auch immer. So und aus diesem Hoffnungskapitel ins Enttäuschungskapitel zu kommen und zu sagen, ja da muss man sich eben, also man muss sich immer bewusst werden, die Enttäuschung steckt einfach drin. Lust und Behagen, Excitement und Komfort, das finde ich super interessant, denn du bist ja jemand, der sich auch immer wieder zeigt als jemand, der ja das Lustprinzip ist auch wichtig, aber der Komfort ist das Entscheidende. Der Komfort ist aber ganz nah oder ganz eng verkoppelt mit Gewohnheiten. Gewohnheiten sind aber typisch nicht neu, sondern alt und gerade das Altsein von Gewohnheiten führt zu einem unweigerlichen Unbehagen, also im Gegenteil des Behagens, man möchte dann wieder eine Neuerung. So diese Neuerung, die man sich und zwar nicht aus innerlichen Gründen, sondern einfach nur Komfortzone verlassen, mal was Neues wagen und so weiter. Das, was ja Trump ins Amt gebracht hat, war ja nicht irgendwie Biden ist zu alt oder Harris ist eine Frau, sondern dieses wir wollen ein Politikwechsel. Wir wollen nicht nur, dass eine Regierung wechselt. Das sehen wir in Deutschland auch. Die CSU, die CDU, also Söder und Merz, ein Gerangel darum, wer das größere Angebot macht. Wir wollen nicht nur eine neue Regierung, wir wollen eine neue Politik. So diese Grünen müssen weg, weil das ist ja alte Politik. Wir wollen jetzt eine neue Politiker. Also ich finde hier bei diesem Enttäuschung, Hoffnung und Enttäuschung, sind wir schon ganz nahe und auch so wie sie es beschreibt, also mit den Fokus, Foki, die sie legt an den Problemen, die wir jetzt gerade haben. Ich find's dann überraschend, dass sie dann Ilko Sascha Kowalczuk, den wir ja nur noch Krawalczuk nennen, seit der nie das Vollklang hat, nennt, weil er noch mal drauf verwies. Ja, die Ostdeutschen hat man immer gefragt. Persönlich alles super, aber das große Ganze passt mir irgendwie nicht. Also man hat da so eine...
Sie erwähnt das in einem Absatz, aber dann ist Schluss mit den Ostdeutschen. Ich finde das einfach schlampig geschrieben. Das stimmt ja auch, was Hirschmann da beschreibt und da kann man auch noch einiges zuzusagen, aber man kann doch nicht alle zwei Seiten ein neues Fass aufmachen und sagen, jetzt fällt mir hier ein Gedicht zu ein und da hat schon mal ein Soziologe was zugesagt. Im Übrigen ist auch freut jemand, der schon über Begehren geschrieben hat. Ach, das wusste ich ja gar nicht.
Also sie kommen mit der Unterscheidung von Lust und Behagen, Excitement und Komfort. Kommen dann auf die Unterscheidung, die Kowalczuk einführte bei den Ostdeutschen, die heute für uns alle gilt.
Der macht irgendein Statement, was gut funktioniert in der Zeitung.
Dann im dritten, also ich finde das super plausibel, so wie du das blöd findest, finde ich das super gut. Ich will es ganz explizit sagen, weil sie dann auf Emil Dürkheim kommen mit der Anomie, also den Zustand der Normlosigkeit. Die Unterscheidung, die vorher aufgemacht worden, bieten eben nicht mehr Orientierung, weshalb sich Enttäuschungen aufsummieren. Bis dazu und deswegen, man muss ja diese Verkopplung, dann kommt ja direkt der Neid.
Ja, dann gibt's die...
Ja, aber die Hoffnung und die Enttäuschung und der Neid, sie koppelt es ja auch explizit unter den amerikanischen Traum, die emotionale Dystopie. Also diese drei Gefühle werden ja schon im Inhaltsverzeichnis als ein Kapitel zusammengekoppelt, weil sie eben zusammengehören. Denn wenn Hoffnung im Raume steht, Obama macht das große Versprechen, jetzt können wir wieder hoffen, dann stellen wir fest, ne, hat sich irgendwie nicht so ergeben. Dann greift die Enttäuschung. Die Enttäuschung mit ihren verschiedenen, ja, das spielt dann auch Neuigkeit wert eine Rolle. Oder wie weit hab ich meine Individualisierung schon getrieben? Oder sag ich noch, ne, mir geht's zwar gut, aber der Gesellschaft find ich irgendwie scheiße. Ich hasse Deutschland, ja. Ich bin zwar ein deutscher Millionär in Dubai, aber ich hasse Deutschland. Das muss man ja erst mal zusammenkriegen. So und dann kommt sie auf den Neid zu sprechen. Und der Neid ist sozusagen das Ergebnis dieses Konglomerats, das dazu führt, dass wir beim Neid ganz explizit sagen, wir reden nicht darüber. Es ist die stumme Emotion und um denjenigen, den wir beneiden zu zerstören, verletzen wir uns sogar selbst. Und das ist genau der Zustand, den wir heute haben.
Ja, das stimmt ja auch. Da bin ich ja gar nicht dagegen.
Und sie ist die Einzige, die das mal so durchgeschrieben hat?
Nee.
Doch. Wo ist das sonst zu lesen?
Also ich kann dir jetzt nicht ein Buch sagen, wo das jetzt woher steckt.
Paralleler Angebot ist zum einen dieses Verlustbuch, uns gegen was verloren und jetzt sehen wir uns in diese Opferrolle und sagen, also Klamüser, aber das ist halt das Buch einmal ausführlich kritisiert.
Und das zweite ist, ich könnte dir zum Beispiel dem entgegenhalten, offenbar hat das gar nichts mit Neid zu tun, denn die Leute, die Trump und Co wählen, sind ja leider zu wenig neidisch. Sie sind ja gar nicht neidisch auf korrupte Politiker. Sie sind ja gar nicht neidisch auf jemanden wie Donald Trump, auf einen Milliardär wie Elon Musk.
Oder?
Also darauf könnte man auch, ich würde sagen, man kann ganz häufig immer wieder das Gegenteil sagen und es stimmt auch. Also ich halte ihre Neid-Analyse nicht für falsch und dass Leute bereit sind, weil sie zum Beispiel die Grünen so sehr hassen, dass sie lieber in den Untergang selbst gehen, bevor die Grünen regieren. Das mag stimmen, das stimmt auch.
Und jetzt müssen wir aber den Neid entkoppeln von der ökonomischen Diskussion. Das ist ja genau die Spannung, die wir haben wollen.
Ja, aber das macht sie nicht, das machen wir jetzt. Das müssen wir jetzt schon ausdrücklich sagen. Sie spricht über den Neid, wie er implementiert wird in den Kapitalismus im Sinne von kompetitiv muss alles sein. Sie bringt natürlich was immer in solchen Büchern dann kommt, die Bienenfabel von Montville und dann geht sie darauf ein, dass also damit der Neid als eine Tugend herausgearbeitet wird im Kapitalismus, dass wer also sich auf sich konzentriert, wer sich also als absolut setzt und daran arbeitet, das Beste rauszuholen, der holt am Ende auch für alle das Beste raus. Wenn jeder an sich denkt, ist an alle gedacht, dass diese, diese Denkweise wird dann implementiert und so hat man ein eigentlich fürchterliches, unchristliches, lasterhaftes Gefühl oder Sentiment hat man plötzlich als Tugend im Kapitalismus herausgegeben.
Vielleicht lese ich das so sehr unter meiner Fragestellung, ja? Also ich bin ja mit konkreten Fragestellungen hier.
Also das ist auch keine falsche Beobachtung, dass das so ist, aber da denke ich auch, ja du hast jetzt nochmal Montville zusammengefasst. Äh, richtig.
Ja, aber lass mich mal kurz referieren, was ich hier wirklich wahnsinnig interessiere.
Wir müssen uns da echt ein bisschen sputen, gell?
Also beim Neid, wir müssen ja nicht alle durchgehen, aber beim Neid. Ich hab ja eben darüber gesprochen, dass ich gerne Sachen in Interaktion klären möchte und nicht ein Verweis auf dritte Werte, Grundgesetz, Satzung, deklarative Momente, irgendwie der Eingangshalle oder was auch immer. Und der Neid ist ja genau die Einflugsschneise dafür. Denn sie schreibt ja nicht, man beneidet jemanden, weil jemand mehr Geld hat. Also das ist ja die typische Neid-Diskussion, wird vorgeworfen, wenn Umverteilung gefordert wird. Nur bei Neid geht es ja um überlegene Qualität, Erfolg und Besitz eines anderen. Also es kann durchaus auch einfach nur die Schönheit, der Erfolg, der Bildungsstand, wie auch immer. So, und dass man sich gegenseitig mittlerweile die Sachen abspricht, im Sinne von, was, du hast eine Befähigung zum Richter, das ist ja gar nicht so wichtig und so, wir können ja alle mit KI-Juristereil-Kram machen und so. Also irgendwie sowas. Das ist doch super relevant, weil über den Neid ja die dritte Partei, Gott zum Beispiel, der eben eine Rangordnung einführt, an der wir uns dann gemeinsam orientieren. Also es ist ja wie in der Soziologie beim Konflikt, der Konflikt ist zwar als Kampf zweier gegeneinander, aber sie orientieren sich eben an einem dritten Wert. Es geht ja nicht nur um die Zerstörung eines anderen, sondern um Konker und so weiter. Also man will ja wirklich Sachen erobern, Sachen haben. Und dass wir hier insbesondere ein Plädoyer brauchen, gerade weil Neid dieses stumme Gefühl ist, das jeder mit sich austrägt und dann tausend Theorien entwickelt. Nein, ich bin nicht neidisch. Ich meine das so und deswegen so und so. Dann verplausibilisiert man so jeden Scheiß. Ich brauche jetzt die Milliarde. Irgendwie so diese Umwege. Also hier gerade beim Neid, es ist doch besonders wichtig, das jetzt als zentrales Gefühl, als die brennende Lava wahrzunehmen und zu sagen, das müsst ihr jetzt im Gespräch oder gar nicht klären. Also gerade hier jetzt kein Verweis auf dritte Werte. Schau dir genau an, worum es bei dem anderen geht. Deswegen ja auch immer meine Frage, wenn jetzt Donald Trump als Milliardär, also Superreich, der mächtigste Mann der Welt wird, der Fokus, den wir haben sollten, ist macht es eigentlich Spaß, in dieser Rolle zu sein? Und ich sehe nicht, dass das Spaß macht. Also hier gibt es nichts zu beneiden. Hier muss jetzt jeder mal seinen eigenen Fokus und dadurch, hier so ein Buch zu haben, wo das mal so kurz thematisiert wird, und zwar mit diesem direkten expliziten politischen Einschlag zu einem ansonsten unausgesprochenen Thema, ist sehr wichtig.
Sie sagt, wir haben eine Kultur des exzessiven Vergleichs. Sie verweist einmal kurz auf die Influencer, bringt auch eine Erzählung von Guy de Montpassant an, um das zu illustrieren, geht dann über zu René Girard von diesem triangulären Verhältnis. Also damit ist er bei René Girard gemeint, dass wenn du etwas begehrst und mir mitteilst, dass du das begehrst, dass ich das dann auch begehre und du plötzlich mein Rivale dadurch wirst, dass ich es vorher gar nicht begehrt hätte. Man muss sich nur den Film Challengers ansehen, dann weiß man wovon die Rede ist. Jedenfalls ist das natürlich nicht nur für Liebesbeziehungen und erotische Beziehungen gültig, sondern auch darüber hinaus, das beschreibt sie. Sie beschreibt es eigentlich nicht, sondern sie zitiert und paraphrasiert René Girard. Ich glaube, wenn ich es jetzt zusammenfassen sollte, meine Kritik an diesem Buch, dann ist das mir einfach zu viel Paraphrase. Es ist wenig eigenständig gedacht und gar nicht eigenständig geforscht, sondern sie geht wild durch, was ihr einfällt und natürlich ist sie belesen genug, um dann René Girard oder so was zur Hand zu haben. Wenn sie zu Marx, auf Marx zu sprechen kommt, dann ist es meistens halb richtig und damit ziemlich falsch, aber ich will das gar nicht jetzt hier wieder ausführen und hier deutlich machen, wo das alles da blödsinnig ist, was sie zu Marx schreibt. Ich will nur mal etwas bringen, was mich wirklich skeptisch gemacht hat, wie weit man ihr überhaupt trauen kann, dass sie diese Literatur begriffen hat. Und zwar, ich springe jetzt mal gerade zu dem Zorn-Kapitel, ja. Bei Zorn geht es also ganz stark um Michael Kohlhaas. Das ist eine Welle von Heinrich von Kleist. Kohlhaas wird aufgehalten. Wir sind also noch in einem Deutschland mit ganz vielen Grenzen. Er darf nicht passieren an einer Grenze, muss da seine Pferde abgeben, bekommt die Pferde erst später wieder. Die sind aber fast verhungert. Man hat die Pferde nicht richtig gefüttert. Und es ist ihm also da ein Unrecht geschehen. So hätte man nicht damit umgehen können. Und Michael Kohlhaas ist dann nachher bereit eine ganze Stadt abzubrennen, nur um Gerechtigkeit zu erfahren. Er trifft da auch noch auf Martin Luther und so. Es ist ein sehr interessanter literarischer Text. Der dann zeigt, wohin Zorn führen kann, sagt sie. Also so ein Gerechtigkeitsfurohr, der bei Kohlhaas vorhanden ist. Und nachdem sie das sehr lange ausgeführt hat, sagt sie dennoch, ja es gibt da noch, der entsteht fast zur gleichen Zeit, eine Essay von Kleist über das Marionettentheater, nämlich heißt dieser. Und da sagt sie, auf wenigen frappierenden Seiten rühmt er das Marionettentheater. Im Gegensatz zum tanzechter Menschen dafür, dass sich der Körper der Marionette ohne Selbstbewusstsein bewege, wahre Anmut behauptet, Kleist sei mit der Abwesenheit von Selbstbewusstsein verbunden. Und sie schreibt dann weiter, Kleist verleiht seiner Faszination für eine Form von Subjektivität Ausdruck, bei der das selbst nicht weiß, was es tut, bei der es ohne selbst auferlegten Grenzen und Beschränkungen agiert, sich des Blickes des anderen und vermutlich auch der Konsequenzen seines eigenen Handels in der Welt nicht bewusst ist. Diese beiden in zeitlicher Nähe zueinander entstandenen Texte zeigen Kleist Begeisterung für Marionetten und für eine Form von Handeln, die nicht vom Abwägenden selbst ausgeht, sondern von einer unselbstbewussten Notwendigkeit. Kohlhass, der gute, herzliche von seinen Mitmenschen, seinen Kindern, seiner Frau geliebte Mann, verwandelt sich in eine hölzerne Marionette, die an den Fäden seines wahnsinnigen Zorns zappelt. Das stimmt einfach nicht. Also das hat nichts miteinander da zu tun. Also Kohlhass verwandelt sich nicht in eine Marionette. Dieser Text mit dem Marionettentheater ist so, wie sie anfangs schreibt. Ihm geht es darum, ob eine größere Anmut darin liegen kann, wenn man ohne ein Selbstbewusstsein, man könnte auch sagen, um es klarer zu machen, ohne Kalkül handelt. Ja, also es geht um die Frage, wenn jemand um seine Schönheit weiß, dann hat das oft das Problem, dass dieserjenige anfängt zu posen oder zu flexen, sagt man glaube ich heute. Damit ist also er sich der Schönheit selbstbewusst und dann würde Gleis sagen, und das macht ihn schon gar nicht mehr schön. Die Marionette, die da so herumzappelt, die weiß nichts von sich und das macht sie anmutig. Die Person, die noch nichts von ihrer Schönheit weiß, die sich noch nicht im Spiegel betrachtet hat, die noch nicht die Kunstgeschichte internalisiert hat, die kann anmutig sein. Darum geht es da. Und Kohlhas ist nicht jemand, der wie ein, also das ist einfach dann das Marionettenkonzept von Gleis nicht verstanden, wenn man dann einfach sagt, ja und klar der Kohlhas ist jetzt so eine Marionette seines Zorns. Weil Kohlhas ist ja eben keine Anmut da und so. Und dann merke ich einfach, sie bindet das, du wirst jetzt sagen, was ist das hier für eine germanistische Exkursion. Aber sie bindet einfach da Kram zusammen, der nicht zusammen gehört.
Das ist einfach Quatsch. Ja.
Und das macht sie an einigen Stellen, die ich jetzt nicht alle durchgehe.
Ich weiß ja auch nicht, warum sie jetzt so viel Literatur da reinbringen muss. Warum du allerdings mit so viel Gewissheit, wie man das zu deuten hat, also ich verstehe, das ist sehr plausibel, wie du das sagst, das macht auch Sinn. Lass mich sozusagen absetzt diese Literatursachen. Ich finde diese Verkoppelung des Neid und des Zornkapitels oder die Reihenfolge, das erste Neid und dann der Zorn. Beim Neid gibt es ja noch einen Mechanismus, nämlich dass aus Neid kollektiv das Ressentiment erwächst, weil ja Neid diese schwierige Verkettung mit dem Objekt des Neids hat, nämlich dass man sagt, mein Nachbar hat einen größeren Garten, ich bin neidisch auf ihn, ich will es aber nicht sagen, also erkläre ich den Garten für eigentlich unwichtig. Ich lüge mich selbst an, nicht nur andere, sondern mich selbst. So, um da rauszukommen, schließe ich mich mit denjenigen zusammen, die schon immer fanden, dass die Typen mit den großen Gärten ja voll scheiße sind. So, wir haben also so eine Art Ressentiment. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage für uns wichtig, abseits aller Literatur, sind ganz in der Politik, warum sind die Ressentiments gegen Reiche wirkloser als die Ressentiments gegen die Armen?
Ja.
Und hier gibt es Erklärungen in diesem Buch, denn diese Armen sind uns einfach näher. Also wir beneiden den Reichen, sagen auch öffentlich, na die sind ja eh alle Idioten oder was auch immer, aber nee eigentlich sympathisieren wir mit den Reichen, wir wollen ja zu ihnen. So und jetzt haben wir ja beim Neid schon gelernt, der Neid institutionalisiert einen Maßstab, einen Dritten, der uns sagt, ja ja, also wenn du so und so musst halt genau das machen, da erfolgreich sein und dann kriegst du auch sozusagen leistungsmäßig das Gehalt, die guten Noten, wie auch immer. So und in dem Moment, wo Ärmere oder Zuwanderer, Ärmere und Andere dieses Spiel erfolgreicher spielen als ich, also mich überholen, nicht den Abstand zu mir noch vergrößern. Also die Supermilliardäre haben jetzt 10 Milliarden mehr. Ja gut, okay, vorher 10 Milliarden, jetzt haben sie 20. So ist mir egal. Aber wenn der arme Andere, der Zuwanderer, der vom Bürgergeld lebte, zehn Jahre später mir plötzlich im Amtszimmer begegnet, dann haben wir dieses mafalaniische Integrationsparadox, das richtig reinkickt. Also da brauchen wir jetzt Strategien.
So auf der anderen Seite des Tisches begegnet.
Genau, also wenn mir der Staat mit Kopftuch begegnet und mir erklärt, was ich jetzt bauen darf und nicht wie das Baurecht auszulegen ist, dann wird es halt kritisch. Also der Neid ist eng verkoppelt mit dem Ressentiment und beim Ressentiment brauchen wir bewusst gewählte Strategien, das einfach nur so geschehen zu lassen ist nicht gut. Beim Zorn gibt es so eine selbe Verkopplung, in dem Falle nicht das Ressentiment, sondern der kollektive bildende Groll und auch da ist es sehr gut diese Lava mal zu sehen. Also von ihr das so.
Aber du hast sogar das Buch von Slotadeik gelesen. Wir haben doch ein schönes Zornbuch.
Zorn und Zeit ist natürlich mega geil, also wirklich ein spektakuläres Buch, aber eine Erinnerung hier und eine, und das macht ja Slotadeik nicht, also Slotadeik traut sich nicht uncool zu sein, sozusagen über Gefühle und so zu schreiben. Das ist halt dieser Vorteil hier. Es ist ein Vorteil, dass sie das macht. Naja, der Zorn. Darauf folgt die Furcht.
Ach, die haben wir auch noch, genau. Ich war schon bei dem Scham.
Ja, die Furcht, können wir kurz nennen, sie ist ein überragendes Gefühl. Also wenn Furcht im Spiel ist, ist alles andere egal. Wer Angst hat, hat Recht. Wer Angst hat, droht ein Opfer zu sein und ist damit schon jetzt ein Opfer. Die Opfer-Olympiade wird gespielt und so weiter und so fort. Hier finde ich auch, hätte es einen literarischen Zuschlag zum Thema Virtualität. Die ausgedachte Furcht, die instrumentalisierte Furcht, also die...
Ja, sie kategorisiert ja hier und sagt, es gibt vier Formen der Furcht und dann würde ich sagen, mir fallen jetzt ein paar mehr ein. Sie geht dann sehr lange auf Corona ein, die pastorale Furcht.
Die Corona-Pandemie war halt so eine globale, alles überstrahlendes Furchtereignis. Ja. Also Furcht, gerade bei der Furcht, finde ich, ist der instrumentelle Teil der Politik. Also es wird ja... Also Oma Erna wird ja direkt in Furcht versetzt.
Genau, sie sagt ja eigentlich ist der Liberalismus das Versprechen, dass man nicht mehr in Furcht leben muss. Das ist ja das, worum es da eigentlich geht. Aber sie sagt dann, das stimmt ja gar nicht. Und da hat sie auch völlig recht. Denn in gewissen Ernstfällen ist der Staat, zum Beispiel bei Krieg und Frieden, doch wieder derjenige, der Furcht verbreitet, der sagt, wir haben Furcht vor den Gegnern, deshalb müssen wir jetzt alle kämpfen oder sonst etwas. Und plötzlich ist man auch nicht mehr frei, kann man nicht mehr entscheiden, wo man hingehen kann und plötzlich ist also die Furcht etwas, was auch in noch so liberalen Demokratien immer wieder als politisches Mittel eingesetzt werden kann und auch eingesetzt wird. Das, finde ich, arbeitet sie gut heraus und auch diese Tatsache, dass sie sagt, wenn der Liberalismus immer sagt, ja das legitimierende Grundprinzip dieses Systems ist, Furcht und Grausamkeit aus der Gesellschaft zu verbannen, dann sagt sie, ja das funktioniert hat immer dann, wenn gerade alles super läuft, dann braucht man auch keine Furcht und keine Grausamkeit. Aber sobald etwas dann ernster wird, sieht man dann doch plötzlich wieder, wie die Furcht und die Grausamkeit kommt. Da hat sie völlig recht. Dann die Rausführung zur Corona allerdings, finde ich jetzt ja so brav nochmal nachreportiert, was da passiert ist, wie so eine pastorale Furcht sich ausbreitet, wie man also bereit war, die Menschen zu schützen und dass diejenigen, die ohnehin den Staat blöd fanden, dann natürlich auch die Corona-Experten blöd fanden, weil die vom Staat aus kamen und die haben dann eine Furcht verbreitet, die andere als eine falsche Furcht angesehen haben. Okay, ist fraglich, ob man da nicht hätte ein bisschen mehr mitmachen können oder man hätte es rausgelassen, ja.
Es ist wie so häufig. Corona kommt als Kapitel rein, pflichtbewusst, weil man ja Zeitgeist und so. Ich hätte auch noch mal gesagt, die Corona-Furcht war ja zuerst einmal das Fremde, was für die Furcht ja so wichtig ist, wie sie schreibt, man kommt dann auf Simmel und so zu sprechen. Das Fremde war in dem Falle erst mal ein Virus.
Ja.
Bevor der Staat plötzlich wieder als Machtinstitution seine Seitenhandschuhe, wie es heißt hier, von Söderberg abstreifte und man dann wieder die Mächtigen fürchten musste oder eben völlig unlegitimierte Wissenschaftler, die dem Staat diktierten, wie es jetzt zu handeln ist und so. Das Furcht-Kapitel wird aber doch noch mal schön auf Furcht vor anderen Menschen eigentlich. Also deswegen fällt Corona da kategorial so ein bisschen raus. Aber dieser andere und da kommt auch wieder das dritte ins Spiel. Also der Fremde bei Simmel, der heute kommt und morgen bleibt, war plötzlich einfügbar in Sozialgefüge über abstrakte moderne Medien wie Geld. Nicht indem man sich mit ihm erst mal beschäftigt hat und befasst hat und so weiter und da so eine Integrationsleistung, sondern und so streiten wir ja auch heute übers Geld. Ja, jetzt geben wir ihm kein Geld. Es geben ihm eine Bezahlkarte, also ja alles dieser.
Genau, das ist eine Maßnahme, um Integration zu verhindern.
Genau, also da wird der Fremde einfach in seinem fremden Zustand gelassen, sozusagen, wenn jetzt ihm selbst noch das Geld verweigert wird. Und die Theorie der Entfremdung bringt sie da rein. Vielleicht kann sie da, ist jetzt nicht Literatur, es ist Karl Marx, aber über die Furcht, über den Fremden kommt sie zur Theorie der Entfremdung.
Soll ich es zitieren?
Bei Marx, ja.
In kürzest möglicher Form lautet Marx Theorie der Entfremdung. Das System der kapitalistischen Produktion und das Klassensystem entfremden den Arbeiter von der und durch die Maschine, an der er arbeitete. So wurde er zu einem Fremden seiner selbst, seines Körpers, seiner Fertigkeiten und des Produkts, seiner Arbeit, das ihm nicht mehr gehörte. Was Marx als politischen Zustand beschrieb, war in erster Linie ein emotionaler. Warum ein emotionaler? Nee, das war ein ganz handfester. Das ist nicht einfach nur ein Gefühl bei Marx, sondern da ist jemand, der Dinge beraubt, die er herstellt. Die Menschen konnten sich selbst nicht mehr als Besitzer und Genießer der Früchte ihrer Arbeit verstehen und waren daher auch nicht mehr in der Lage, ihr Schicksal wirklich selbst zu meistern. Der Kapitalismus schuf die Bedingungen, unter denen sich Menschen in der Welt nicht mehr heimisch fühlen, weil ihnen ein grundlegender Wert des Seins enteignet worden ist. Aber Marx kritisiert ja nicht, dass wir dahin wieder zurück sollen, sondern Marx kritisiert ja nicht die Entfremdung daran, dass wir eine arbeitsteilige Produktion haben. Das ist ja nicht sein Ding.
Hier bitte ich jetzt stellvertretend für die Autorin für Humor.
Ja Moment, Marx sagt doch mit dieser Entfremdung natürlich, dass es diese Arbeitsteiligkeit gibt. Aber es geht ja vor allem darum, dass der Arbeiter etwas schafft, dass dann dieses merkwürdige Ding mit den theologischen Mucken ist, nämlich diese Ware, die dann so ein Eigenleben führt. Und dieses ist eines, das vom Kapitalismus gelenkt wird. Ja, es ist also das Kapital ist die Macht, der man gegenübersteht. Und dieses Verhältnis von der Arbeitskraft, die man verkaufen muss und dem Kapital, das sie kauft. Das sorgt für eine Entfremdung, wo Marx jetzt nicht sagt, wenn man wieder in eine Wirtschaft zurückkommt, wo man Substanz hat, ja dann ist wieder gut, sondern er sagt ja gerade, wir müssen dahin kommen, dass die Produktionsmittel vergesellschaftet werden. Und damit ist dann das, was hergestellt wird, natürlich wieder im Besitz der Gesellschaft, was aber nicht jetzt zum Beispiel eine Abwicklung der arbeitsteiligen Gesellschaft meint, weil das ja gar nicht möglich wäre, es sei denn, man sagt, man will jetzt wieder ins 18. oder 17. Jahrhundert zurück.
Ja, also interessant ist ja, dass das Kapital, damit meine ich jetzt den Begriff, der natürlich interessanterweise als Buchtitel da dient, ein Verweis auf etwas zuvor unausgesprochenes, also ungesehene, aber brennende Lava. Wir müssen uns mal um das Kapital befassen. Also nicht um den Arbeiter, der leidet, den superreichen Kapitalisten, wie auch immer, sondern das Kapital selbst. So, hier finden also Verkopplungsgeschichten über Kapital statt und die sind zu explizieren, weil vorher wurden sie noch nicht beschrieben. 130 Jahre, 140 Jahre später haben Gunnar Heinsan und Otto Steiger immer noch ein Buch geschrieben über die Rätsel der Wirtschaftswissenschaften, nämlich das Eigentum, Eigentum, Zins und Geld. Das heißt, wir hatten es nach einem Jahrhundert immer noch mit brennender Lava, die wir nicht so richtig sehen wollten. Es gab durchaus einen akademischen Zugriff auf, ja ja, wir wissen, was Geld ist und so, aber in der Politik war das nicht so richtig angesehen. Und ich finde es eigentlich ganz amüsant, dass sie, und vielleicht bräuchte man hier einfach so einen Schlotterdeigartigen Autor, der noch mal darauf hinweist, dass ausgerechnet der Autor, von dem ja immer noch das Sein bestimmt das Bewusstsein, ja und dass sie jetzt kommt, ne, das kann man so einfach gar nicht sagen. Also wenn schon Sein und Bewusstsein, dann ist dieses Verhältnis mindestens zirkulär, wenn nicht umgedreht. Und sie kommt halt gleich so mit diesem, ne, ist umgedreht, das Bewusstsein bestimmt das Sein.
Ne, ich glaube sie ist einfach damit eine typische Vertreterin dieser blinken Akademiker, die ich wirklich inzwischen nicht mehr ausstehen kann. Also ich finde deswegen dieses Interview von Adam Tewes auch so gut, weil sie nicht mehr begreifen wollen, warum es eigentlich geht. Also das ist hier so, dann können wir jetzt gleich auch noch unsere anderen beliebten Autoren aus Deutschland hinzunehmen, wie kriegen wir wieder ein Gefühl her, dass wir wieder verbunden sind mit den Waren, die wir herstellen und ich weiß gar nicht, wo das hin soll. Wenn sie sagt, was Marx als politischen Zustand beschrieb, war in erster Linie ein emotionaler, dann ist das falsch.
Ich finde das witzig vor allem.
Es ist kein emotionaler Zustand. Es ist so, dass man genötigt wird, seine Arbeitskraft zu verkaufen und man ist der Herrschaft des Kapitals ausgesetzt. Und jeder, der jetzt gerade arbeiten geht oder von der Arbeit kommt, der muss sich nicht ausgebeutet fühlen im Sinne von, wie Engels das für die arbeitende Klasse im 19. Jahrhundert beschrieben hat. Aber er weiß, dass er morgen wieder antreten muss. Er weiß, dass wenn er morgen sich krank meldet, vielleicht dann schon gesagt wird, na also war recht häufig krank. Er weiß also, dass er einem einen Druck dort ausgesetzt ist. Und das ist nicht einfach so ein Gefühl, das so entsteht, das so da ist, weil die Produkte, die man fertigt, nicht mehr aus einer Hand sind und weil die einem nicht selbst gehören, sondern es ist diese Art der Herrschaft, die ausgeübt wird. Und mit der will sie sich aber gar nicht beschäftigen. Ich glaube, bei Eva Illes ist die Auseinandersetzung mit dem Kapitalismus deshalb so häufig halb gar, weil sie sich am liebsten nur mit der Konsumseite, mit den Konsumenten im Kapitalismus beschäftigen muss, will. Da aber die meisten Menschen nicht nur Konsumenten sind, sondern auch Arbeiter bzw. Lohnabhängige, ist der Konsum etwas, was dort in der Freizeit stattfindet. Bei ihr scheint es aber anders zu sein. Und ich finde, das blitzt auch bei diesem Corona-Kapitel immer mal wieder so durch, dass ich so denke, ja, da schreibt sie auch so sozialdemokratisch und man hat sich geeinigt, dass man jetzt und so weiter. Das ist aus so einer Perspektive auch geschrieben. 200 Quadratmeter Wohnung, entweder in der einen Stadt oder der anderen oder in der dritten Stadt. Mal gucken, wo man sich aufhält. Und dort ist man dann natürlich aus dem Größten raus. Ich will einfach dort eine Auseinandersetzung haben, zum Beispiel mit Reallohnverhältnissen und warum da einfach eine Furcht da ist, dass man morgen arbeitslos wird. Also. Und nicht, dass ich sage, Mensch, der Laptop, den ich heute gebaut hab, der ist aber irgendwie von mir entfremdet, weil der ja da sonst wo verkauft wird. Nein, die Furcht liegt darin, morgen arbeitslos zu werden.
Lass mich versuchen, ein inspiratives Denkangebot zu machen. Die völlig richtig und ich will ausdrücklich sagen, also in meinem Buch, ich fordere sehr viel Geld. Geld, Geld, Geld. Die Lösung ist Geld. Gegen Armut hilft Geld. Der Zustand der Welt, der lässt sich mit Geld, also es mangelt eigentlich an nichts. Es ist eine Verteilungsfrage. So, ich bin also ganz auf deiner Seite. Ich kenne schon alle Argumente. Du hast recht und das ist der richtige Weg. Aber jetzt trotzdem eine kleine Einflugsschneise, ja. Weil sie schreibt, was Marx als politischen Zustand beschrieb, war in erster Linie ein emotionaler. So diesen Satz, was Marx als politischen Zustand beschrieb. Ihr steckt nicht drin, was Marx falsch gemacht hat, was Marx übersah oder wie auch immer, sondern ihr steckt drin, was Marx, ich lese mal so vor wie ich ihn lese, was Marx zu Recht und alternativlos als politischen Zustand beschrieb, war in erster Linie ein emotionaler. Und das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, finde ich, denn er bedeutet, typischerweise beginnt es mit einem Leidensdruck. Das Leiden ist Anlass für sehr vieles. Die Herausforderung ist dann zu sehen, wo hilft hier eine individuelle Therapie und was ist aber eigentlich ein politisches Problem. Wir hatten das schon mal, äh, die Christina Huckelenbräucher damals zu meiner Zeit in der FAZ, so eine kleine Glosse darüber geschrieben, wenn man die Kosten für Psychotherapie allein erzieht. Das ist von den Müttern, ja. Wenn man die, die der Staat ja mobilisiert, um da zu helfen, wenn man die diesen Frauen einfach aufs Konto überweist, ist ihnen besser geholfen psychologisch, als wenn man sie zur Therapie schickt. Weil dann haben sie nämlich mehr Zeit, sie müssen nämlich nicht zur Therapie und sie haben mehr Geld und alle psychischen Probleme oder viele an Folge dieses Geldmangels, der Armut.
Richtig.
So was bedeutet, die Politik ist sehr häufig die richtige Einflugsschneise für ein psychologisches Problem, wo uns vorgegaugelt wird, liest auch das Buch von Hoson Hopf, die helfen dir. Also spätestens die 56. Empfehlung wird dir helfen und dann folgen ja immer noch 300. Also irgendwas wird schon dabei sein. So wo wir sagen, nee, also 365 oder 300.000 Tipps helfen da nicht. Das mit dieser Ausbildungsgarantie muss klappen und das Studium ohne Armut muss halt klappen und das hat nichts mit dir zu tun. Du scheiterst da nicht und so weiter, sondern das ist einfach politisches Missmanagement. So und das finde ich aber in diesem Satz so gut, dass sie sich einfach traut zu sagen, die Armut, die Ungleichheit, das ist nicht einfach so ein Problem, sondern wir haben es hier mit emotionalen Problemen zu tun, die aber eine politische Behandlung brauchen und das gerade bei dem Autor festzustellen, der nun mal in einer Zeit, in der es andere Gründe gab und driftigere Gründe, das Problem mal zu beschreiben, wie er es beschrieben hat, also gerade bei dem Autor, der dieses Verhältnis von sein und Bewusstsein so für uns deutlich prägte nochmal aufzubrechen und zu sagen, nicht mal da kommen wir um das Thema Gefühle drum herum, sondern selbst beim Hardcore Manchester-Kapitalismus mit krassen, also das ist ja nicht nur Umverteilung, sondern die einen haben einfach gar nichts, nur ihre Arbeitskraft und dann dürfen sie acht Stunden schlafen, aber nur eine Britsche, die sich mit drei Leuten teilen im Schichtbetrieb und so. Ja, also Schichtbetrieb auch beim Schlaf, selbst im bewusstlosen Zustand. Dass man selbst da nochmal darauf hinweist, auch da bitte nicht einfach die Gefühle übersehen, sondern als Ausgangspunkt nehmen, finde ich gut.
Ja, wenn gleich ich nicht sehe, wo sie dann diese politischen Forderungen hat, die du jetzt gerade gestellt hast, die ist nämlich da nicht im Buch vertreten.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja auch ein Zulieferbetrieb und nicht das politische Buch.
Kommen wir zu einem Fazit, dachte ich jetzt. Nostalgie und Heimatlosigkeit? Nein, jetzt kommen, also wir können unsere Hörer auch nicht jetzt mit jedem Kapitel so ausbildlich.
Du wolltest doch über die Scham irgendwas sagen.
Nein, sie geht auf das eine. Also was würde man machen, wenn man über Scham spricht? Nein, man könnte über die Scham von Annie Arnaud sprechen und dann über Didier Erybon, wo sie auch noch mal Rückkehr nach Reims uns jetzt erklärt. Also soll ich das vorlesen? Nein, nein, nein.
Wirklich ist es geradezu lustig.
Sie schildert also ausführlich, Didier Erybon ist ja ein französischer Soziologe, gehört zur Bourdieu-Schule, lebt in der Provinz, in den 60er Jahren, 50er-, 60er-Jahren aufgewachsen, ist schwul, geht in die Stadt nach Paris, macht dort Karriere als Soziologe, zu Hause werden die einstmals sozialistischen, aber etwas homophoben Eltern alle rechts bleiben homophob. Er selbst kann sich verwirklichen in der Großstadt und dann schreibt sie, nachdem sie all das geschildert hat, damit kann ich nun eine Hypothese anbieten, um zu erklären, warum Eribons homosexuelle Scham leichter zu überwinden war als seine Klassenscham. Meines Erachtens liegt dies daran, dass er in den 80er-Jahren erwachsen zu werden und ein intellektuellen Leben in Paris zu führen begann, als sich die schwulen Bewegungen um zwei zentrale Gegenmittel zur Scham konstituierte. Öffentliche Sichtbarkeit und Stolz. Und ich denke mir so, ach nee. Also dass man als homosexueller Professor dann in Paris natürlich besser zurechtkommt und dass das natürlich eine Schamüberwindung ist, die anders gelagert ist als Armut, als Scham zu überwinden, wo eben ganz viele Leute einfach arm bleiben und es dort auch nicht diese Fortschritte gegeben hat, wie bei den homosexuellen Bewegungen, ist doch so auf der Hand, worauf will sie denn jetzt noch hier hinaus, also außer uns das nochmal zu erklären und was wir schon wissen?
Also ich denke und ich habe ja häufiger davon erzählt, wie jetzt in WhatsApp-Gruppen in den Schulklassen einfach klar ist, man versteckt seine Armut nicht mehr, sondern man trägt sie, ich würde nicht sagen mit Stolz, aber es hatte schon dieses Moment der Selbstwirksamkeit, Selbstermächtigung, dass sich schwule Communities offen zeigen, die Schimpfworte als Selbstbeschreibung übernehmen und CSD veranstalten und so. Das war bisher ein Metier für dieses Metier, aber es ist auch eine Methode für die Themen Armut, weil wenn man nicht mehr, also Scham führt ja dazu, dass man so hardcore individualisiert.
Nein, ich hab ja gar nichts gegen die These an sich. Ich sage nur, man kann doch nicht fünf Seiten, zehn Seiten zu Eribon schreiben, um dann am Ende zu sagen, ja, das war ich hab jetzt eine Hypothese, um dann festzustellen, dass es in den 80er Jahren eine Schwulbewegung in Paris gab, die auf Pride setzt.
Ich weiß ja auch nicht, warum das Buch über vier Seiten zu reden ist.
Das ist doch nicht, also damit kann man doch jetzt nicht nochmal ankommen, dass das als eine Hypothese zu einem was auf der Hand liegt.
Gut, bleiben wir noch bei der Eifersucht, als letztendlich die Liebe.
Ja, das ist ja auch ganz furchtbar. Das Eifersuchthema war vielleicht das schlimmste Kapitel.
Findest du?
Findest du wirklich, was sie hier beschreibt? Also ich finde, sie sagt, die Eifersucht, das ist so ein Galgen im Zentrum unseres Begehrens. Ja, die Eifersucht hatte aber auch eben etwas Sehnsüchtiges darin. Sie bezieht sich auf Lacan, der spricht von der Jalouissance. Also das ist auch die Begierde, die in der Eifersucht steckt. Es ist nicht so, sie bringt das Beispiel von Kant, also der Mann, der seine Frau betrügt irgendwo. Wenn man dem sagen würde, wenn du rauskommst, dann steht da ein Galgen, dann würde der nicht seine Frau betrügen. Dann würde das nicht kommen. Und dann sagt aber Lacan, ne ne, manche würden das erst dann machen, haben erst dann das Begehren, ihre Frau zu betrügen, wenn da tatsächlich der Galgen droht. Also das heißt, das Verbot produziert das Begehren im Prinzip. Und auch diese und bei der Eifersucht ist eben das auch sehr stark gegeben. Und so entsteht da auch eine Besitzgier, wie sie das nennt. Ich glaube, dass das von ihr gut beobachtet ist und stimmt und auch gut zusammengestellt ist. Nur dann geht sie, macht sie Kurzschlüsse, indem sie über Femizide schreibt. Und das ist ja auch tatsächlich ein weltweites Problem. Also dass Männer aus Eifersucht ihre Frauen töten. Dann geht sie aber dazu über, dass sie die Eifersucht als etwas ansieht, das nur so eigentlich im patriarchalen System vorkommen kann. Und da würde ich sagen, das ist falsch. Also eifersüchtig sein kann man auch ohne Patriarchat. Auch ohne diese Beziehungen, die sie da beschreibt. Also demnach dürften jetzt zum Beispiel Homosexuelle gar nicht eifersüchtig sein. Ja, da wäre das ja gar nicht mehr.
Die leben ja trotzdem auch im Patriarchat. Es ist ja nicht so, dass...
Es ist ja eine gewisse Struktur in der Psyche vielleicht nach Exklusivität. Nicht bei allen Deuten, aber bei sehr vielen wird es da sein. Und wenn man Beziehungen mit Liebe und Emotionen und all das auflädt, und dann gibt es aber nebenher noch anderes, dann produziert das gewisse Gefühle, die nicht nur darauf zurückzuführen sind, dass wir im Patriarchat leben und dass der Kapitalismus irgendwas mit einer Eigentumsordnung und so weiter einem sagt. Sondern es kann auch aus einer tiefen Verlorenheit heraus eine Eifersucht da sein, dass man sich doch nicht so geborgen fühlt, wie man dachte es zu sein. Ich glaube nicht, dass man diesen Kurzschluss, den Sida macht, Monogamie, gleich Patriarchat, gleich Eifersucht machen kann.
Also ich hab's ja wie gesagt...
Auch wenn es da Zusammenhänge gibt, also das will ich jetzt nicht leugnen und natürlich gibt es ganz viele Morde, die mit solchen Motivlagen entstehen. Ich will das alles nicht leugnen und das ist auch alles sehr furchtbar. Zugleich gibt es aber auch Eifersucht, die nicht zu solchen drastischen Mitteln führt und ich würde auch nicht behaupten, dass das, wenn das Patriarchat verschwunden ist, gänzlich verschwindet.
Ja. Also ich hab's ja wie gesagt so ein bisschen inspirativ gelesen, nicht so sehr als Prüfungsleistung eines literarischen Seminars, wie auch immer, wo wir die Worte hinhauen müssen. Von daher ist dieses Eifersuchtskapitel an dieser Stelle fand ich interessant, weil dieser, wie ich eben schon andeutete, aus dem Buch vielleicht nicht so eindeutig herauslesbar, aber diese Hinwendung zu... Ich schreib hier gleich zu Beginn, das Problem der Moderne ist auch, dass die Politik so wirtschaftlich überwölbt ist. Also dass wir gar keine politische Hoheit haben und eine politische Macht, die spätestens jetzt so eng mit ökonomischer Macht verflochten ist. Und diese ökonomische Macht erst recht stellt so ganz viele Selbstbildfragen. Also jemand fährt mit einem größeren Auto vor, mit teuren Hosen, wie auch immer. Wir, anstatt dann einfach zu sagen, ah ja, da ist aber jemand krass unterwegs, sehen wir das immer auch als Botschaft an uns.
Ja.
Obwohl es ja nur eine Information ist, aber vieles ist immer angegriffen.
So.
Und die Eifersucht führt zu einem besonderen Phänomen, nämlich dass anders als bei den anderen Gefühlen, die sozusagen ein Kollektivierungs- oder ein soziales Moment haben, also aus dem Neid kommt oder aus der Furcht kommt der Groll, aus dem Neid kommt das Ressentiment und so. Also politische Größen, mit denen man halt auch instrumentell arbeiten kann. Haben wir es bei der Eifersucht mit einem Phänomen zu tun, dass, wie sie schreibt, der Eifersüchtige fühlt sich verspottet. Und der Ausweg ist dann so ein individuelles Ohrheit-Erlangen über, er war es eigentlich, nachrecherchieren, Dinge irgendwie das Leben des anderen kontrollieren wollen. Also so ein Femizid ist ja die Verletzung eines Selbstbilds und dann die Rückgewinnung, ich befehle hier. Und wenn ich das nicht, also dann ermorde ich einfach. Und sie haben ja so einen schönen Satz, der Eifersüchtige ist ein Protowissenschaftler. Also der fängt plötzlich an, so ganz, also eine Fragestellung zu entwickeln und dem dann so ganz krass nachzugehen. Bis hinzu, wir hatten uns ja auch mal kurz unterhalten über dieses Gespräch von Philipp Banzo und Ulf Bohrmeier bei Alles gesagt, wo ja noch mal die Richterseite.
Endlich im Podcast werden das von uns.
Genau, werden das so besprochen. Das heißt mal in der Oper. Und Ulf Bohrmeier schildert halt diese Szene, er sitzt da im Strafgericht als Richter und jemand wird des Mordes beschuldigt und es stellt sich heraus, der Typ hatte nur noch sich selbst in der Welt.
Also er hatte eine Freundin, die aber...
Aber nur diese eine Freundin.
Genau, nur diese eine Freundin und die hatte eine Affäre mit, ich glaube sogar einem Arbeitskollegen. Und dann hat er gewartet, bis die irgendwann im Schlafzimmer waren und dann ist er da rein und hat den Mann dann in diesem Falle, den Nebenbohler erschossen und dann wurde er vor Gericht gefragt, haben sie denn nicht Freunde, mit denen sie sich ausgetauscht haben? Und dann sagt er doch, einem hab ich es erzählt und der sagte dann, wird schon dicker. Und dass das natürlich nicht ausreichen kann für eine emotionale Lage, in der man sich dann befindet, ist irgendwie klar.
So und selbst die Freundin, dieser eine soziale Bezug, den er noch hatte, hat er komplett in sein Selbstbild inkorporiert. Also er hat ja sozusagen einfach, nein ich möchte hier diese Grenzüberschreibung, diese Verletzung nicht erleiden, also werfe ich diesen Teil einfach ab. Sie muss jetzt sterben, um mein Selbstbild zu schützen.
Die Freundin ja nicht, das war der Nebenbulle. Oder der Nebenbulle. Aber er ging zu so einer radikalen Tate über.
Harte Grenzziehung.
Weil es eben keine andere Möglichkeit gab, über diese Eifersucht oder diese Enttäuschung oder was zu reden. Ja, so simpel wie es klingt.
Genau. Und ja, ich will jetzt auch nicht zu viele Worte verlieren über dieses Liebe-Kapitel. Das macht sie ja in vielen Büchern, das ist ja dann ihr Metier. Aber als politisches Buch damit zu enden, dass man nochmal über Eifersucht und Liebe spricht. Weil auf der einen Seite lebe als ich erweitere mein Weltentwurf auf jemand anderen, der ihn mit mir teilt. Und wenn das aber schiefgeht und ich verlassen werde, dann geht auch ein Stück Welt und nicht nur jemand. Also diese Verquickung, diese extreme Individualisierung, obwohl man doch gemeinsam durchs Leben gehen will und so. Das finde ich, da sollte man vielleicht ein paar mehr Bücher noch schreiben, wie dieses Ausweichen ins, wie jetzt nicht sagen, komplett Emotionale, aber die große politische Dimensionalität dieses totalen Rückzugs, dieses totalen Verzichts, dieser totalen Vermeidung und wie auch immer. Dann zieht man sich wie so ein Bruttowissenschaftler zurück und so stellt man sich ja viele Leute vor, die dann heute irgendwie hören, Trump wurde angeschossen. Also gehen sie dann erst mal ins Internet und machen so eine Privatforschung und so weiter. Und verstricken sich da in ihrem Weltbild und so weiter. Also dieses nicht mehr vor die Tür gehen, mit niemandem mehr reden. Und das Einzige, was man von der Welt noch kriegt, ist so ein Jahr wird schon egal irgendwie. Ja, das ist, also ich bin selber überrascht, jetzt auch von meinem eigenen Schreiben dieses Jahr. Aber wie sehr, wie krass politisch die Themen sind, von denen wir immer dachte, kommt ja nicht vor in den Abendnachrichten. Also spielt das auch keine Rolle. Aber die Leute wählen einfach Trump, weil sie Ghostbusters gesehen haben. Who you gonna call? Wichtigste Frage. Wen rufen wir an, wenn ja was, ist ja egal was, ich will mich gar nicht interessieren für die Welt, irgendwer muss halt was machen. Und dann wählen 70 Millionen Amerikaner den Milliardär, der so ihnen das Milliardärsein vorspielt, wie sie glauben, dass Milliardäre sind. Alles ist Gold, überall haben sie jemanden, der für sie die Hand langer ist. Wenn sie dann Geschichten hören, dass der in New York so fixer hat, also einfach Anwälte, die für ihnen so Sachen erledigt haben, dann denken die, oh das ist mein Mann. Also es ist für sie nicht abschreckend, sondern das führt sie hin zu diesen Kandidaten. Und das kann man nur auf diesen Gefühlsregungsebenen. Also da gibt es keine Sachaufklärung jetzt.
Die Grundthese ist richtig, es ist nur leider das falsche Buch, aber man kann ja jetzt auf dem aufbauen. Ja, genau. So wenig einig waren wir uns noch nie. Wir sprechen über exklusive Moderne der Soziologin Eva Illus. Ich sage es frei heraus, das Buch ist Mist. Aber vielleicht erleben wir durch dieses Buch eine gewisse Diskursverschiebung hin zu der Politizität von Emotionen. Nämlich darüber ist schon zu sprechen, inwieweit Neid, Eifersucht, Scham dazu führen, dass gewisse Politiker gewählt werden, andere nicht, dass der Rechtsruck sich vollzieht. Eva Illus hat darauf wenig Antworten, hat viel in der Literatur gestöbert und doch nicht so viel gefunden. Aber man kann ja dann unserer Diskussion lauschen, wir haben uns glaube ich noch nie so viel über ein Buch gestritten.
Ja, weil Wolfgang sich an Gefühlen und Romanen aufhielt, wo ich denke, nein, Eva Illus balanciert für uns auf brennender Lava. Darüber kann man mithilfe von Romanen und mithilfe von Gefühlen reden, aber es gibt eben die Misere, der neue Grundbegriff Misere, mit Absicht im Dunkeln gehalten und wir folgen hier auch nur einer Spur und fahren nicht auf einer Autobahn zur Erkenntnis, in der Hinsicht ein mutiges, die Soziologie überbrückendes interdisziplinäres Denkangebot, das wir als Zulieferbetrieb für unsere eigenen Fragestellungen wirklich sehr gut ausbeuten können.
Paradise Now, das außergewöhnliche Leben des Karl Lagerfeld, heißt eine neue Biografie von William Middleton geschrieben, ein Mode-Experte und zeitweilig war ja auch befreundet mit Karl Lagerfeld.
Zeitweilig haben die sich zerstritten.
Na ja, mit Karl Lagerfeld gibt es ja dann manchmal so Aufs und Abs oder sagen wir so, er gehörte mal zu dem Journalisten, die häufiger eingeladen wurden, wenn irgendetwas Neues anstand. Aber es war nie eine ganz enge Freundschaft. Wenn man sehr eng mit Lagerfeld befreundet war, dann bedeutete das häufig auch, dass man es irgendwann nicht mehr war. Lagerfeld hat schon immer wieder Leute aus seinem Leben aussortiert wie alte Klamotten. Wo er sagte, jetzt muss was Neues her. Er lieferte manchmal dann auch merkwürdige Begründungen dafür, warum er mit jemandem nicht mehr befreundet ist. Dieses Schicksal ereilte jetzt Middleton nicht so sehr, sondern er kennt sich aber aus mit der Mode und er weiß auch, wie man an Lagerfeld rankommt. Also wie man an Personen rankommt, die etwas über ihn zu erzählen haben. Das ist wirklich eine ganz erstaunliche Rechercheleistung. Das Buch ist bei Steidl erschienen, dem Hausverlag von Lagerfeld und ich muss erst mal loben, es ist wunderschön geworden. Es ist sehr umfangreich, 600 Seiten insgesamt mit vielen Bildern und Illustrationen von Lagerfeld über Lagerfeld. Das kostet 55 Euro, also es ist wirklich teuer. Es ist ein opulenter Band und es ist eine sehr dichtgeschriebene, sehr lesenswerte Biografie. Nun gibt es ja schon eine Lagerfeld Biografie von Alfons Kaiser, die ich auch schon hier empfohlen habe. Dieses Buch hier funktioniert ein bisschen anders, weil dieser Autor mehr noch den Blick auf die Mode wählt. Der Fokus liegt auch auf den einzelnen Shows, die Lagerfeld realisiert hat. Er hat ja sehr viele Kollektionen entworfen und die werden auch ziemlich genau beschrieben. Es ist aber auch ein tiefer Einblick in die Modewelt, wie die einzelnen Unternehmen zueinander standen, die einzelnen Kouturiers. Es ist aber auch, und das ist vielleicht der besondere Schwerpunkt bei diesem Buch, ein Buch, das davon erzählt, wie Lagerfeld kulturell gebildet war, was für ihn wichtig war und worauf er sich auch immer wieder bezog. Welche Filme er beispielsweise in den 50ern im französischen Kino gesehen hat, die dann vielleicht noch 30 Jahre später ihn inspiriert haben zu einer Kollektion, was er von Literatur hält, auch wie er verlegerisch tätig geworden ist, dann mit Steidl zusammen. Es geht um die besondere Liebe zu Harikraf Kessler, ein Mann, der eigentlich die ganze Art Nouveau-Stil zu, den ganzen Art Nouveau-Stil nach Deutschland und darüber hinaus populär gemacht hat, der ja aber vor allem Tagebuch geführt hat über seine Begegnungen. Und das hat Lagerfeld sehr gut gefallen, dass er also nicht nur George Cross und Henry van der Felde und alle möglichen kannte, sondern dass er auch immer dann mit sehr spitzer Feder aufgeschrieben hat, wie diese Leute so sind. Kessler war zum Beispiel auch mal zu Besuch bei Walter Rathenau. Das wird dann hier einmal zitiert, um so diese Art von Kesslers Schreiben zu zeigen. Und er ist dann bei Rathenau in seinem Haus in Kronewald zu Gast und notiert danach. Er hat die Zimmer selbst gestrichen und zwar im Biedermeier-Stil in lauter kalten, steifen Tönen. Kornblumenblau, Sepia-Braun-Ocker-Gelb, schrieb Kessler. Es ist, als ob wie wenn alles, was unter der steifen Bourgeois-Fassade an toter Bildung, an kleinlicher Sentimentalität und an verkümmerter Erotik steckt, in dieser Ornamentik als Hautausschlag hervorprächte. Das Ganze eine Mischung von steifer Würde und sekundarer Fantasie. Wie wenn ein Bankier und ein Junge, der wichst, zusammen es erfunden hätten. So also der Stil von Harry Graf Kessler in den Zehnerzwanziger Jahren. Das findet Lagerfeld toll. Er hat diese Kessler Tagebücher überall liegen, egal in welchem Domizil er ist. Zum Teil werden die auch mit auf Reisen genommen, dass die immer zugegen sind. Man reiste sowieso bei Lagerfeld mit wahnsinnig viel Gepäck. Es waren also sehr, sehr ausgiebige Reisen, die da unternommen wurden dann. Aber auch wenn die Reisen kurz waren, unter sieben, acht Koffern, ging da eigentlich nie etwas. Er hat ja dann auch so in den letzten 15 Jahren seines Lebens darauf verzichtet, überhaupt noch Linie zu fliegen, sondern ist dann nur noch mit dem Privatjet gereist. Ganz interessant ist auch, wie hier immer wieder diese Eitelkeit von Lagerfeld zu Wort kommt. Es geht also gar nicht so sehr nur hinter das Schlüssel, ins Schlüsselloch zu blicken. Auch hier erfahren wir wieder natürlich so ein paar Details aus dieser Beziehung, die er mit Jacques de Basheer hatte. Auch hier wird wieder spekuliert darüber, ob es jetzt hier eine sexuelle Beziehung war, was Lagerfeld ja immer geleugnet hat. Manche sagen dann, na ja, ganz so war das vielleicht in den ersten Jahren doch nicht, dass das so puritanisch war. Jedenfalls hat ja Lagerfeld dann nach dem Tod von de Basheer, der an AIDS gestorben ist, sehr, sehr stark zugenommen. Er hat sich den Kummer in sich reingefressen, hat nie eigentlich darüber geredet, was da in ihm los ist. Eigentlich diagnostiziert man ihm hier so nachträglich so eine Depression, die er quasi mit Essen bekämpft hat. Und es wurde immer schwieriger auch so, dass er Probleme mit der Luft bekam, dass er ja nicht mehr sich so gut bewegen konnte, obwohl er ja früher auch Bodybuilding gemacht hatte und so. Und jedenfalls war es dann so, dass er irgendwann sich nur noch in schwarzen Anzügen von einem japanischen Designer quasi versteckte, das war so sein Panzer plus Fächer und all das, sodass dieser Körper so mitgeschleppt wurde. Und Lagerfeld war aber dann auch jemand, der gerade so Ende der 90er Jahre oder so Mitte 90er Jahre modisch nicht richtig weiterkam. Also die Kritiken für seine Shows, das wusste ich gar nicht, waren nicht mehr so toll. Also der war ja dann immer mal so bei Gottschalk oder was zu Gast, aber so richtig begeistert waren dann immer weniger davon. Und dann ist es so, dass dieser Biograf jetzt hier, The Middleton, es schafft auch mal mit Frederik Gubi zu sprechen. Das ist der Butler von Lagerfeld gewesen. Wenn manche das mal so im Fernsehen gesehen haben, Lagerfeld hatte bei den Shows immer jemanden im weißen Smoking-Jacket dabei, der ein Tablett mit einer Cola Light hielt. Und das war dieser Butler, der aber nicht nur diese Aufgabe hatte, sondern eigentlich permanent um ihn herum war. Dieser Mann hatte im Elysée-Palast gelernt, kannte sich also aus, wusste, wie man sich so zu verhalten hat.
Er war dabei, also nicht nur zu Hause, sondern grundsätzlich.
Der kam da mit und führte diese Kristallgläser mit sich, aus denen die Cola Light getrunken wurde. Gubi erzählt dann auch so ein bisschen, also wie verrückt, das war, wie er da so alles dann in Biarritz und so empfing. Jedenfalls heißt es dann, das ist die einzige Passage, die ich vorlesen will. Gubi erinnerte sich an einen Schlüsselmoment in Karls Leben im Sommer 1997 in Biarritz kurz nach dem Tod von Gianni Versace. Karl hatte Versace seit vielen Jahren gekannt und war entsetzt über seine Ermordung. Er nahm an seiner Beisetzung in Mailand teil, wo er neben Prinzessin Diana, Sting und Elton John saß. An jenem Tag in Eloria schlug Karl morgens die Modeseiten der Lokalzeitung auf und las die Schlagzeile die letzten Opas der Mode, darunter ein Foto von Karl mit Valentino zu sehen. Er sah jetzt der Butler, er sah mich und den Maître d'Hôtel aus Monaco an und sagte, geben Sie mir die Nummer von Dr. Utre. Auch wenn Karl seine Extremdiät bei diesem Pariser Arzt Jean-Claude Utre erst einige Jahre später beginnen sollte, den ursprünglichen Anstoß lieferte damals der Luria der Schock eines unvorteilhaften Fotos und einer unfreundlichen Schlagzeile. Und dann macht Lagerfeld drei Jahre später diese Extrem-Transformation. Und nicht nur nahm er dann so radikal ab, sondern er war plötzlich auf allen Kontinenten weltberühmt. Vorher war diese Berühmtheit nicht da und das kam durch seine Kooperation mit H&M. Das war das erfolgreichste, was er überhaupt je gemacht hat, weil es überall präsent war. Und danach auch konnte Lagerfeld nirgends mehr alleine hingehen. Also vorher hatte er sich schon auch noch in Paris mal, hat er schon mal noch allein die Straßenseite gewechselt. Das war von da an nicht mehr möglich. Von da an ist dann immer Sébastien und sind Leibwächter und alles an seiner Seite. Es ist ein Buch, das ein außergewöhnliches Leben zeigt, von dem man nichts ableiten kann, in dem Sinne, dass man sagt, das hätte ich aber auch gerne. Oder man kann auch nicht politisch, moralisch daran gehen und sagen, oh das ist aber viel CO2-Ausstoß, wenn man so viel euch hier gegenfegt. Man muss sagen, das ist außergewöhnlich. Es ist aber vielleicht inspirierend insofern, als wir hier einen Menschen sehen, der permanent arbeitet und zwar bis zum Schluss. Er bekommt ja dann diese Diagnose Krebs, macht immer weiter, immer weiter, leugnet diese Krankheit vor allen, außer zweit denen er das erzählt. Als sie ihn irgendwann dann wenige Wochen vor seinem Tod sehen, ich glaube das waren die Leute von Fendi, sitzt er im Rollstuhl und sagt, das liegt nur daran, dass er aber seine Knöcheln habe. Also bis zum Schluss zieht er diese Sache durch und er versucht aber auch bis zum Schluss, sich bei den Leuten in Erinnerung zu bringen oder dass sie ihn nicht vergessen. Das funktionierte vor allem auch dadurch, dass er Blumenbouquets verschickte. Also nicht so einfache Sträuße, sondern das durfte ein bisschen mehr sein. Und noch ein, zwei Tage vor seinem Tod, da war ja eigentlich wieder eine Show in Italien geplant, wo schon klar war, das wird er nicht mehr schaffen, hatte er dann auch nochmal in diesem Blumenladen beauftragt, große Gebinde zu machen, unter anderem auch für Bernard Arnaud, LVMH. Und er war eigentlich berühmt dafür, dann immer Karten dazu zu schreiben, persönliche. Und dann fragten die auch von dem Blumengeschäft, welche Karten denn, welche Wünsche da rein sollen. Und er hat nur noch gesagt, keine Karten. Und da war denen auch klar, das wird das letzte Mal sein. Sie haben damit einen Großkunden verloren, denn er verschickte im Jahr Blumen im Wert von 1,5 Millionen Euro. Das ist ein tolles Buch für Leute, die sich auch für Mode interessieren, muss man sagen. Also es geht auch hier um viele Details, 70er, 80er Jahre in Paris. Was war da los bei Chanel, bei Christian Dior und so etwas. Wen das jetzt gar nicht interessiert, ist das jetzt nicht zu empfehlen.
Gibt es da Fotos über den bunten vor seinen schwarzen Anzügen und so weiter? Ich hab kein Bild von Lagerfeld, wie er mal was anderes anhat, als das, wofür berühmt ist seine schwarzen Anzüge.
Na ja, schwarz hat er schon immer gerne getragen, aber er sah halt mal anders aus. Also jetzt siehst du ihn hier am Strand. Also so sah er eigentlich mal aus. Oder du kannst dann schon feststellen, dass er immer diesen gewissen Look hatte, aber durchaus früher was hermachte so. Also er hatte nicht immer dieses hochstilisierte, mit den weißen Haaren und all das, das kam natürlich später.
Ist auf jeden Fall, wie soll man sagen, jetzt ist es natürlich ein Modemacher. Es ist also ein Buch über einen Modemacher.
Ja, ein Buch über Mode.
Genau. Aber wir können ja wieder ein bisschen davon abstrahieren und sagen, es ist ein Buch über das Körperliche, das Ästhetische, wie auch immer, wo dann die Mode ein Thema ist und Lagerfeld ein Vertreter. Aber insgesamt finde ich schon, sollten wir sowas als vorbildhaft und für uns alle Sinnstiften sehen. Denn diese Art von Hyper-Individualisierung geht ja nicht immer einher mit 1,5 Millionen Euro für Blumen, CO2-Ausstoß für 200 Leute und so.
Nein, ich glaube, was man wirklich davon für sich rausnehmen kann, ist eine gewisse Ästhetisierung des Lebens und der Umgangsform. Du hast uns ja im Teaser dieses Buch der Umgangsform vorgelegt. Und was alle über Lagerfeld sagen, ist, dass er so tolle Umgangsformen hat. Was nicht heißt, dass er immer steifer, sondern er hat ständig irgendwelche Unverschämtheiten auch geäußert über andere Leute und hat wahnsinnig gerne gelästert. Aber er war jemand, der schonen wollte, dass man das Leben ästhetisiert, dass es so wie es ist, vielleicht doch alles ein bisschen langweilig und banal ist. Und das ist auch eben der treffende Titel für diese Biografie. Paradise Now. Also nicht zu sagen irgendwann, wenn ich tot bin, dann ist vielleicht im Himmel alles ganz wunderbar, sondern das Paradies auch hier zu schaffen. Das muss nicht mit einem derart starken Überkonsum einhergehen. Aber ich glaube, was wichtig ist, dass man sich selbst auch ein bisschen am Riemen reißt. Und das finde ich schon ganz gut.
Was auf jeden Fall gut ist, über Leute was zu erfahren oder vielleicht sogar Leute in seinem Leben zu heiraten, bei denen klar ist, hier gelten jetzt mal nicht die allgemeinen Regeln oder meine Regeln oder welche Regeln, sondern wenn dann seine Regeln. Und dann unterwirft man sich und versucht das Beste daraus zu machen. Sehr deprimierend, die Leiden der Generation kühnert. Wir sind wieder im Hier und Jetzt und verabschieden uns von allem, was wir eben toll fanden. Michael Schlieben hat in der Zeit eine Art Porträt nochmal über diese 49 Leute geschrieben. Namentlich genannt werden Jessica Rosenthal, ehemalige Jusuforsitzende, die Mitte Oktober schon sagte, oder hier steht eigentlich eine fröhliche Politikerin, die gerne lacht. An diesem Herbstag blickt sie skeptisch und ein bisschen traurig durchs Fenster auf den Arbeitssitz von Olaf Scholz. Irgendwann spricht sie es aus. Keiner kann die Streitereien mehr ertragen. Die Menschen sind mit der Ampel durch. Also man wusste, okay, hier ist die Straße zu Ende. Wir haben gerade in der Frage der Zuwanderung zu viele Debatten gegen den Populismus der anderen verloren. Und ich frage mich, warum ist das passiert? Carlos Caspar, auch aus diesem reigen SPD. Dem 30-jährigen Sachsen kam es irgendwann merkwürdig vor, dass die drei Regierungsparteien kaum noch miteinander zu Beschlüssen kamen. Die FDP hat eigentlich keine Lust mehr aufs Regieren, aus Verantwortung übernehmen, sagt er. Und da steht hier, ob er seinen Beruf anderen jungen Menschen empfehlen würde. Carlos Caspar atmet schwer aus. Das kann ich nicht klar bejahen. Diese Legislatur war eine der härtesten. Das sagen auch schon sehr altgedehnte Abgeordnete. Spätestens hier. Wenn man im Bundestag auftaucht, dürfen für einen diese Regeln nicht gelten. Also zum Beispiel, nee, nee, das ist grad ganz hart. Wir können grad dieses und jenes nicht machen, weil und so die Weltlage. Nee, nee, ich finde, da muss man sich einfach Wege finden, um das auszumerzen. Natalie Pavlik. Natalie Pavlik hat bis zum Ende gehofft, dass die Ampel hält. Wobei hat sie es wirklich gehofft. Sie ist sich jetzt Anfang Dezember nicht mehr so sicher. Irgendwann, so räumt die 32-jährige Politikern ein, habe sie sich selbst bei dem Gedanken ertappt, vielleicht ist es gar nicht so schlimm, wenn diese Regierung platzt. Nun im Rückblick ergeben einige Situationen Sinn. Also nachdem sie wussten, wie die Ampel zerschossen wurde, da sie vor dem Ampel aus nicht so verstanden hat, sagt sie, plötzlich war alles strittig und es war nicht mehr unbedingt inhaltlich begründet. Also hier sind Politiker festgestellt, dass sie in machtvolle Positionen kommen und reine Publikumsrolle sind. Zuschauer wie jeder andere, noch mit der Superenttäuschung, aber eigentlich bin ich doch hier ein Mächtiger. So, also das ist die Demokratie, über die wir hier reden, die wir die ganze Zeit verteidigen gegen Trump und so weiter. Hier wird es erklärt. Diese 49 Gruppe, die startete mit, wird dann hier zitiert, was für eine Party als es losging. Die potentiellen Minister und Staatssekretäre von morgen. Und klar, die sagen dann, die Rahmenbedingungen der Ampel waren schon extrem. Das haben auch die gestandenen Politiker gesagt. Also es ist wenig verwunderlich, wie es steht, dass auch die Berufsanfänger zu teased verunsichert sind. Da wünsche ich mir mehr Bulldozer. Und mit Bulldozer meine ich nicht Leute, die sich einfach durchsetzen, sondern mit Leute, die die Regeln ignorieren, sich nochmal in die Augen schauen und fragen, aber wir haben doch die Bundestagsmandate. Also wir können doch jetzt hier einfach erstmal so ein bisschen, wir sind doch nur unserem Gewissen unterworfen und nicht so einer Weltgeschehenslage. Naja, es ist jedenfalls wirklich drübsinnig, das zu lesen. Vor allem wie dann hier am Ende, also die hatten diese 49 und die haben sich auch immer wieder getroffen. Sie kamen zu nichts. Wenn sie irgendwo vor, also anwesend waren, waren es saumäßig langweilige Redebeiträge der Fraktions- und Ausschusssitzungen. Das Arbeitspensum war aber dennoch immens. Also die haben sich da treiben lassen von so, keine Ahnung, was man halt so macht, als Bundestagsabgeordneter. Also mir ist es völlig schleierhaft. Und zu diesen Treffen der 49-Jährigen kam es dann schon gar nicht mehr.
Der 49? Was 49-Jährigen?
Der 49 anwesenden oder Mitglieder dieser Gruppe. Weil am Ende war niemand mal da, der das organisieren wollte, sagt Pavlik. Also man hat schon gar nicht mehr den, das ist im Grunde die Hoffnungslosigkeit, die wir hier lesen.
Steht da auch etwas drin über das fehlende Machtbewusstsein? Denn mir wurde immer mal so von Leuten, die da so ein bisschen Einblicke haben, geschildert. Mit denen kann man alles machen. Die lassen sich da durchziehen. Hin und wieder nehmen sie mal noch was für Instagram auf. Da haben sie dann eine gewisse Selbstwirksamkeit und das war es dann. Aber sie haben gar nicht so ein Machtbewusstsein dafür, wie man agieren muss, wenn man jetzt wirklich zum Beispiel mit einer Gruppe aus 49 Personen was durchsetzen will.
Steht hier nicht explizit drin, aber ist der Grundtenor. Und ich würde auch sagen, das Bundestagsmandat, also der Zugang zum Parlament, ist für die alle einfach nur eine Etappe zwischen Ortsverein und was auch immer, verantwortliche Positionen, also Amt statt Mandat und so. Das wird relativ deutlich, aber das ist der Subtext.
Also sie haben sich ja auch nicht öffentlich hervorgetan. Das ist ja auch interessant. Also ich erinnere mich eigentlich nur, dass die ein oder andere, die du da erwähnt hast, so irgendeine Rede hier zur Impfpflicht im Auftrag von Karl Lauterbach, aber sonst ist ja auch von denen nichts gekommen. Man kann sich ja, auch wenn man jetzt nicht nochmal extra dafür beauftragt wurde von der Partei, kann man ja sich nach vorne spielen. Also man muss ja nur mal an Marie-Argne Strack Zimmermann denken, was hat die zu tun? Wir wissen es alle nicht, aber sie ist jeden Tag in den Medien gewesen. Und man kann das auch natürlich dorthin treiben, dass man damit auch einen Einfluss auf die Partei über Bande ausübt.
Ja, also ich möchte, bevor ich jetzt die Lehren, die die daraus zogen, aber meine Lehre ist eben auch, wenn wir ein Kabinett haben, das schon nicht mehr in der Lage ist, etwas zu beschließen, es sei denn die Minister erpressen sich gegenseitig. Also dieser Pau sagt, wenn du meine Kindergrundsicherung nicht auf die Tagesordnung hebst, dann stimme ich nicht für dein Wirtschaftswachstums-Chancengesetz und damit ist es einfach blockiert. Also wenn Erpressungen selbst da stattfinden, was soll dann Einfluss irgendwo anders bedeuten?
Ja.
So, also muss man hier sich Räume erkämpfen, die es nicht gibt. Man muss ganz hoffnungsvoll an so eine Sache rangehen und man braucht Verbündete. So und die hatten weder Hoffnung noch Verbündete. Die haben sich ja nicht mal mit sich selbst verbindet. Das ist ja völlig bescheuert. Also wenigstens die 49 hätten einfach mal einen Unterschied machen können.
Ja und die Öffentlichkeit nutzen. Also die Öffentlichkeit ist ja nicht einfach nur da, um sie zu informieren, sondern man kann die Öffentlichkeit nutzen, um dann Druck nach innen auszuüben.
Genau.
Das ist ja das Interessante.
Ja, das ist völlig absurd.
Man muss es so machen wie Otfried Fischer. Du kennst ihn noch, der Bulle von Tölz. Ja, das hab ich mal gelesen in diesem Buch über Fernsehen von Roger Schawinski. Der war ja damals halt einst Chef und hatte dann mit Otty Fischer den nächsten Deal abgeschlossen, fast abgeschlossen, für die nächste Staffel Bulle von Tölz. Dann ist Otfried Fischer zu wetten das gegangen, warst da bei Gottschanker gesagt, ja und das wird jetzt sicherlich auch einige traurig stimmen, aber der Bulle von Tölz macht jetzt erst mal eine Pause. Der Schawinski ist fast vom Stuhl gefallen, was macht der da? Natürlich hat er den Druck erhöht, dass doch die nächste Staffel wesentlich besser honoriert wird. Ja und das ist ihm auch gelungen. Und genau so muss man eigentlich Politik machen, wenn es anders nicht geht, wenn man nicht da direkten Zugänge hat zum Kanzleramt oder so, dann muss man in der Talkshow sitzen, dafür sind sie da und muss dann sagen, ich mach jetzt von hier aus die Politik und das ist dann auch wirksam.
Genau, also Donald Trump kommt jetzt als der mächtigste Mann der Welt und wir lernen immer, der macht das so transaktional. Also sowieso Deals und so. Transaktional heißt aber, man begegnet sich auf Augenhöhe. Das heißt Donald Trump ist immer davon abhängig, dass die Interaktion gelingt, also jemand muss ihm schon einen kleinen Vorteil einräumen, ansonsten gelingt das nicht. So er versucht das ja typischerweise durch Druck. Also er ruft dann einfach diese Senatsleute an und sagt, also ihr müsst jetzt den und den und hier und da und das will ich und dann passiert das halt einfach. Und es ist völlig ungetestet, was ist, wenn da jemand widerspricht. Weil was will er machen? Das ist das Interessante finde ich gerade mit Paul, also dem FED-Vorsitzenden, den kann er nicht entlassen. Und der hat aber noch zwei Jahre Amtszeit. So es gibt keine Druckmittel des amerikanischen Präsidenten, es sei denn er überschreitet eine Grenze.
Ja.
So dass Donald Trump Grenzen überschreitet, ja er wird halt irgendwas probieren, wie auch immer, wenn ihm da was nicht gefällt. Nur alle anderen haben eben auch diese Möglichkeit der Grenzüberschreitung. Und der Profit kann immer darin liegen, Trump anzuschießen. So, also so stabil wie das gerade aussieht, ist es ja alles gar nicht. Wir leiden ja darunter, dass Demokratie, also unsere Politik nicht mal dann zu wirkungsvollen Entscheidungen kommt. Wenn sich eigentlich doch alle gut verstehen und die allgemeinen Regeln gelten. So, also ist sozusagen noch das Funktionalste, wie man halt so durch den Alltag kommt. Damit schafft man zwar keinen Bürokratieabbau, aber man schafft halt so einen konstruktiven Schritt innerhalb dieser Bürokratie. Nur dieses Trump Zeug, was die da jetzt probieren, da würde ich jetzt auch langsam umschalten von Angst vor Trump, weil jetzt ist er da. Also klar kann man sich jetzt in Angst ergeben. Aber man kann jetzt auch mit so einer nüchternen, also mit so einer soziologischen Nüchternheit sich einfach das Gefühl anschauen, ohne immer gleich diese persönliche Überhöhung, die da medial so mitgestrickt wird. Also dass uns die Nachrichten noch alles hypernormalisieren, können wir jetzt einpreisen. Also für die wird alles normal sein. Aber diese kleinen Besonderheiten und Zäsuren, die werden wir relativ zügig sehen, glaube ich. Also ich erwarte von Trump erst mal nur Paukenschläger. Also die Amtsantrittsrede wird ein Paukenschlag. Dieses erste Haushaltsgesetz wird ein Paukenschlag, weil eben die Regeln sind, Amtseinführung ist die größte mediale Aufmerksamkeit und dieses Haushaltsgesetz ist eben das eine große Gesetz, das man machen kann. Danach ist man dem Philipp Buster ausgeliefert. Also alles, was in diesem Gesetz nicht drinsteht, hat es schwer. So, also muss das mit Paukenschlägen beginnen. Nur mit Paukenschlägen, so ganz ergeben sind eben diese Typen ja auch nicht.
Aber er kann natürlich erheblichen Druck auf Paul aufzügen.
Ja genau, also er kann überall Druck auf Paukenschlägen aufzügen.
Er kann zum Beispiel sagen, es gibt da berechtigte Einwände und Vorwürfe, wir müssten da vielleicht doch auch mal ermitteln gegen Paul, weil da vielleicht was unklar ist. Also da können ja einfach Leute auf diese Weise unter Druck gesetzt werden, wenn man sagt, ja da ist aber juristisch vielleicht was faul und dann kannst du natürlich so schon was machen.
Aber, genau, lass mich dazu noch eins ausführen. Also Trump kam jetzt ins Amt mit einem sehr hohen Maß an Authentizität.
Ja.
Also man hat ihn gesehen und hat einfach gefühlt, was er meint, war ja klar und so. Keine Ahnung. Musste jetzt nicht der Wirklichkeit entsprechen, aber man hat ihm das so durchgehen lassen, man wollte dem Onkel nicht widersprechen, er erzählt da seine Geschichten so ungefähr. Nur, wenn er jetzt so Grenzüberschreitungen macht, wie zum Beispiel dem Paul so eine instrumentalisierte Untersuchung des Justizministeriums und so weiter, dann wissen wir alle, ja gemeint ist eigentlich, das ist halt jetzt der formale Weg, den man so geht. Also Trump muss jetzt relativ zügig und erfolgreich wechseln.
Er kann ihm ja schlechte Reizen zerstören.
Ja genau, also es ist so, Mord und Totschlag ist natürlich immer möglich, also man hätte auch diese, ein CEO wird in Amerika auf offener Straße erschossen, auch drehen können mit, ja es wird jetzt so ein neuer politischer Wind in Amerika, wenn die CEOs nicht, wer nicht hören will, muss fühlen so ungefähr, ja. Also hätte man auch sozusagen, aber doch ist es Luigi, je nachdem. Also mal gucken, was passiert. Das ist jedenfalls alles sehr fragil und man kriegt aber jetzt viel Anschauungsmaterial für neue Sachen. Gut, zurück zur Kleinpolitik, also die Lehren hier, das ist ganz interessant. Aber fast noch schlimmer als das Verhalten der FDP finden viele im Rückblick, dass die SPD sich vom kleinsten Koalitionspartner der hat hat treiben lassen. Dass man es der FDP gestattete, das Bild der Ampel so negativ zu prägen. Es ist eine Enttäuschung, die durchaus das eigene Spitzenpersonal einbezieht. Ja, vielen Dank für den Hinweis nochmal in journalistischen, dass das die eigene Parteispitze mit einbezieht. Nur, so wie sich die SPD-Spitze von der FDP hat treiben lassen, haben sich die 49 von ihrer SPD-Spitze treiben lassen. Also es ist sozusagen derselbe Vorwurf. Wenn man weiß, ich habe keine Verantwortung in der Regierung, sondern ich habe eine Verantwortung im Bundestag, dann kann man das durchaus nutzen, ohne dass man dann gleich glaubt, man gefährdet jetzt die Regierung, weil man mal ein paar Spurenzchen macht. Ein Name, den viele der Jungen nennen, wenn es um das schlechte Image der Ampel geht, lautet Olaf. Nicht Lindner. Bei mehreren Regierungserklärungen konnte ich nicht mehr zuhören, sagt einer. So frustrierend sei es gewesen. Also wenn man seinen eigenen Regierungschef in der Korkanzlerfraktion vor sich stehen sieht und enttäuscht ist, muss man einfach davon ausgehen, dann sind es die Wähler auch und das bedeutet, ein Drittel dieser Mandate hier sind mindestens weg, wenn nicht die Hälfte. Also da muss man das einfach einpreisen und dann auch handeln. Carlos Caspar hat viel darüber nachgedacht. Vielleicht habe man der FDP zu vieles durchgehen lassen, wovon man inhaltlich nicht überzeugt war, aus Gründen der Disziplin und Regierungsverantwortung eben. Ja, aber nicht ihr habt der FDP, sondern du hast einer Parteispitze usw. zu viel durchgelassen. Also es ist schon der richtige Weg zur Lehre, aber man muss sie auf sich selber beziehen.
Ich beginne mit einem Auszug, der so lautet, Irgendwo über uns ist die Sonne die einzige, die wir kennen, doch wir denken beide nicht daran. Aber irgendwie spüren wir die frühe Wärme des Sommers. Sie ist sanft. Damit auch unser Schmerz. Dass wir zusammensitzen auf dieser Bank, an dieser Straße, auf der endlos die Autos hin und her fahren. Ja, dass wir zusammensitzen mildert seinen und damit auch meinen Schmerz, der nie so groß sein kann wie der seine. Der Verkehr stört uns nicht, wir haben keinen Zugang zum Leben des Tages, das sich vor uns in der Entfernung von einem Meter abspielt. Es ist laut, sinnlos lebendig und es stinkt nach Auspuffgasen. Dieses Sonntagsleben auf der Autobahn in der Nähe der Havelschusssee. So sitzen wir auf der Bank in irgendeiner Stadt, in irgendeiner Zeit des Daseins, uns wärmt die einzige Sonne, die wir kennen. Ich habe die Vergangenheit vergessen und sitze da als ein Mensch, der weder zurückdenken kann, noch sich das Morgen vorstellen will. Still ist es trotz des Sonntagsverkehrs. Diese Worte sind 40 Jahre alt, aber wir können sie erst jetzt lesen. Sie stammen von der Autorin Theser Oesly. Sie hat nicht nur als Autorin, sondern auch als Übersetzerin gearbeitet, ist in Anatolien geboren, hat zeitweise in Berlin gelebt, hat auf Deutsch das geschrieben, auf Türkisch wurde es übersetzt und ist auch in der Türkei erschienen zur damaligen Zeit, also in den 80er Jahren. Jetzt aber erst hat sich Surkant dem angenommen und hat dieses Buch veröffentlicht, das den Titel trägt Suche nach den Spuren eines Selbstmordes. Und der Selbstmord, von dem da die Rede ist, ist der des italienischen Autors Cesare Pavese. Dieser ist für Theser Oeslu eigentlich der Autor ihres Lebens. Sie reist ihm nach, will verstehen quasi, warum er sich in das Leben nahm, will verstehen, wie seine Literatur ist. Sie begibt sich auf eine Reise, diese führt aber nicht direkt nach Italien. Sie führt zunächst einmal nach Prag zum Grab von Kafka. Sie wird noch weitere Dichtergräber aufsuchen und sie reist damit aber auch zu sich ins Innere. Es ist eine ganz existenzialistische Literatur, die manchmal eine Heiterkeit hat, aber eigentlich ist alles überlagert von einer großen Melancholie, von einem Schmerz, von dem ja auch hier die Rede war und dabei ist sie manchmal nicht allein, wie auch hier sitzt sie nicht allein auf der Bank und dann sagt sie aber auch ja, dass der Schmerz ihres Kompanen auf der Bank und ihr eigener Schmerz groß sind, aber nicht so groß wie der seine und mit dem anderen Schmerz ist immer der von Jhézard Paweze gemeint, den sie versucht nachzuspüren. Was ist das eigentlich? Es ist wirklich eine ganz besondere Literatur, weil es in dem Sinne kein Reisebuch ist, es ist aber auch kein Roman, sondern es ist eigentlich so, dass wir hier einen Denkerin unterwegs erleben bzw. eine wahrhafte Literatin, die aus der Literatur kommt und wieder neue Literatur, der hinzufügt. Sie beschreibt auch immer wieder, wie sie schreibt, wie sie da sitzt. Sie erzählt von anderen, die auch einen Migrationshintergrund haben, die aber vielleicht nicht enttäuscht sind, noch nicht. Die hineingehen in diese Betriebsamkeit, der sie entfremdet gegenübersteht. Sie schreibt, gestern kamen viele Jugoslawen an den Tisch. Sie sagten vieles in ihrer Sprache. Ich saß müde unter der Sonne und suchte nach Wörtern. Auch die Architekten des Hotels kamen und setzten sich an den Tisch. Sie ließen Cognac kommen. Wir tranken zusammen auf die Liebe, auf die Trennungen. Einer küsste mich. Ich ließ mich küssen. Sie waren freundlich und teilten meinen Schmerz. Dann heißt es weiter. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie empfunden haben, wie sehr sie mir in meiner Traurigkeit helfen, wie sehr sie mir halfen, die Enthaltung wieder aufzubauen. Menschen, einfache, ungepflegte, schmutzige Haare. Allen fehlten Zähne im Gebiss. Wie sehr war ich in sechs Monaten in Berlin an die gepflegten Menschen und an die schönen Gebisse der Westberliner gewöhnt, an ihren Geruch der Duftfabriken. Hier fehlt das alles, aber ich bin umgeben von Menschen, hier klopfen Herzen. Hör auf zu schreiben, es ist Zeit zu lieben, sagt er. Ich höre auf zu schreiben, folge ihm, wir lieben uns in meinem Bett. Ich höre wieder sein regelmäßiges Atmen im anderen leeren Bett. Obwohl ich zum ersten Mal das Gefühl habe, ins Bordell gegangen zu sein, weiß ich auch dieses Gefühl zu schätzen. Ich hatte es lange gesucht. Es war wie Tränen. Dieser Orgasmus mit diesem Architekten des Hotels. Bitter und schön. Als sich die Sonne den Hügel nähert, sitzen wir auf der Terrasse. Er trinkt seinen Cognac mit Kaffee. Er sagt mir, er heiße Zoran. Und das bedeutet Sonnenaufgang. Ich sehne mich nach weiteren Sonnenaufgängen. Und dennoch bleibt bei all den Begegnungen, die sie da hat mit Männern eine große Welteinsamkeit, die sie schildert. Es ist herausragende Literatur. Ich bin sehr gespannt, weil noch ein weiteres Buch von ihr bald erscheinen soll in diesem Jahr, das den Titel trägt, Die kalten Nächte der Kindheit. Also es ist eine große Entdeckung, die man hier machen kann. Und es ist ein Buch, das einen natürlich melancholisch zurücklässt, das einen aber auch trägt durch diese wunderbare Sprache.
Sehr gut, vor allem sehr gutes Format. Im Vergleich zu Lagertales, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass man das auch wirklich lesen kann. Ich will was Heiteres vorstellen. Wir sind am Jahresanfang und die Frage ist, wie werden wir mit 2025 fertig? Es gibt mehrere Autoren, ungefähr zehn oder so, die in der Zeit eine Zusammenfassung ihrer Empfehlungen gegeben haben. Mir geht es im Grunde nur um den Letzten, aber wir bahnen uns den Weg dahin, indem wir uns auch den leichten Quatsch der anderen anhören. Zum Beispiel hat Florian Eichel gesagt, wir sollen auf Zombies ballern. Also mehr spielen. Gaming. Eine Empfehlung, der ich nicht folge, du auch nicht. Vielleicht sollte man dieses Jahr zwischendurch mal auf Zombies schießen. Die haben keinen falschen eingestellten moralischen Kompass, sondern einfach nur Hunger. Ich finde das Bild, wir wollen es ein bisschen ausdeuten, Hunger ist nicht weit entfernt von der Gier. Wir wissen, Milliardäre sind nur Milliardäre, weil sie gierig waren. Sie brauchen das nicht. Es hat keinen volkswirtschaftlichen Mehrwert, dass sich das Geld da so akkumuliert und wie auch immer. Und wir haben ja schon deklariert, über Milliardäre können wir Böses sagen, denn die Eigenschaft, die sie zu Milliardären macht, können sie ja einfach ablegen. Also am Ende bleibt der Hunger. Sie haben einfach nur, deuten wir es also so, was sie tun.
Ja, wenn gleich, also die Geschichte der Zombies im Kino eine ist, die man eher klassenkämpferisch lesen sollte, nämlich der Zombie steht häufig für die Arbeiterklasse.
Ja, kann man ja im Augenblick, die Zäsuren erkennen.
Es ist eher der Vampir, der für den Aristokraten oder auch den Geld-Aristokraten steht.
Lenz Jakobsen, relativ langweilig, sperrt sein Handy immer mal in eine Box, um sich von ihm zu befreien.
Ja, ist aber schon mal sinnvoll.
Ja, aber ja, okay. Er hat nur den schönen Satz dann. Das Gefängnis hilft Opfern wie mir, sich etwas freier zu fühlen. Lass ich ihm natürlich durchgehen, finde ich witzig. Elisabeth von Taden, gemeinsam spielen, allerdings offline.
Das machst du doch, du spielst doch schon mal Pret-Spiele.
Ja, sehr gerne sogar. Das ist das Gegenteil von Weltflucht. Wir haben es also nicht mit Eskapismus zu tun. Spielen macht stark, um sich rauszutrauen ins Getümmel. Das Spiel ist im Grunde, gibt es ja sehr viel Literatur zu, der prototypischen Interaktion, die allerdings solange gespielt wird, ein Test ist, ein Versuch, ein So-Tun-Als-Ob, wie auch immer, aber in dem emotionalen Erlebnis wahrhaftig. Also in deren Sicht ist das schon ganz richtig. Stabile Doppelkopfrunden zum Beispiel immer sonntags vor Myoska. Die Empfehlung, warum auch immer. Ist man auf der einen Seite verstrickt in so eine So-Tun-Als-Ob-Interaktion oder danach guckt man im Fernsehen, also Politik in Anführungszeichen. An Kathleen, ich hab mit dem Namen wirklich Probleme, An Christine Tlusti.
Richtig.
Mensch, Mensch, Mensch, ein zweites Frühstück nach Thomas-Mann-Manier. Am Vormittag die Arbeit kurz zu unterbrechen in diesem Stadium, in dem man zwar allmählich wacht, der Tag aber noch nicht völlig unbeschrieben ist, verleiht jedem noch so tristen Trott eine gewisse Nonchalance. Ja, verstehe ich, aber ich habe eigentlich das Frühstück jetzt abgeschafft. Also beide, jetzt muss ich sagen. Egal welche physischen und mentalen Zumutungen uns dieser Tag abverlangt oder diese Welt abverlangt, es ist besser, wenn man zuvor doppelt gefrühstückt hat. Wie stehst du dazu?
Ich frühstücke auch nur nachdem ich aufgestanden bin und dann ist es erstmal gut.
Andreas Zenka mit Forscherinnen reden, das ist ein bisschen hochnäsig finde ich. Also ich würde sagen, dann nimm einfach GPT. Also halt nicht die Forscher von ihrem Alltag ab, sondern frag GPT. Daniel Gernhardt möchte die Rapperin Döi Schie, ich kenn sie nicht, D-O-E-C-H-I-I wie auch immer. Titus Blume sagt, flanieren statt spazieren. Was ist der Unterschied? Die alte Welt liegt im Sterben, die neue ist noch nicht geboren, jetzt ist es Zeit zu flanieren. Flanieren bedeutet Langeweile und Pläne schmieden. Zwei Dinge, die dieses und auch in den nächsten Jahren essenziell sein werden, denn beim Flanieren weiß man vorher nie, wo man am Ende steht, räumlich wie gedanklich. Finde ich nicht verkehrt. Johannes Schneider sagt, ein Gedicht auswendig lernen. Das ist wie ein Klavierstück lernen. Ja, ist auch nicht verkehrt. Mertin Wortmann auf Spotify stöbern. Ja, stimmt. Wieso stöbern wir eigentlich nicht auf Spotify? Also wir scrollen die ganze Zeit durch Sachen, aber bei Spotify mache ich maximal meine Lieblingsliste an. Aber ich habe jetzt kein Stöberverhalten, aber das ist ja eigentlich der Vorteil von Spotify, wenn schon große Ausbeuterei und so hat man da alles auf einen, in deren Sicht nennen wir es Boomscrolling, gute Musik zu sammeln, statt schlechter Nachrichten. Ivana Sokola, das Jahr 2025 einfach ignorieren, absagen oder canceln. 2025 wird weltweites Gap Year. Keine Ahnung, wie das gehen soll, aber es ist ihr Vorschlag. So, Julia Lorenz, Gesprächsrepertoire ausmisten. Ich lese vor. Mittelinteressante Bargespräche, ungezählte Zeitungseiten und das halbe Internet sind voll von Diskursgerümpel. Ich sage immer Sehgewohnheiten. Das ist noch das bessere Wort. Diskursgerümpel. Dass man mal verzweifelt, mal bocklos von einer Ecke in die andere schiebt. Und es stimmt. Genau so läuft es ab. Je unübersichtlicher die Zeiten, desto größer scheint das Bedürfnis nach rhetorisch geordneten Weltverhältnissen zu sein, nach verlässlichen Phrasen und Themen, die zur vermeintlich einzigen Konstante der Gegenwart führen, zur Erkenntnis, dass alles ganz schön schlimm ist. Ein Roman, der kein wichtiges Buch zur Zeit ist, überhaupt Kunst, die sich schwer auf Deutungsangebote für die Gegenwart abklopfen lässt, gilt vielen Menschen, gilt auch mir im Alltag manchmal als Luxus, den man sich nicht leisten darf, wenn man, wenn die Hütte brennt. Dabei stimmt das Gegenteil.
Ja, sehr richtig.
Genau richtig. Wer sein Gesprächsreportuaren nicht ab und an entrümpelt, an nichts vermeintlich Triviales denkt, der denkt irgendwann gar nicht mehr. Ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Auch nicht zu Musk und Trump und Rechtsdrell. Fangen Sie ein völlig nutzloses Hobby an. Großer Vorsatz für 2025. Ich versuche es und vielleicht finden wir alle bald neue Worte, um Zeiten wie diese zu beschreiben. Also das ist wirklich der Tipp 2025. Wenn man ein Gespräch führt, bei dem man merkt, das habe ich schon mal geführt, einfach aufhören, sich entschuldigen, darum bitten, dass auch der andere jetzt Vorschläge macht, aber so kann es nicht weitergehen.
Ja.
Das ist wirklich sehr gut. Diskursgerümpel ist für mich auch ein neuer Grundbegriff. Ich liebe neue Grundbegriffe. Diskursgerümpel. Und zwar ganz vorwurfsvoll Leuten vorwerfen. Sorry, aber das Diskursgerümpel, ich hab das gestern erst dahin geräumt, ich kann es jetzt nicht wieder darüber. Das ist wirklich sehr gut.
Wir kommen zu Adam Toos. Der hat einer chinesischen Zeitschrift ein sehr langes Interview gegeben, das jetzt auch zu lesen ist auf Englisch in seinem Sub Stack. Ding Xiong Fai hat ihn interviewt, sehr interessante Fragen gestellt. Wir können natürlich jetzt nicht auf das ganze Interview eingehen, das ausgedruckt 15 Seiten hat. Du siehst hier, ich hab dir das gesamte Internet ausgedruckt.
Ja.
Und jetzt will ich aber so ein paar Punkte herausarbeiten. Und zwar einmal wird er gefragt zu John Mersheimer, über den haben wir auch schon gesprochen, über diese strukturellen Realisten. Da hat er ja ihn zum Teil verteidigt, zum anderen ist er aber auch mit ihm im Dissens. Tuus sagt, ich finde die empörte Haltung westlicher Liberaler gegenüber den russischen Ansprüchen auf die Ukraine unredlich. Putin hat seine roten Linien auf der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz im Februar 2007 deutlich gemacht. Der Westen mag Putins Standpunkt nicht gut heißen, aber wenn wir seine Warnung ignorieren, sollten wir uns über die Folgen nicht wundern. Zwischen Russland und dem Westen gibt es strukturelle Spannungen. Das ist keine Frage von Putins persönlicher Ideologie, sondern von großen geopolitischen Gegensätzen, die durch Öl und Gas einnahmen Russlands, die wiederum durch das weltweite Wirtschaftswachstum generiert werden, verstärkt werden. Das teilt er mit Mörscheimer, diese geopolitische Analyse. Sein Problem mit Mörscheimer ist aber, im Wesentlichen schreibt Mörscheimer, gewalttätige Handlungen der Natur harter Männer zu, die bösartige Dinge tun. Aber damit hört sein Denken auf. Es ist eine Abkehr von der Verantwortung, den Rückgriff auf groß angelegte Maßnahmen zu erklären. Und das ist mein Problem mit ihm. Er sagt, ich bewundere seine Kühnheit, darauf zu bestehen, dass wir die Perspektive Russlands berücksichtigen und ich stimme zu, dass Russland nach einer Logik handelt, die nicht irrational ist. Ich schätze auch seine Anerkennung, dass die Ukraine das ultimative Opfer dieser ganzen Entgleisung der Politik ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass den Interessen der Ukraine am besten gedient ist, indem sie ermutigt wird, sich angesichts des russischen Widerstands dem Westen anzuschließen. Aber was er eben nicht sieht, ist, dass man es dann doch so runterbrechen kann, darauf, dass sich da diese Männer gegenüberstehen. Ich bin mir da nicht so ganz sicher, ob ich das teile, dass Mörscher immer das immer tut, weil Mörscher ja doch eigentlich immer darauf verweist, dass Staaten sich gegenüberstehen und dann keine übergeordnete Institution da ist, die das ordnen kann, weshalb man in so eine Konstellation kommt, die aber nichts damit zu tun hat, ob die Männer hart sind oder sonst was, sondern das ist eher so eine nationalstaatliche Logik, die da steht. Aber immerhin haben wir jetzt mal da von TUS einige ganz gute Einschätzungen bekommen. Weiter erklärt dann TUS seinen akademischen Werdegang, auch seinen den Werdegang seines Denkens, wie er beispielsweise von Brünow Latour geprägt ist, was ich gar nicht so nachvollziehen kann. Ich kann es auch nach dem Interview nicht nachvollziehen, aber man kann es ja mal zur Kenntnis nehmen. Und dann wird er sehr ausführlich dazu interviewt, dass ja damals Perry Anderson, so ein wichtiger Marxistischer Theoretiker in The New Left Review einen 47-seitigen Artikel geschrieben hat, der im Prinzip die drei großen Bücher von Adam Toos verreißt. Und dazu hat Toos nie nur Replik verfasst. Er fängt dann erst mal an so zu schreiben, was Perry Anderson wohl an Toos Ansatz nicht passte. Und vor allem wirft er immer wieder vor, dass Adam Toos ein Denker sei, der nicht die übergeordneten Strukturen im Blick habe, sondern der in medias res stehe mit seiner Literatur, mit seinem Denken. Also der mitten drin stehe. Und deswegen könnte er viele Erklärungen gar nicht geben. Toos sagt jetzt, wie unsere vorangegangene Diskussion über Polykrise, Latour, Beck und so weiter nahelegt, habe ich eine notwendigerweise unvollständige, aber dennoch umfassende historische Erklärung dafür, warum uns Struktur in diesem besonderen Moment nicht transparent gegeben wird. Also vielleicht das kann man dann sagen. Also bei Latour geht es ja darum, wir sind nie modern gewesen, dass man eben nicht so eine große Erzählung abliefern kann von der modernen, dass alles sehr viel fragmentierter ist, dass es palimpsestartig aufgebaut ist. Und dann sagt Adam Toos, man kann eigentlich nur die großen Linien erkennen, wenn man sich in medias res begibt. Das Problem mit so vielen Leuten aus so einer marxistischen Linken, wie Perry Anderson sie vertritt, sei, dass sie sich eben nicht in medias res begeben, sondern dass sie am Ende glauben, dass sie mit alten Paradigmen heute neue Phänomene beschreiben können. Toos sagt, letztendlich ist der Hauptgrund dafür, dass ich nicht eine, also es ist eine sehr, sehr lange Antwort über drei, vier Seiten dann, letztendlich ist der Hauptgrund dafür, dass ich nicht eine ausführliche akademische Antwort an Anderson schreibe, nicht meine Ungeduld mit der Oberflächlichkeit seiner veralteten historischen Kritik, sondern die Tatsache, dass er Recht hat. Seine Kritik hat mehr als alles andere meinen bewussten und unermüdlichen Fokus auf das Denken und das Engagement für intellektuelles und politisches Handeln in medias res befeuert. Meine Arbeit ist alles andere als eine Politik der Untätigkeit, sondern zutiefst engagiert. Er verweist dann auch auf sein Buch Shutdown, das haben wir ja auch hier im Salon besprochen. Er sagt, das war für ihn ein Lernprozess. Er hat ja so ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Die Sindflut. Da beschäftigt er sich mit den zwanziger Jahren und der welthistorischen Konstellation. Und da sagt er, in akademischen, historisch linken Kreisen ist man versucht, die Schachzüge klassischer revolutionärer Perioden endlos zu wiederholen. Die Kommentären, die Ausrichtungen der kommunistischen Partei Chinas auf die Nationalisten, die Entscheidungen der Deutschen Republik in der frühen Weimarer Jahren. In Sindflut habe ich mich selbst diesem historischen Spiel hingegeben. In der historischen Nachstellung spielte ich die Rolle eines hartgesottenen, Keynesianischen, linksliberalen Politikers, der keine Angst hat, die Verantwortung für Gewalt zu übernehmen. Ich bedauere, dass ich mich selbst dieser historischen Zeitschleife hingegeben habe. Nicht, weil ich eine andere Position eingenommen habe, als die von Anderson befürwortete, sondern weil ich mich überhaupt auf das Spiel eingelassen habe und damit seine Kritik Tür und Tor geöffnet habe. Ich habe mir erlaubt, aus dem dringlichen Bereich der Gegenwart in die zeitverschobene Gegenwart des akademischen Elfenbeinturms zu kleiden, in dem jetzt 1924 ist und ich ließ mich in eine unproduktive Auseinandersetzung über eine Geschichte hineinziehen, die nicht mehr unsere ist. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass dies eine Art Realitätsflucht ist. Wenn wir uns in einer revolutionären Phase befinden, wäre das eine Sache, aber das tun wir absolut nicht. Es bringt also nur sehr wenig für das Verständnis der heutigen Politik, wenn man sich in einem historischen Disneyland engagiert, in dem wir als Lenin Trotsky Wilson verkleidet sind und uns vorstellen, wer wir gewesen wären und was wir getan hätten. Das ist Geschichtsimitation. Es ist die Art von kindischem Zeug, dass Leute am Computer spielen. Wir müssen erwachsen werden. Es steht geradezu viel auf dem Spiel in der Welt. Die Dinge sind zu dringend. Wir müssen in der Gegenwart sein, so gut wir können voll und ganz in medias res. Also es finde ich sehr interessant.
Ich hab mich schon gewundert, warum da in medias res als Losung verwendet wird. Obwohl es ja um dieses reflexive Verhältnis zum Gegenstand, den man beschreibt. Das ist ja genau derselbe die Diskussion auch im Journalismus. Dieses ständige Abfeiern von wir sind ja keine Aktivisten. Wir interessieren uns für unseren Gegenstand gar nicht. Wir nehmen den Autor, der die größtmögliche Distanz hat, damit es objektiv wird und so.
Oder ich musste sehr daran denken an eine E-Mail, die du verfasst hast vor wenigen Wochen. Wir bekamen eine E-Mail mit schlimmen Anwürfen, vor allem an mich und an dich gerichtet. Aber ich glaube in der ersten Linie zählte das gegen mich, dass wir über Gaza gesprochen hätten und wir sollten doch, also das ginge so nicht und dann wurde nur eine Parallele nach der anderen gezogen, dass man Gaza so betrachten sollte, wie in der Nazi-Zeit die Alliierten gegen die Nazis eben gefeuert haben und Dresden bombardiert haben und deswegen sei das auch absolut zurechtfertigend, dass man also Gaza quasi wie so als Naziland ansieht und da gelten, da muss jetzt nun in dieser Weise agiert werden, in der da agiert wird und dass man das nicht sehen kann, das sei geschichtsvergessen und so weiter. Und da hast du darauf geantwortet, diese E-Mail, ich hab da gar nicht darauf geantwortet, dass das ziemlich unverschämt hat, ist also wie das da formuliert ist, also was uns da alles unterstellt wurde. Aber viel wichtiger fand ich, dass du geschrieben hast, dass dir das schwerfällt, das zu sagen, weil du eigentlich auch immer sagst, blickt auch in die Geschichte und so. Aber du hast dann gesagt, mach vielleicht auch mal das Geschichtsbuch zu und mach die Nachrichten an. Und das ist genau dieser Hinweis auch hier, dass man jetzt natürlich alle Planspiele nochmal von früher durchgehen kann, dass man dann was vielleicht auch gerade mit etwas anderem zu tun hat. Und vielleicht sollte man auch mal die Nachrichten anmachen und da reingucken und was kann man damit anfangen. Und das macht eben Tuus, das erklärt er dann hier. Er sagt dann nochmal diesen Unterschied, der uns eigentlich klar sein müsste, weil wir das gelesen haben, aber nochmal so deutlich herausgestellt zwischen der Finanzkrise und der Corona-Krise. Er sagt, der wesentliche inhaltliche Unterschied besteht darin, dass das Kernstück von Crash, also das war das Buch zur Finanzkrise, was die makrofinanzielle Geschichte betrifft, die durch staatliche Bilanzen stabilisierte Privatbanken-Krise von 2008 ist, während die zentrale Geschichte von Shutdown, also diesem Lockdown Buch, eine Krise auf dem amerikanischen Markt für Staatsanleihen, den Treasury-Markt ist. Dies ist bis heute das große unterschätzte Finanzereignis des letzten Vierteljahrhunderts, wahrscheinlich gefährlicher als das, was 2008 bei den Privatbanken geschah. Der Grund ist einfach, der US-Treasury-Markt ist der Dreh- und Angelpunkt des globalen Finanzsystems. Wenn wir über das auf dem dollarbasierende Währungssystem sprechen, sprechen wir in Wirklichkeit abgesehen vom Handel über den US-Treasury-Markt. US-Staatsanleihen sind die sicheren Vermögenswerte, die in die große US-Dollarreserven in der Regel investiert werden. Die US-Staatsverschuldung bildet die Grundlage des gesamten Dollar-Systems und der Markt für diese Schulden, der eigentlich vollkommen liquide sein sollte, stand 2020 kurz vor dem Zusammenbruch. Das Ausmaß der März 2020 unternommenen Anstrengungen zur Stabilisierung des Treasury-Marktes, die um ein Vielfaches größer waren als 2008, spiegelt die Schwere des Risikos wieder. Warum musste man überhaupt so viel machen, damit das Vertrauen hergestellt wird? Also das ist eigentlich das, wo noch nicht so viel drüber gesprochen wird. Modern Monetary Theory, sagt er, davon sollte man sich verabschieden, sagt er. Sie produziert viel Rauch und nicht so viel Feuer. Was die Krisenreaktion auf Covid bestätigt hat, ist die grundlegende Logik hinter dem monetären Kansianismus und der funktionalen Finanzierung Schulen, die es seit den 1940er Jahren gibt. Die grundlegende Lehre ist einfach, unter extremen Bedingungen, die einer echten Krise ähneln, ist die wirkungsvollste Reaktion einer Synthese aus Fiskal- und Geldpolitik. Man führt gleichzeitig hohe Haushaltsdefizite und Haushaltsausgaben ein und finanziert sie durch Geldschöpfung. Das ist nichts Neues, das könnte man beim New Deal-Regime schon sehen. Man müsste also da gar nicht über das Wesen des Geldes und so etwas nachdenken. Jede Schuldtitel-Emission, die zu Spannungen auf dem Schuldenmarkt führt, wird von der Zentralbank in ihrer Bilanz absorbiert. So hat der Westen den Zweiten Weltkrieg finanziert und so haben wir die Reaktion auf Covid finanziert. Das ist also seine Haltung dazu. Vielleicht noch eine Sache und zwar ist das diese Frage mit der beiden Regierungen. Da meinte er, ja er hat ja seitdem mitberaten und sei aber so stark desillusioniert auch und könnte auch nicht verstehen das oder ja kann es verstehen, aber er schildert das so als ein Problem, dass die Medien immer von Post-Neoliberalismus gesprochen haben. Das ist eigentlich nicht der Fall. Er sagt, ich sehe die beiden Regierungen als einen etwas verzweifelten Versuch, eine zunehmend chaotische Situation mit einem Hauch liberaler Kohärenz zu überdecken. Also das heißt, das eigentliche Problem war immer da, das hat sich nicht gelöst. Er äußert sich natürlich noch sehr intensiv in diesem Interview zu China. Er sagt auch, dass der westliche Klimaschutz in den 90er-Jahren stecken bleibt. Er sagt, sie stecken immer noch in der Klimapolitik der 90er-Jahre fest. Wir betrachten Klimapolitik aus westlich zentrierter Sicht als einen Kampf zwischen progressiven und böse Wichten im Westen, zwischen Aktivisten und CO2-Verbrechern, wie ExxonMobile. Wenn man den amerikanischen linken Klimajournalismus liest, konzentriert sich ein Großteil davon immer noch auf die Aufdeckung von Klimaleugnung, Klimaskepsis und Exxons Missetaten. Aber wenn man sich die 20 größten Umweltverschmutze der Welt heute ansieht, steht Exxon auf Platz 5 der Liste. Wer steht an der Spitze? China, Kohl, Saudi Aramco, Gazprom, größtenteils staatliche Unternehmen aus Schwellenländern, die das globale Wachstum in den letzten 20 bis 30 Jahren vorangetrieben haben. Also hier geht es, sagt er, nicht um Moral oder so, sondern es geht wirklich um eine andere Geschichtsphilosophie. Es ist wirklich ein solcher Wechsel, dass das ganz schwer in die Kopferein zu bekommen ist. Wie kann es überhaupt sein, dass wir jetzt nicht mehr dort federführend sind, sondern es ist die Demografie, es ist die Wirtschaftsleistung dieser anderen Länder, die dafür gesorgt hat, dass der Westen es nicht mehr alleine in der Hand hat. Und damit umzugehen wird ganz, ganz schwierig sein. Er lernt jedenfalls auch schon Chinesisch.
Ja, kennst ja meinen Appell, Europa in ein Museum umwandeln und Amerika ist noch kleiner als Europa. Also man kann zwar ewig lange durch Tricksereien und so sich dagegen wehren, aber am Ende gibt die Demografie den Ausschlag. Und wir haben 500 Millionen Europäer und 300 Millionen Amerikaner oder 350 Millionen. Was bedeutet ganz Europa und ganz Amerika ist 10 Prozent der Welt. Alles andere sind nur irgendwelche medialen Geschichten, die überzeugend sind und dieser Treasury-Markt aus 25 Billionen Dollar in der Hoffnung, dass China da immer mitkauft, wenn neue angeboten werden. Wie das alles aufgehen soll unter Trump, man braucht ja doch so eine gewisse oheitliche, also nicht Bulldozer, sondern mehr so ein Schein des Seins, so eine Gefügigkeit, die irgendwie passt. Also ich sehe das nicht so richtig. Aber mal sehen. Zum Glück haben wir ja TOOZ, der uns dann da auf dem Laufenden hält. Die großen globalen Risiken laut Ian Bremmer publiziert über sein Think Tank. Wie der heißt hab ich grad vergessen, aber steht ja verlinkt. Erstes großes Risiko, GZERO statt G7 oder G20. Gibt keine, also der Mörschheimer ist jetzt sozusagen in seinem Metier. Es gibt jetzt UN-Asian ausgefallen, Weltbank, IWF, Halbgar. Aber es gibt schon gar keinen Interaktionszusammenhang her, wo man sagt, die G7 treffen sich, aber da findet dann irgendwie Indien keinen Platz und so. Ist ja alles absolut. Also im Jahr 2025 ist das, dieses GZERO Prinzip, ein Rezept für eine anhaltende geopolitische Instabilität, die neue Machtvakuums noch schafft. Also aus der Großen resultieren dann die Kleinen mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit für Missverständnisse und Konflikte. Zweitens Regierung durch Autoritarismus oder wie sie es hier nennen, Rule of Dawn. Also Donald Trump. Donald Trumps zweite Amtszeit wird nicht wie seine erste sein, denn er kommt mit mehr Erfahrung und einem Team von Getreuen, die die Hebel der Bürokratie gezielter nutzen werden. Die Kontrolle über die Schlüsselministerium wird genutzt, um Trump und seine Verbündeten vor juristischer Verfolgung zu schützen und politische Gegner einzuschüchtern, steht hier. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das ist so die eine Seite. Die andere Seite ist, dass mit sehr viel Brutalität so Ideologien durchgekloppt werden, die eigentlich keine inherente Logik haben. Oder die nicht allein sind mit der Welt, sondern man versucht dann überbiegen und brechen, das sehen wir ja in Russland auch. Auf der einen Seite sorgt man für so einen komischen Krieg, der zu wirklich krassen ökonomischen Verwerfungen führt. Und man braucht dann irgendwie 30 Prozent Wirtschafts- oder des Staatshaushalts ist dann irgendwie, oder das ganzen BIPs ist dann Wehrtechnik. Und gleichzeitig will man aber den jungen Familien so viel Sicherheit geben, dass sie sich wieder sieben Kinder zutrauen. So und das eine wird eben so strukturell und das andere so semantisch durchgeprügelt. Aber es gibt genau nichts, was da irgendwie als Klammer dazwischenhalten kann. Und so wird es glaube ich in Amerika auch werden. Also es wird gruselig. Drittens, USA-China-Zusammenbruch. Kurz nach seiner zweiten Amtseinführung wird Trump neue Zölle auf chinesische Waren verhängen, um Peking zu Zugeständen zu zwingen. Zu was ist dann die Frage? Ich finde es ja auch sehr interessant, dass die Chinesen gerade so gar nicht irgendwie halten sich ruhig. Also die Europäer sieht man mal zucken so ein bisschen rum und dieser israelisch-arabische Raum ist auch so ein bisschen in Aufruhr und Iran und überhaupt. Aber China wartet jetzt erstmal ab und wird es dann wahrscheinlich die große Einladung geben, den großen Empfang und wie auch immer. Da müssen alle so ein bisschen hoffen, dass der Moment einfach gelingt. Obwohl Chinas Wirtschaft 2025 schwächer dasteht als noch beim letzten Handelskrieg, wird Peking entschieden reagieren und weniger bereit sein, Zugeständnisse zu machen. Also China hat ja jetzt irgendwie gelernt, dass es der Westen ernst meint mit wenn Grenzen überschritten werden, dann und so weiter. Gleichzeitig hat aber China irgendwie, finde ich auch, wahrscheinlich gelernt, dass man es ganz schön weit treiben kann, wenn man etwas will. Also Putin. Also man hält doch ganz schön gut durch. So. Es muss ja nicht immer alles optimal laufen, aber so ein Krieg, wenn er denn läuft, kann man ihn schon kämpfen, würde ich so sagen. Aber mal sehen, die Armee dort ist ja riesig. Viertens, also Global Risks, Trumponomics. Trump setzt Zollandrohungen als politisches Druckmittel ein, um Handelsvorteile zu erzwingen, was Kosten für US-Verbraucher und Unternehmen steigern. Das hat bestimmt schon jemand durchgerechnet, aber dieses Bild von kleiner Einkommenssteuer und Unternehmenssteuer mehr dafür nur noch Zölle. Und dann aber in Weihnachten und 90 Prozent der Weihnachtsgeschenke müssen aus China, also kommen aus China bislang. Dass das eigentlich nicht aufgeht. Also dass da irgendwie dieses grundsätzliche Gefüge nahmasehen.
Naja, man wird dann Tricks finden. Also es ist schon jetzt so, ich sprach kürzlich mit einer Ökonomin, die aus China kommt. Und ich zeigte ihr so eine Statistik von den sinkenden Exporten aus China. Und dann sagte sie, ja, die sind gesunken, weil das jetzt immer über andere Länder noch mal geht. Die haben es einfach dazwischen geschoben, wie wir das mit diesen Ölexporten da auch beobachten können. Und damit ist es dann leichter zu machen und das ist dann auch zu überlegen. Zudem ist das ja wirtschaftlich immer so eine Sache mit den Zöllen. Man kann ihn natürlich in dieser Art erhöhen. Das bedeutet ja aber für die Konsumenten, dass sie dann sich wesentlich weniger leisten können, was auch wiederum bedeutet, dass weniger Geld im Umlauf ist, damit eigentlich der Binnenmarkt geschwächt wird. Und damit hat man eigentlich sich dann auch ins eigene Fleisch geschnitten. Das ist ja nicht komplett so anwendbar, wie Trump sich das vorstellt, dass er quasi durch die Zölle sich eine blühende Wirtschaft finanziert, sondern diese hohen Zölle stören auch die eigene Wirtschaft. Das haben wir mit überall.
Das CDU-Programm. Wir sind gegen, also wir sind für die Schuldenbremse, weil ohne Schuldenbremse würden ja die Parlamentarier machen, was sie wollen. Wir müssen sie begrenzen. Okay, abgehakt, das ist die Ideologie. Dann schreibt doch mal ein Wahlprogramm. Wir schenken euch 190 Milliarden.
Ja.
Also da passt es ja auch nicht zusammen, ne? Also sieht man überall und hier auch bei Trump & Nomex der zweite Teil. Massenabschiebung und eine restriktive Einwanderungspolitik reduzieren das Arbeitskräfteangebot, treiben Löhne und Preise in die Höhe und dämpfen das Wachstum. Also es ist ja auch unvereinbar, diese beiden Sachen gleichzeitig zu machen.
Man kann ja sagen, was wir häufig, und ich will jetzt nicht hier falsch verstanden werden, dass ich Dinge relativiere oder so und sage, ist doch gar nicht so schlimm. Aber was wir ja häufig linken oder linksliberalen Regierungen vorwerfen, ist, das ist ja nur Symbolpolitik. Ja, die schenken uns am Ende auch nur, dass wir einen Namenseintrag ändern können oder so. Aber eigentlich hat es gar keinen Fortschritt gegeben. Jetzt ist ja das Versprechen der Rechten, ich gucke nach Österreich, zu Kickl, Remigration. Er hat ja wirklich sich von Selner das ins Programm diktieren lassen. Während Kickl, also FPÖ und ÖVP schon mal regierten damals noch FPÖ als Junior-Partner, haben ja gar nicht wahnsinnig viele Abschiebungen stattgefunden. Also aus der linken Perspektive immer noch alles eine schlimme Politik und so. Nochmal ganz klawig das hier nicht verharmlosen. Aber es war ja nicht das, was da versprochen wurde. So ist also jetzt auch natürlich die Frage bei Kickl ebenso wie bei Trump. Trump hat schon die Mauer damals nicht gebaut, ja. Also was ist das da eigentlich? Erleben wir da auch wieder ganz viel Symbolpolitik? Erleben wir Emotionspolitik insofern, als man den Hass auf die, die nicht so aussehen wie wir oder so steigert. Aber de facto, wenn man dann abrechnen würde und sagt, ja wie viele Leute wurden abgeschoben oder aufgehalten oder so, dann ist die Zahl vielleicht gar nicht so viel anders wie bei beiden. Man weiß es nicht, aber zumindest war das jetzt auch immer bei solchen rechtspopulistischen Regierungen.
Also die bauen schon eine sehr große Lage an Texas, die sind wirklich groß. Und ja, das Phänomen kennen wir aus Europa, Meloni kommt ins Amt, verspricht Abschiebung und weniger Zustrom und die Zahlen verdoppeln sich. Und die Leute wissen das auch und sagen dann aber, ja aber ihr glaub ich wirklich, dass sie es versuchen. Also man hat so ein Authentizitätsgedanken, der da reinspielt. So fünftens, Russland bleibt eine Bedrohung. Russland ist der führende Schurkenstaat, Moskau bedroht weiterhin die EU und dann steht hier im Text, eine mögliche Waffenruhe in der Ukraine könnte das europäische Sicherheitssystem untergraben und den Kontinent künftig erneut russischen Angriffen aussetzen. Also das ist jetzt nach drei Jahren und so weiter und es geht immer weiter und es scheint mittlerweile auch ein bisschen Strategie zu sein. Mal gucken, was Trump da jetzt durchwirbelt. Sechstens, Iran unter Druck. Also Irans geostrategische Position hat gelitten, dadurch dass diese Stellvertreter Milizen kreuz und quer, dadurch ist Tehran hier ein kommt einem verwundeten Löwen gleich. Mit großen Arsenalen an Raketen und Drohnen. Ein fragiler Staat. Ja, unkontrollierte KI wird noch genannt als eigenen Punkt. Also da können wir alle nur gespannt sein. Keiner weiß, was da passiert. Sie ist jetzt da und wir kennen ihre Potenziale und haben gleichzeitig, kriegen wir es in Podcasts immer erzählt, 2025 wird es erstmal kein großes, nächstes Modell oder so geben, aber die Produktivierung, also dass man das jetzt so in Produkte einbaut, geht jetzt voran. Und jetzt kann man ja im Kopf so überlegen, welche Produkte nutze ich so in meinem Alltag, wie könnte KI da helfen? Und da hat man ganz schön viele Ideen. Und wenn man sich dann überlegt, ich bin ein Militär und welche Produkte habe ich so im Alltag und wie könnte da KI jetzt helfen? Also wirklich sehr kritisch. Angovered Spaces in vielen Regionen, Gaza, Syrien, Teile Afrikas herrscht Machtvakuum. Ohne globale Führungsmacht bemüht sich da niemand um Stabilität. Da würde ich auch sagen, ja, also nachdem ich jetzt diesen Film über den Bürgerkrieg in Amerika, wie heißt er, Civil War, das ist ja so ein Szenario. Wenn das einmal läuft, haben wir keine Probleme, das zu verstehen. Das ist dann wie überall sonst auch. Also wir verstehen den Klimawandel, wir verstehen die Funktionsweise eines Coronavirus und es entgleitet uns politisch trotzdem. Also wenn da einmal das so eine sozusagen niemand bemüht sich um Stabilität, ja irgendwann gibt es da Kipppunkte. Und das kann auch in Amerika. Also je nachdem wie jetzt in Los Angeles diese Feuer und so, wie das da gehandhabt wird, da ist einiges los. Und jetzt interessant, nachdem Trump jetzt Kanada bedroht, steht hier als Zehntes mexikanische Padsituation. Die Präsidentin Claudia Scheinbaum, Schienbaum hat zwar einen überwältigenden Wahlsieg errungen, muss jedoch mit Trumps Drohungen und auf Strafzölle und Migrationspolitik und so weiter sich auseinandersetzen, was eben zu inner mexikanischen Situationen führt. Diese Verhandlungen und Unsicherheiten mit und durch Amerika blockieren Investitionsentscheidungen und bremsen das mexikanische Wachstum in einer ohnehin schwierigen Phase. Ja, so sehen die diese Welt und vielleicht kann man ja eine Weltvergesellschaftung herstellen über diese Drohungsszenarien. Klimawandel, KI auch, Social Media wird wieder ein neues Kampffeld seit gestern.
Mal gucken. Will Teflin hat im N plus one Magazine über Casual Viewing gesprochen, weil Netflix looks like that. Ihm ist aufgefallen, da gibt es seit April 22 einen Film, der heißt The Bubble und dann vier Wochen später kommt ein Film aus, der heißt Bubble. Normalerweise würde man das ja niemals machen, dass beide Filme gleich heißen, aber von was unterschiedlich im Handeln. Bei Netflix alles egal, warum nicht, wird schon keiner sehen, denn das scheint etwas Neues zu sein. Filme werden produziert, ja für wen eigentlich, für was eigentlich, also nicht mehr dafür jedenfalls, dass Leute da sitzen und sich komplett einen Film ansehen. Alles ist sehr merkwürdig geworden. Es ist ein sehr, sehr langer Essay, 15 Seiten lang. Er schildert erst einmal, wie Netflix entstanden ist. Reed Hastings hat ja da so eine tolle Anekdote. Er hatte Apollo 13 ausgeliehen und hat dann vergessen, diesen Film zurückzugeben und musste dann über 40 Dollar zahlen und dachte, Mensch, das muss doch irgendwie anders gehen und fängt dann an zu überlegen. Die Schlussbeahnte dieses Essays, die verrate ich jetzt, ist natürlich, dass dieser Dienst, wo er das ausgeliehen hat, diese Anekdote hörte und sagte, überprüfen wir mal, gab es da mal so eine Ausleihe bei uns, die Apollo 13, wo ihm 40 Dollar zahlen musste? Nein, also diese Anekdote von Reed Hastings scheint wohl erfunden zu sein.
Aber für alle, die es jetzt nicht kennen, wir können ja trotzdem das Prinzip mal kurz nennen, weil ich finde es so überzeugend, dass ich denke, ja gut, okay, hat halt noch so ein Gedankengründungsmythos dazugestrickt, aber dass man keine Überziehungsgelder bezahlt, sondern sich einfach nur ein Film ausleitet. Das finde ich schon mal gut. Guck dir ein, also entscheide dich in der Videothek und nicht zu Hause. Wähle dir ein und den kannst du so lange behalten, bis du den nächsten ausleihst. Also das ganz seriell zu gestalten. Und dann hast du einfach ein Film in der Ausleihe und bezahlst dafür ein Abo. Und hast aber nicht 10 zu Hause rumliegen und oh, jetzt wollte ich die doch Montag zurückgeben, gebe ich die erst Mittwoch zurück und es kostet für alle 2 Euro mehr. Das ist so eine gute Idee. Also das ist so kundenorientiert und da ist so viel Psychologie drin. Eine andere Anekdote, im Schuhladen, du hast zwei Schuhe und dann kommt der Verkäufer und sagt nicht, hier noch einen dritten, sondern welchen soll ich denn auch wegtun. Also dass man immer nur eine Zweier-Auswahl hat. Und das bei einem Film, runterbrechen auf, nimm dir einen Film mit nach Hause und der quält dich dann auch als ich bin noch ungesehen, hallo willst du nicht mal und so weiter. Ist einfach genial.
Jedenfalls eine erfundene Anekdote und inzwischen hat sich Netflix anders entwickelt. Es werden nicht mehr DVDs verschickt, sondern es wird gestreamt. Das war sehr früh dann das Ziel von Reed Hastings. Was aber zu beobachten ist, ist, dass zunächst einmal damit nicht nur die Videothek disruptiert wurde, sondern auch das Fernsehen. Dann nämlich, wenn Netflix selbst anfängt Serien zu produzieren. Einige Schauspieler haben wir aber dann auch recht schnell erfahren, dass sie, wenn sie eine Serie für Netflix drehen, da plötzlich 30 mal weniger verdienen als in einer Fernsehserie, weil es nicht mehr diese weiteren Auswertungswege gibt, diese Beteiligungen. Es ist so, dass Netflix groß investiert in Serien. Die Ausgaben für Inhalte sind von 2013, wo sie bei 2,4 Milliarden US-Dollar lagen, dann innerhalb von sechs Jahren auf 12 Milliarden US-Dollar gestiegen. Und das neue Ziel war dann nicht mehr, das Fernsehen nur zu disruptieren. Es ging auch darum, die Filmindustrie aufzumischen. Da hat man dann auch darauf gesetzt, Qualität zu produzieren. Man hatte also versucht, ja, große Namen zu bekommen. Man wollte plötzlich große Namen, aber man wollte jetzt nicht Blockbuster drehen. Blockbuster-Produktion war etwas, was im Kino immer mehr stattfand. Nur noch der große Superheldenfilm des Blockbuster-Franchise. Das war es, worauf sich die großen Studios immer mehr fokussiert haben. Deshalb, weil man glaubte, man könnte so den Erfolg sehr genau berechnen, vorhersagen, während man ja in den 90er Jahren sehr viel Geld auch mit Filmen, mit Filmen machte, die so aus dem mittleren Segment kamen, die vielleicht 30 Millionen gekostet haben oder vielleicht auch nur 10 Millionen. Aber das war natürlich immer das Risiko, dass so ein Film auch ganz floppen konnte. Also hat man sich immer mehr darauf versteift, IP-gestützte Filme zu produzieren. Das heißt also Franchise, Filme, die auf irgendwelchen Marken aufbauen. Das war eine Lücke, in die ist dann Netflix hineingegangen. Und zwar hat man da gesagt, wir machen das jetzt mal wieder. Wir machen mal wieder die kleineren Filme. Denn 12 Milliarden klingt zwar viel, aber wenn man da jetzt nur 10 Blockbuster mitdreht oder sagen wir 20 Blockbuster, ist auch blöd. Nein, man wollte ja viele Produktionen machen. Und so hat man da 10 Millionen, da 15 Millionen hingegeben. Hier wird Elijah Wood zitiert, der damals in einem Netflix-Film mitspielte, 2017. Ich fühle mich nicht mehr zu Hause in dieser Welt des Kinos, sagt er. Es gab eine Zeit in den 90er Jahren, in der dieser Titel direkt auf Video erschienen wäre, was eine Art Todesurteil gewesen wäre. Aber das ist nicht mehr der Fall. Wenn überhaupt hat Netflix diese Chancengleichheit für Filmemacher geschaffen. Nun also konnten auch die anderen, die kleineren, ran. Die Filmproduktionsfirmen, sogar Dokumentationen abseitiges und so, hat man gedreht. Man hat Bong Joon-Ho einen Film machen lassen. Alice Rohrwacher durfte einen Film drehen. Also das waren wirklich solche Galeonsfiguren des Programmkinos, des Autorenfilms. Doch das Engagement für gutes Filme machen war von kurzer Dauer. Wie beim DVD-Verleih und der Umstellung auf Streaming ging es Netflix eher um die Größe als um das Kino, das es vergrößerte. Filme waren, wie der Gründer gesagt hatte, lediglich Mittel zum Zweck, Abonnenten zu gewinnen, die jeden Monat für den Zugang zur gesamten Netflix-Inhaltsbibliothek bezahlten. Es war bald nur noch das Ziel genug von allem zu haben, dass irgendjemanden anlocken konnte. Es ging nicht mehr darum, einzelne herausragende Produkte zu haben, wie das jetzt zum Beispiel ja noch mit dem Film von Jane Campion oder so der Fall war, sondern es sollte einfach nur die Palette voll gemacht werden, damit er so reichhaltig da ist. Aber es interessierte nicht mehr, herausragende Qualität zu haben. Sie wollen Ausreißer nicht mehr, jetzt hier einer zitiert, sie wollen jemanden, der die richtigen Erwartungen hat. Oh, schau dir diese beiden, also man guckt in so ein Thumbnail. Oh, schau dir diese beiden küssenden Paare an. Einer trägt Schwimmflossen. Das muss eine romantische Komödie sein. Ja. Willst du heute Abend eine romantische Komödie sehen, dann gucken wir die doch. Auch das Dokumentarfilmangebot wurde dann schnell, wie hier steht, zum Supermarktregal voller Boulevard-Zeitschriften. Will Teflin schreibt dann, wie dieser neue Netflix-Film dann aufkommt, eigentlich angepasst wird an 2000 Geschmackskluster, die Netflix herausentwickelt hat und schreibt dann, dieser neue Netflix-Film deckt jede existierende Nischen, Interessen und Identitätskategorien ab, wie zum Beispiel einen Film über ein großes Mädchen, Tall Girl, aber auch Horse Girl, Skater Girl, Sweet Girl, Lost Girls und Nice Girls. Der Titel eines solchen Films ist scheinbar für Suchmaschinen optimiert und kündigt genau an, worum es geht. Daher Titel wie A Perfect Pairing für eine romantische Komödie über einen Weinmanager oder Murder Mystery für einen Krimi. Die Eröffnungssequenz sieht zusammengewürfelt aus, als hätte der Designer von Adobe Vorlagen in After Effects Roulette gespielt. Eine typische Einstellung zeigt zwei Figuren im Profil, die Hüfte hoch, während die Kamera langsam über sie hinwegfährt. Ein langsames konstantes Surren, das Bewegen in eine ansonsten träge Einstellung bringen soll. Es gibt eine Überzahl an Drohnenaufnahmen. Der Dialog der Figuren ist gestelltsvoller, über Erklärung Klischees und Jargon, den kein Mensch jemals verwenden würde, wie zwei Bots, die in einer Schleife stecken. Willst du ein Bier trinken? fragt dein Kumpel, Adam Sandler in Murder Misery. Adam Sandler, ich kann nicht, ich muss noch ein paar Besorgungen machen. Jimmy, was? Du willst kein Bier, was ist los? Ich habe die Ergebnisse der Detektivprüfung erhalten. Jimmy, du hast wieder nicht bestanden, deshalb habe ich den Test nie gemacht. All die Angst und Enttäuschung. Und so geht das dann immer weiter. Die Cutter dieser Filme scheinen auch aufgegeben zu haben. Die Schnitte zwischen den Aufnahmen sind hektisch, Beleuchtung ist schrecklich. CGI wird verwendet, wo es auch nur irgendwo geht. Also es wird dann hier ein Film, der heißt The Kissing Boos genannt, da wird ein Fußball geschossen, man macht das aber mit CGI, man weiß gar nicht warum, man hätte es ja auch mal drehen können. Dazu dann Musik, die jeder kennt, die wird dann nochmal eingespielt. Die Dialoge sehr interessant. Mehrere Drehbuchautoren, die für den Streaming-Anbieter gearbeitet haben, berichten mir, dass ein häufiger Hinweis von Führungskräften des Unternehmens lautet, lassen sie diese Figuren ankündigen, was sie tun, damit die Zuschauer, die diese Sendung im Hintergrund laufen haben, mitverfolgen können. Und ich habe Squid Game, die zweite Staffel jetzt gesehen, und mir ist wirklich aufgefallen, ich glaube, ich hätte mich mit dem Rücken zum Fernseher drehen können und hätte die gesamte Serie nachvollziehen können, wie ein höher Spiel, weil alles gesagt wird. Es wird in dem Sinne nichts mehr gezeigt. Insgesamt gibt es diese Geschmackskasse, es gibt 36.000 Mikrogenres, nach denen Filme so miteinander verbunden werden. Du kennst das ja, wenn dir irgendwas angezeigt wird und du bist verblüfft, was das miteinander zu tun hat. Das liegt dann daran, er schreibt, hier entsteht Kino für die Ohren. Und es ist so, dass man eigentlich nur noch ein Gelegenheitsfernsehen produziert. Und damit komme ich zum Schluss. Es geht nämlich da um diese Statistiken. Wenn immer gesagt wird, dieser Film, dieser Blockbuster bei Netflix, der hat 72 Millionen Haushalte erreicht. Und das ist dann ein Film, von dem wir beide komischerweise, obwohl wir Netflix haben und das hin und wieder gucken und noch nie was gehört haben. Wie kann das sein? Das Erreichen von 72 Millionen Haushalten bedeutet nicht das, wonach es sich anhört. Tatsächlich bedeutet es, dass 72 Millionen Content mindestens zwei Minuten von The Old Guard angesehen haben. Laut Netflix waren zwei Minuten lang genug, um zu zeigen, dass die Auswahl beabsichtigt war. Und damit wird es gezählt. Dann hat man das jetzt geändert. Man zählt jetzt ein bisschen anders. Die Aufrufe von Netflix mögen auf dem Papier beeindruckend sein. Man geht jetzt so mit Minuten und so etwas vor und sagt dann, also da wurde ein Film 6,7 Millionen mal angesehen. Aber das geht dann alles über die Sehstunden. Wie ermittelt sich das aber? Dabei macht Netflix keinen Unterschied zwischen Nutzern, die einen Film bis zum Ende ansehen und denen, die weniger als zwei Minuten schauen und denen, die dank Audio, die dank Autoplay nur ein paar Sekunden sehen, herumspringen und mit 1,5-facher Geschwindigkeit schauen. Alle diese abgelenkten, bruchstückhaften Aktivitäten werden in die Gesamtbetrachtungsdauer eines Films einbezogen, die das Unternehmen dann durch die Laufzeit des Programms dividiert, um dann zum Beispiel auf 6,7 Millionen Aufrufe zu kommen. Für Netflix ist ein Film ein Buchhaltungstrick, eine Pixelmenge, die es dem Unternehmen ermöglicht, immer fantastischere Aussagen über seine Zuschauerzahlen zu machen, um dann zu sagen, hier liebe Investoren, seid weiter dabei. Dieser Film, den die Obamas produziert haben, Leave the World Behind, hast du den gesehen?
Nee.
Ah, siehste? Dann, du scheinst ja der Einzige zu sein, denn der wurde auch angeblich 121 Millionen mal gesehen.
Oh Gott.
Es ist ja also nur noch traurig, man gaukelt den Filmemachern Bedeutsamkeit vor. Die Streaming-Anbieter nicht nur Netflix haben auf dem Weg zu ihren Studios, die sie haben, extra so Werbe, so Billboards aufgestellt, auf denen die neuesten Filme beworben werden. Und dann hat er sich hier mal die Mühe gemacht und hat geguckt, ob sonst irgendwo diese Filme auf Plakaten beworben werden. Nein, nur damit der Regisseur der morgens sein kann, die haben hier schon meinen Film ganz groß plakatiert. Es ist also eigentlich eine Vortäuschung, falsche Tatsachen oder ein Scam. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das jetzt nennen will. Und es gibt dann eine ganz interessante Sache, der Leiter des Filmfestivals von Cannes. Ich bin ja nicht so gegen Streaming generell, wie das dann Cannes der Fall ist oder so. Aber er stellte eine Frage und die finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Welche Regisseure wurden von Streaming-Plattformen entdeckt? Und tatsächlich ist mir auch kein einziger eingefallen. Es waren nur Zukäufe aus irgendwelchen Pools von Leuten, die schon bekannt sind.
Aber ja, das ist das LOL-Prinzip. Amazon kauft einfach alle Fernsehstars der letzten 20 Jahre und macht dann mit den Reisen hier, kochen da, nicht lachen da. Da entsteht nichts Neues.
Eine ganz traurige Entwicklung, ich empfehle dir den sehr, der Artikel ist frei zugänglich, den mal zu lesen.
Traurig ist auch hier, also das Buch von Hoss und Hopf, es heißt jeden Tag einen Schritt oder einen Schritt pro Tag oder irgendwie so.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Wir lesen die Spitzenrezensionen aus Deutschland und zwar einfach von oben nach unten durch, wie sie sich mir gestern darstellten. Du kannst ja, ich lese immer, sag ich mal den Namen, dann die Überschrift und dann so die erste Zeile. Und du, vielleicht fällt dir was auf. Lukas, inspirierende tägliche Begleitung für persönliche Weiterentwicklung. Jeden Tag ein Schritt von Hoss und Hopf ist eine wahre Schatzkiste für alle, die an ihrer Persönlichkeitsentwicklung arbeiten und ihr Leben bewusster gestalten möchten. Ibrahim, inspirierendes Buch für kontinuierlichen Erfolg. Jeden Tag ein Schritt ist ein äußerst motivierendes und praktisch orientiertes Buch. J-Punkt, inspirierende und leicht zu lesen macht dankbar. Das Buch liest sich durch den Aufbau in Kapitel für jeden Tag leicht und flüssig. Inspirierende und praxisnahe Anleitung für persönliches Wachstum. Das Buch Jeden Tag ein Schritt, wie du täglich erfolgreicher wirst von Hoss und Hopf, hat mich von Anfang an gefesselt. J. Sehr authentisch und extrem inspirieren. Ein täglicher Begleiter für persönliche Weiterentwicklung. Hoss und Hopf haben mit jeden Tag einen Schritt, ein Buch geschaffen, das inspiriert und motiviert. Maxime. Inspirierende und praxisnahe Anleitung für persönliches Wachstum. Das Buch, jeden Tag ein Schritt, wie du täglich erfolgreicher wirst von Hoss und Hopf, hat mich von Anfang an gefesselt. The Austrian Reviewer, auch das wie alle anderen ein Wer- Das ist ein sehr effizienter Kauf bei Amazon. Tägliche Inspiration für ein besseres Ich. Das Buch Jeden Tag ein Schritt, wie du täglich erfolgreicher wirst von, dann sind die Namen ausgeschrieben, Kiaras, Hossainpour und Philipp Hopf ist eine wahre Bereicherung für alle, die sich persönlich und beruflich weiterentwickeln möchten. Patrick. Inspirierend, motivierend und alltagstauglich. Jeden Tag ein Schritt ist ein Buch, das nicht nur zum Nachdenken anregt, sondern auch konkrete Ansätze liefert. Blablabla. Eine noch, Patrick. Inspirierender Wegweiser zum täglichen Erfolg. Jeden Tag ein Schritt von den beiden Autoren ist ein wahres Meisterwerk, das mich von der ersten Seite an gefesselt hat. So was fällt uns auf? Erstens, in jeder Überschrift taucht das Wort inspirierend auf, in 90 Prozent als erstes Wort.
Wäre das vielleicht noch was für dein Buch eine Maßnahme? Hättest du gerne ein Aufkleber auf deinem Buch, auf dem steht? Einfach nur inspirierend und dann mein Name drunter. Weißt du, ich liefer dir so ein Blurp. Wolfgang M. Schmitz sagt inspirierend.
Also das sind alles verifizierte Käufe, das sind alles inspirierende und so.
Ja, also die Sache ist doch...
Also wenn der Titel des Buches vorkommt, immer ein Anführungszeichen, immer mit dem Bindestrich oder ein Doppelpunkt, die Autoren werden in der Abkürzung Hoss und Topf durchgehend großgeschrieben. Also wenn mir jemand sagt, dass das echte Leser sind oder nur echte Menschen, die hier wahrhaftige Rezension schreiben, dann ist das irgendwie gelogen. Das heißt noch nicht, dass ich denen was unterstelle. Nur auf eine Bestsellerliste kommt man mit keine Ahnung, 3000 Verkäufe in der ersten Woche. Also eine gute Kampagne mit Signierung hier, Alarm da, Vorabdruck und so weiter, sollte eigentlich irgendwie so 3000 in der ersten Woche hin bedeuten. Wenn ich in Dubai sitze und mich in einem TikTok nach dem anderen dafür abfeiern lasse, dass ich hier noch mal eine Million in Solana investiert habe und die Plattform super geil finde und ich meine Bitcoins verkauft habe und jedes Mal geht es um 100.000 hier, 200.000 da, um mich in der besten Liste einzukaufen, brauche ich sehr viel weniger Geld. So und damit ein Kickstart zu machen für, ich weiß, ich habe ein völlig zerklüftetes, individualisiertes Publikum, jeder kämpft für sich und kriegt plötzlich das Signal, das lesen die jetzt alle, ja dann besteh ich es mir auch. So, also ich will dir nichts unterstellen, aber es ist so augenscheinlich KI-Zeitalter, was wir hier erleben. Das ist einfach, also wir leben ja an dieser Schwelle, in der Menschen, die viel Geld haben, Wege suchen, dieses Geld umzumünzen in wie das...
In der Anerkennung.
Ja, der Anderwood, der Präsident Anderwood hat das ja damals so beschrieben. Sehr viele Menschen haben sehr viel Geld, aber was sie eigentlich wollen ist Macht und so. Wo gibt es Macht? Carol Swisher unterstellt ja Donald Trump die ganze Zeit und das ärgert ihn sicherlich sehr. Der möchte sich eigentlich nur einkaufen in diese Milieu seines Vaters.
Ja.
Wo er verstoßen wurde.
So. Und jetzt hat er diesen mega Erfolg, aber bei einem Publikum, mit dem diese Leute nichts zu tun haben wollen und auch sagen, wir sind zu vielen bereit, aber nicht zu allem. So und Donald Trump jetzt so, ich bin zu allen bereit. Ja, damit hat er halt diesen Erfolg errungen, aber er bringt ihn eigentlich nicht dahin, wo er hin will. Und ich glaube 2025 ist wirklich das letzte Jahr, in dem wir noch mit, ich habe ein Buch geschrieben, eine Bewunderung hervorrufen können. Weil, und das ist auch gut für das Buch, finde ich. Es kommt ab 2025, spätestens nächstes Jahr, drauf an, was in diesem Buch steht. Und ob es überzeugend ist, weil ein Buch kann einfach jeder schreiben. So und das, also ich, wir gucken in das Buch nicht rein. Ja, aber diese Rezension hier, das ist einfach ab so.
Ich hab noch eine andere These dazu. Also es mag sein, dass da generiert wurde. Das klingt mir danach gerade, dass das auch grammatikalisch und automatisch stimmt.
Also es sind keine Rechtschreibfehler drin, in keinem dieser Kommentare.
Deutet sehr darauf hin. Deutet sehr darauf hin. Und dennoch fragt man sich, wie ist das mit den verifizierten Käufern? Also man kann auch das natürlich versuchen zu deichseln über Mittel und Wege. Und wenn man genügend investiert, dann kommt man dahin. Also sicherlich ist es ja so, dass diese beiden jetzt nicht Tantiemen brauchen von Bucheinnahmen. Nee. Also das ist ja einfach Quatsch. Das wird ja jetzt nicht so sein, dass sie sagen, hurra wir haben 50.000 Euro verdient. Die verdienen die ja, wenn man ihnen Glauben schenken darf, auf ganz andere Weise sehr viel schneller. Da ist ja das wirklich ein sehr, sehr langatmiger Weg. Deswegen hast du da, glaube ich, mit dieser Anerkennungssache völlig recht. Was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, dass wir ja dort eine Community haben, die das Buch auch mal kauft, um darin zu plättern. Aber natürlich selbst dieses so locker leicht gestaltete Buch mit vielen weißen Seiten nicht lesen wird. Selbst das ist noch zu viel. Wir haben noch Autoren gehabt, die auch noch die Seiten voll geschrieben haben, aber die auch nicht mehr gelesen wurden, aber gekauft wurden. Das ist zum Beispiel Tilo Sarrazin. Natürlich hat niemand Deutschland schafft, sich abkomplett durchgelesen, außer ein paar Journalisten oder Wissenschaftler. Aber man las die Einleitung und den Schluss und hat sich sonst da als Statement angeschafft.
Das ist Meme-Kultur.
Genau, und es ist eine Statement-Kultur, die hier stattfindet. Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, und das muss gar nicht von denen organisiert sein, sondern irgendwie von ihren Megafans, die sagen passt auf, kauft alle das Buch über Amazon, ihr habt ja alle einen Account. Und hier sind Beispieltexte für Rezensionen. Jeder schreibt eine Rezension, denn wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass Horst und Hopf auf Platz eins der Bestseller-Listen kommt, denn dann ist mal diesem linken Mainstream etwas entgegengesetzt. Also irgendwie so wird die Handlungsanweisungen gelautet haben und dem kommen die jetzt nach. Und da ist dann KI noch dankbar, dass man nicht mal selbst schreiben muss. Das Buch ist inspirierend, weil man dann sich nicht damit rumschlagen muss, wie schreibt man eigentlich inspirierend. Und das ist für die Leute ein Statement, das gesetzt werden kann. Und das ist ein wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr trauriges Signal aus dem Buchmarken.
Ja genau, das ist nämlich insgesamt, also ich unterstelle den beiden gar nichts. Die machen einfach, was sie so machen. Ich will nur sagen, sich in eine Bestenliste einzukaufen ist kein Problem. Es kostet nur Geld. Geld ist für viele Leute kein Problem. Also wenn das Problem ist, in die Bestenliste sich einzukaufen, das kann man einfach machen. Die Frage ist nur, warum? Und diese Antwort ist immer albern. Also alle Wege, die über einen manipulativen Weg in die Bestenliste führen, sind immer albern, weil wir genau wissen, womit sie zu tun haben. Wir haben ja nun ein Buch über die basalen Emotionen und wie man sein Weltverhältnis steuert und den Begriff Limial als und so. Dass man da so Irritationswechselgefüge aus eigenem Gemütszustand, den man dann noch als Vererbungsmasse der Community so anbietet, fühl dich wie ich, wenn du dich verhältst und so wie ich. Also solche Sachen. Das ist einfach ganz armselig, was wir hier sehen. Und ich will jetzt ausdrücklich dazu sagen, ich bin nicht neidisch.
Nee, was ist das für ein Witz?
Für mich kommt es darauf an, dass Abendveranstaltungen stattfinden, wo ich eine spezifische, das ist vielleicht auch eine Botschaft für alle, die mich einladen wollen, eine spezifische Fragestellung, nicht Stefan Schulz einladen, weil man schon immer mal Stefan Schulz vor Ort oder Gott und die Welt und so, sondern spezifische Fragestellung, wo ich weiß, erstens das kann ich vorbereiten, zweitens das ist dann mein Beitrag. So, darum geht's. Und dafür, sage ich ganz ehrlich, das Buch ist jetzt für mich auch nur ein Vehikel dafür. Also klar, es gibt auch dieses Moment des sich mal hinsetzen und das mal durchzuformulieren, weil man dann zu Gedanken kommt, die man ohne Schreiben nicht hätte, also das Schreiben ist schon so der Denkprozess selbst. Dann natürlich das Angebot, dass es so gelesen wird. Aber am Ende geht es doch um dieses die Diskurse, die Debatten, die man damit führt. Wer hat es gelesen, wer schließt wie daran an? Meine Bücher wie so ein Meme-Stalk, als ist meine Anleihe in der Community, ins Regal zu stellen, also das bedeutet mir gar nichts. Mir ist auch jetzt wieder aufgefallen, ich habe selber keine Version von Redaktionsschluss mehr. Ich dachte, ich hatte noch eine, ich finde sie nicht mehr. Ich habe noch eine zu Hause. Siehst du, du hast noch eine. Und es ist mir aber auch nicht wichtig. Also ich werde sie jetzt wahrscheinlich einfach mal einlesen, so das nächste Jahr, ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Zeit. Aber diese Vermiemung und von Community-Risierung abseits aller Inhalte. Also es kann wirklich niemand behaupten, dass das, was hier in diesen Rezensionen steht, stimmt. Nämlich, dass dieses Buch über Seite 30 hinaus inspirierend ist, weil ja was denn auf Seite 178, also der Tag 178 hat nochmal so eine unfassbare Wendung, die man vorher nicht auf 150 Seiten, das ist doch alles absurd.
Im OMR-Podcast hat irgendwann mal Philipp Westermeyer darüber gesprochen, dass er auch ein Buch schreibt und das hat er dann auch gemacht. Das ist also der Moderator dieses Marketing-Podcasts und dann hat er auch gesagt, dass er sich da Mitarbeiter geholt hat, die das mit ihm schreiben, weil man ja nie wieder Anteil ist. Und sein Ziel war es, sich am Ende Spiegel Westseller-Auto nennen zu können. Und ich dachte, warum, wenn man so erfolgreich ist, wie Westermeyer, der verdient ja wirklich gutes Geld, macht da riesen Geschichten mit 70.000 Leuten in Hamburg. Warum muss man sich dann noch Spiegel Westseller-Auto nennen? Warum, wenn man das alles erreicht hat, warum braucht man das? Warum brauche ich diese Anerkennung? Das ist ja genauso, wenn ich jetzt plötzlich einfach, ich muss jetzt also ganz dringend mal einen Doktor-Titel machen, egal wozu, aber ich würde den gern noch vor mir her drangen. Ich werde nie an der Uni lehren, aber ich muss ihn unbedingt noch haben. Nein, das ist eine Qualifikationsschrift, wenn man sie braucht, um akademisch vorzukommen, sollte man es machen, aber wenn man nur irgendwas braucht, was man sich anstecken kann, dann muss man ins Mode-Geschäft, da muss man noch mal gucken, was bietet Lagerfeld an. Und dann kann man sich das anheften, aber Orden und Labels und so weiter, ich glaube, dass ich habe ja auch auf meinem Buch mit Ole zusammen das Spiegel-Bestseller, ein Bildchen da drauf oder was ist das? Ein Aufkleber?
Ja, das drucken die Verklargern mit.
Warum hat man das drauf? Weil es tatsächlich verkaufsfördernd ist. Die Leute glauben, es sei ein Qualitätskriterium, wenn da Spiegel-Bestseller steht, aber es sagt ja nur etwas über den Verkauf. Wir haben gerade von Stefan gehört, der ist gar nicht so hoch, der Verkauf, um diesen Sticker da zu bekommen. Aber es ist wirklich schwachsinnig, nach diesen Orden zu gieren, sondern man muss da einfach sagen, wichtig ist das, was man sagen möchte. Und wichtig ist auch dann, ein paar wirkliche Leser zu finden für diese Sachen. Genau. Und nicht einfach Leute, die sagen, ich kauf das mal und schreib darunter inspirierend. Also ich werde natürlich, wenn das Buch kommt, mach ich eine Insta-Story und schreib inspirierend. Das neue Buch von Stefan Schulz.
Kinderwiese, so inspirierend.
Super. Aber wir wollen nicht nur über inspirierende Bücher sprechen, sondern auch über Musik. Lieben Sie Brahms? Frage ich. Johannes Brahms, der kommt nicht in der Oper vor, sage ich gleich. Da muss man ins Konzert. Zum Beispiel kann man sich die Klavier-Trios anhören. Ich habe eines seiner drei Trios gehört, gespielt vom Trio Sora. Das sind drei junge Musikerinnen, die sich zu einem Trio zusammengeschlossen haben. Und die habe ich einen Tag vor Silvester in der Villa Musica Mainz gehört. Sie kamen da verspätet an. Sie konnten noch pünktlich das Konzert machen, aber sie kam mit der Bahn natürlich schon wieder verspätet aus Paris. Und das hat mir sehr gut gefallen. Daraufhin habe ich mir die Doppel-CD gekauft. Sie haben nämlich alle drei Trios von Brahms eingespielt und auch noch ein Trio für Horn, das etwas umgearbeitet wurde, dann, dass sie das in ihrer Konstellation, also Klavier, Geige und Cello spielen können. Brahms ist ein großer Romantiker, mit dem ich immer wieder meine Schwierigkeiten habe, weil für mich oft die Struktur seiner Werke nicht so klar ist. Dann habe ich mich aber immer wieder jetzt belehren lassen in letzter Zeit, die sagten mir Musiker, nein, nein, Brahms ist eigentlich ganz strukturiert und er rettet eigentlich die Form. Ich erkenne das nicht überall, aber ich genieße immer mehr jetzt diese Musik und bin begeistert von diesen Trios, weil sie mir auch eine gewisse Übersichtigkeit gewähren und ich ein bisschen doch näher komme dem, was Brahms da tut. Es sind Einspielungen, die sehr dynamisch sind, die sehr frisch und jung wirken, wenngleich es doch auch nach 19. Jahrhundert klingt, vielleicht auf einmal ein sehr weiches Klavier gewählt hat. Man spielt nicht auf einem Steinway, sondern einem Bösendorfer. Das ist Geschmackssache. Ich glaube zu Brahms passt das. Es ist jedenfalls neben diesen Fragen jetzt ein interpretatorischer Zugriff, der einen sofort packt. Es sind Stücke, die einen auch nachvollziehen lassen, wie so eine Entwicklung eines Künstlers stattfindet. Also das erste Trio ist wirklich mit einer Melodie so, dass man das gleich beim ersten Mal hören fast mitsingen kann. Zumindest den ersten Satz. Ja, das ist wirklich wunderbar. Es geht zu Herzen und dann wird es aber gleichermaßen komplexer. Es ist nie einfach. Aber wenn man es dann vergleicht, viele Jahre später dann mit dem dritten Streichquartett, das wesentlich kürzer ist, wo auch kaum noch so Übergänge sind zwischen den Themen, wo das alles sehr zusammengefasst ist und auch die Themen sehr, sehr, sehr kurz sind und es auch gar nicht mehr so geht, lange Melodiebögen auszuführen, dann hört man da einen anderen Brahms, der natürlich mit dem Frühjahr noch zu tun hat. Das ist ein Vergnügen, dass man dabei haben kann. Es ist aber auch einfach sehr, sehr schöne, richtig gute Musik, die man nun genießen kann in dieser Einspielung vom Trio Zora.
Dieses Trio hat also diese CD rausgebracht oder zwei CDs sind es, aber man kann es natürlich auch auf den entsprechenden Streaming-Plattformen hören.
Ja, sehr gut. Ich eröffne heute mein, ja doch, Eröffnung. Ich bin in der alten Oper. Ah, es gibt ein Musical.
Was gibt es? Grease. Ah.
Ich mache alles mit.
Du machst alles mit?
Ich mache alles mit. Ich freu mich aufs drauf.
Prima.
Gut, dann habt alle einen schönen Januar, der wird natürlich turbulent. Ja. Schaut euch die Trump-Amtseinführung an. Direkt. Also die ist nicht auf Dunja Hayali erzählt euch, was da ausgelegt, sondern das sollte man mit eigenen Augen sehen, glaube ich.
Ich bin gespannt darauf.
Wir gucken es dann natürlich auch.
Bis dann.